Okay, the board will convene and start with a salute to the flag.
I salute to the flag of the United States of America.
Okay, it's September and we have a new student board member.
And so the first order of business is to swear her in.
So our new board member, Hema Quetzal Cardenez, will please come forward and we'll administer the oath.
Okay, please raise your right hand.
Put that in your left hand.
Okay.
I, state your name.
I, Gemma Quetzal Cardenas.
Do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend the Constitution.
Of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance.
To the Constitution of the United States.
to the Constitution of the United States and the Constitution of the State of California that I take this obligation freely without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter.
and which I'm about to enter.
Congratulations.
You're a member of the State Board of Education.
I think we'll pause for a photo.
Would you like?
Yeah.
OK.
Good.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'll take that back.
All right.
OK, another.
There's a nice fan club here from Oakland Unified, including Superintendent Kyla Johnson Trammell.
So I know they're so proud of him.
Okay, we are now ready for the report of the superintendent.
Thank you, President Kerst and board members.
And wasn't this a nice way to start a day?
Just seeing Hema and her support team and teachers, mom, superintendent, all here to back you up and gives you hope, right?
We're inspired when we see someone like you to be the student voice and an active leader now and in the future.
So again, congratulations.
First, we're back.
Hope you all had great summers.
Fairly smooth opening of school around the state.
We want to let everyone know that schools are open despite the wildfire, widespread wildfire devastation in California.
You remember last year we had at one time 650 schools closed and 300,000 students out of school.
This fire has been bigger in many respects, the Carr fire and the Mendocino fire and others that have raged around the state.
But thank goodness, not as much damage, but hundreds of homes have been lost.
Students lost their homes, everything they had.
Teachers, school board members, the devastation has been widespread.
I want to give a special thanks to Shasta County Superintendent of Schools, Judy Flores.
She and her team took my team, our facilities people, around to look at the devastation in August.
And she ably led efforts to open the schools on time, made sure faculties are safe and serve students and their families, including those who lost their homes.
We also had the tragic loss of lives, including four of our own firefighters.
There is a new fire that just emerged closing down I-5 yesterday.
So the students at Castle Rock Elementary had an unexpected overnight stay at the high school.
They couldn't get back home because the I-5 was closed.
The bus could not take them back home.
So they slept over at I think it was Dunsmuir High School and they're safely back at home reunite with their parents today.
I met terrific teachers and dedicated administrators all working together.
They work non-stop to get the schools up and running.
I was heartened to see humanity at its best with neighbors helping neighbors and schools collaborating to ensure students were able to attend their first day back.
One example is a school named Ego Ono took in 60, 70 students from another school that couldn't get reopened.
Shasta Elementary Union District couldn't reopen.
So they just combined on one campus and they're working so well together again on behalf of the students.
My CDE team comprised of Deborah Brown, Juan Morales, Marguerite Reese, and Leslie Taylor have been working closely with Judy and all the other county superintendents affected by the fires on the recovery and the cleanup and connecting them with resources for assisting in the recovery.
Applying to FEMA and keeping records, applying for other aid for recovery.
Last year, you recall,
applied and received about $14 million including $2 million for mental health to deal with the trauma that these students and their teachers are going through.
So that is underway.
Just one note in the midst of it all, we visited one classroom where the firefighters had to chop their way through the roof to get in to see if there was fire going on in that particular wing of the school.
And when you enter the classroom, it was dusty and smoky, but there was a big sign on the whiteboard, sorry.
To leave such a mess, we had to save your school.
So the firefighters from Butte County wrote a message.
They were sorry to make a mess, but they had to save the school.
And it's true that law enforcement and firefighters bravely worked together in the emergency to save lives and save schools.
Computer science standards.
Just later today, you're going to receive, this is a very happy day for all board members, especially Trish Williams.
It's a good happy day for California.
But the computer science standards following we have the legislature declaring September of this year as California Computer Science Education Month.
And again, I want to congratulate all those who worked on the creation of the computer science standards for public schools, and in particular, CTE staff, Stephanie Grayson and Cliff Rednick and Renee Ostley Swank for their outstanding leadership.
And of course, our superhero superstar here, Trish Williams, did an incredible job.
So I know we're going to hear more and just your leadership and tenacity have been much appreciated.
It's a milestone.
Career technical education, just wanted to give a quick report.
You'll get a more detailed report later today.
You'll hear more about the progress that we're making with the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
This collaborative effort has worked to provide ongoing funding to create, expand, and improve our CTE programs, including the Strong Workforce Program.
The 2018 budget appropriates $314 million in ongoing funding for K-12 career education.
And I want to say we've seen great results around the state from the earlier investments in terms of graduation rates going up and student attendance and students' interest in staying in school when they do hands-on career tech kinds of courses and pathways.
And I want to thank Donna Wyatt and her team, and you'll hear from them later today, for their leadership in bringing about these important milestones of progress.
I created a Charter Schools Action Team over the last couple of months.
In August, I pulled together leaders, thought leaders, involved experienced parties to help.
This terrific team will
review laws governing charter schools and provide advisory recommendations to the next state superintendent, governor, and state board of education and legislature.
The California Charter School Act was enacted 26 years ago, but has had few changes or comprehensive review since then.
Team members represent a variety of organizations and perspectives, including philanthropists, charter schools themselves, teachers, parents, and administrators.
This team is being co-chaired by Action Team members Carl Cohn, our own former board member and CCEE leader, and Susan Bonilla, representing the Council for a Strong America.
The Charter School Action Team will make recommendations in early December, and we welcome any input from any board member or any group that you're working with in that process.
Healthy Kids Survey.
I hope everyone will review the results of this year, the latest California Healthy Kids Survey.
The CDE, our department, and the California Department of Health Care Services coordinated the statewide service.
And as you know, the survey assesses how well schools are meeting students' needs for school safety, drug and alcohol prevention, mental health, and other factors that influence learning and positive development.
The survey shows that alcohol, tobacco, and other drug use continues to decline among middle and high school students.
That is good news.
And improvements have occurred in pupil engagement, school climate, and mental health.
In my last report to you, I shared with you the great need to secure funding to address the mental health needs of students throughout the state.
Everything from depression to suicide, we have
major needs and not enough services.
I wanted to mention that the legislature passed four bills that are going to help us in suicide prevention and in getting more mental health dollars focused.
And I formed a mental health task force which is working on an action plan to be ready by mid-November to be part to form a core for a legislative and budget package next year to invest more money in mental health.
We have hundreds of millions of dollars of Prop 63 money that counties have been holding on to in reserve accounts and in interest accounts.
And we're working with the Prop 63 Commission to free that money, to target that money and get it to work with the services and with the professional development training our teachers need to help students who have mental health needs.
I'll only mention briefly, but point to your packet.
Global 2030 is an initiative I started indicating, underscoring, emphasizing that it's important to know more than one language.
And as you travel around the world, other countries, it's just standard to know two languages and often three.
And so I have a column I wrote on the values of
bilingual education, including everything from brain development to just being able to excel academically in all subjects.
And that is in your packet.
I just got back from China, where I was working with education officials there.
We were wanting to create a dual immersion Mandarin program, a large one in California.
And they were willing to recruit the teachers, help identify the teachers who would come here and be with us for a year or two or three years under certain visas to help with the Mandarin Dual Immersion programs.
So the teacher exchange is exciting progress.
We had a lot of updates, didn't we?
It's been a long month, but I wanted to just say, again, congratulations to Hema, Cardenas, and all of us.
We have some good work to do here together.
Thank you very much.
Okay, I wanted to start with giving the board members a little background on our new member, Hema Ketsalakardanes.
She has been and is a senior at the Life Academy of Health and Bioscience in the Oakland Unified School District.
And she has done a great deal in the Oakland Unified District in terms of different activities.
She's been co-founder of the Life Academy Student Leadership since 2016.
She's been an intern for the Student Engagement Office at the Oakland Unified School District.
She has been Health and Wellness Director of the Oakland Unified School District All-City Council Student Union.
and its vice president before that.
And she's been a student representative on the Oakland School Board and a student representative for the Oakland Sanctuary District Task Force and ambassador for the Oakland Promise.
So please welcome Hema to the board.
Good.
I have some other announcements before we begin with item one.
The annual fall recruitment is underway for us on terms of our state board commissions for the 2019 and beyond.
We need a student board member and so we need people to apply for that.
We need the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools to replace some of those members.
The California Practitioners Advisory Group, we also need to replace some of those members.
We have three positions on the Instructional Quality Commission that we're seeking applications for.
And we're also looking, as I indicated earlier, for the student board member as well.
We have seven public hearings on our September agenda.
Items four, five, and six will be heard this afternoon.
And items 15, 16, 17, and 18 will be heard on Friday.
We also then, I wanted to mention that we have consent calendars.
And there's a handout on the table in the lobby listing the regular consent items.
Those are items 11 through 14.
We also have on consent at this point all our waiver items, waiver 1 through 17.
Board members who wish to remove some of these from consent or waiver consent, please notify the executive director.
And do that by 12 o'clock tomorrow, Thursday.
We have... Pardon?
Okay, 11 o'clock Thursday today.
Yeah, I keep thinking Wednesday, you know, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday.
I can't get used to this.
Okay, I want to say that you have your electronic file, red file, and for letters from the outside.
And we have an electronic agenda and one agenda of ours printed in lobby.
If you want to give anything to the board and your member of the audience, provide at least 25 copies.
And when you speak before the board, please introduce yourself and the organization or whoever you may represent yourself perhaps prior to speaking.
We look for brevity and you need to recuse, board members need to recuse themselves if they must do so before any discussion on the item begins and we have some recusals.
Okay, we're now ready for item one and this is a multi-pronged item that Cindy Gazanis will present.
And so I'm going to ask the board for clarifying questions after each of the sub items.
And then we'll have public comment on the whole batch of the items after that.
So, Cindy, you may begin.
Good morning, members of the board and welcome to our new student board member.
My name is Cindy Kazanis.
I'm the director of the assessment.
Excuse me.
Not the assessment.
Whoa.
I've already forgotten.
Of our accountability division, it's a pleasure to speak with you today and to present this item.
I will be joined at the podium by Jenny Singh to break up the item.
It is a very long item.
It's very technical in nature.
So with that, I will
Just wanted to introduce the attachments that will be covered in today's presentation.
We will be talking first about the new measures for inclusion in the College Career Indicator, the proposed methodology for calculating chronic absenteeism indicator, proposed cut scores for our one-year graduation rate, and how to incorporate the five-year graduation rate into the dashboard for reporting purposes.
And then you're going to get a preview of the redesigned California School Dashboard.
So we're very excited for the conclusion of this presentation because we have been spending our summer working on this.
I'm getting a little bit of echo.
Do you hear that as well?
OK.
All right.
So the recommendation for the item is that the department recommends that the State Board of Education approve, first, the inclusion of a state syllabi literacy, Golden State Seal merit diploma, and leadership military science, also known as the Reserve Officer Training Corps, or JROTC.
as additional measures in the College Career Indicator.
The second is the methodology for the Chronic Absenteeism Indicator.
And the third, the proposed cut scores for the Dashboard Alternative School Status, one-year graduation rate.
And finally, fourth, the reporting of the five-year graduation rate in the California School Dashboard.
But before I go into the item, I just wanted to give you a preview of what's going to be on your plate for two months from now.
So in November of 2018, you will be asked to look at several of the items because we now have the end of year data from all school districts.
We've been working with it for about a week.
So we will be very busy over the next two months as well to make sure that these items are ready for your review and that we get the appropriate stakeholder feedback for each of these pieces.
So the academic indicator, we're going to bring back status and change cuts.
Actually, for the first time, you're going to see status and change cut scores for grade 11.
For college career indicator, you'll look at change cut scores for the first time and approve those.
Chronic absenteeism, status and change cut scores.
Again, this is the first time you'll be seeing those.
And for graduation rate indicator, we're looking at revising the status cut scores for the four-year adjusted cohort and revised criteria for the one-year graduation rate for alternative schools.
And in particular, I wanted to note publicly that the department intends to recommend an action that you approved in July
that we actually take out one of the measures of the one-year graduation rate.
We have been in contact through this entire process and we have worked very closely with our special education division and following your decision, additional concerns were brought to light about the validity and reliability on a statewide basis of this measure.
So we are prepared to recommend in November, we want to make sure that we get stakeholder feedback on this of course, but the removal of that measure.
Finally, we will be reviewing with you and asking for you to review rather and adopt criteria for determining LEA eligibility for differentiated assistance and intensive intervention.
Specifically with the adoption of the college career indicator, we now need to end the adoption of the broad course of study local indicator for priority 7.
There may be a need to remove that from priority 7.
You had it as priority 7 and priority 8.
So we will again be working over the next two months to get stakeholder feedback on each of these measures.
I also wanted to mention something you don't see, but it actually involves quite a bit of staff time, is that bringing our alternative schools into the accountability system requires us to redo all of our programming.
And we knew that was coming, but I just wanted to offer a bit of, you know, a bit of what it requires to put out this dashboard.
So again, we've had this data approximately a week and we are all hands on deck to get a public release out for December.
So we're going to start with attachment one.
This is an indicator that you have seen now for the last two years.
And the measures that you're seeing today are things that we have been talking about for, I would say, at least two years, if not longer.
So I only provided you
four bullets on things that you had seen previously.
I think the list is actually longer than that, maybe closer to eight to ten.
The College Career Indicator has been extensively discussed, whether it's through memos or through the item, the agenda item process.
But of note, I would say in February 2018, we did do an extensive
review of the timeline and also how to include additional measures and sort of looked at the validity and reliability of this indicator as well.
And just a reminder, back in February, I think it's important to talk about what's the purpose.
So the purpose of this indicator was to emphasize that a high school diploma represents the completion of a broad and rigorous course of study that prepares students for success after high school.
We're looking at the four-year cohort.
So we're looking at specific criteria that are relying on tests and course completion.
Determine if a student is prepared, approaching prepared, and not prepared.
We're also wanting to make sure that this measure, as you heard from San Juan Unified back in May, how they're doing to help use this data to prepare their students for success after high school.
They told you back then that there were gaps, and so they are using this data to see how they can enhance their program to make sure that students are not only college but career ready.
So the other thing I wanted to talk first about too is how this model is actually implemented.
And keep in mind this is not, unlike other things that we're going to be talking about today, this is not on an individual student record.
This is a reflection of a school and district's performance.
So the information is not available at the student level, even though we talk about how students meet the prepared categories.
We are restricted to data elements that we collect through our student level data system.
So you'll see a slide in just a bit about what that exactly means.
And then the measures we are using need to be evaluated.
Our determination of validity and reliability and rigor is using the grade 11 summative assessment.
So there's a very strong dependency on our assessments or measures in the College Career Indicator.
And then I think finally, it's not the intent that every single high school in the state needs to implement all the measures that are listed in the College Career Indicator, but that credit rather should be given for the successful implementation of existing programs.
And so as you saw in San Juan, they had strong programs in certain areas, in certain schools, and they're now looking district-wide to see how those could be replicated and make sure that, again, all students have access to
to those programs.
You have a copy of this, a color copy of this, in your basket, and this has of course been on the department's website now for about a year.
This flyer is a one-page document that is also translated into Spanish.
Probably our top other languages, I forget which ones get translated through everything, but this is definitely translated into Spanish.
And this has been used to really describe, I think, just at a glance, how measures have come into the CCI.
So if we start with prepared, and we look at those little logos on the left-hand side, the ones with the pencil and a bubble above it is using an assessment requirement.
Those with a book is using a coursework requirement.
The top four items are items that we consider to be standalone items.
The final two, which are A through G requirements and career technical pathway,
need to have an additional criteria and that's the white box below.
So the measures that have been included for Sandiland measures are of course the Smarter Balanced Summative Assessment, Advanced Placement, International Baccalaureate, and Completion of Dual Enrollment.
The last three are of course
vetted out those, especially the AP exams and the IB exams are things that are vetted through a full valid and reliability process system by, of course, these external organizations.
The completion of dual enrollment as well, you know, they're looking at something that is considered college level course.
So with IB and AP, you can potentially get college credit for those courses as well.
So what the College Career Indicator is really meant to do is to show the cumulative achievement over a four-year period of a student's and then what a school is offering.
It's meant to demonstrate, again, a rigorous and broad course of study.
This is information that has been included in not only the agenda item, but the information memorandum.
And for me, I felt like it was a little easier to see it in a visual format.
So what you can see is that we have four measures that were proposed.
One measure we're actually recommending not including, that is the last measure.
But the first three measures I'm gonna talk about in depth.
And I think it's important to note that while, for example, the state syllabi literacy was implemented, I think, back in 2012, we only began collecting data in 2017 at the student level.
And what we collect for that data, as well as Golden State Merit Diploma, as well as A through G, is simply did you complete
the requirements.
We don't ask you how you completed the requirements, we simply ask you if you completed the requirements.
So we don't have the ability to dig into the records to see, you know, did the student do each of the course requirements for this Golden State SEAL and pass with the particular grade.
So there is room for, you know, interpretation at the local level and
potential error, and you're going to see that in some of the slides, but that is the limitation.
So we're doing the best we can with this data, and I have to tell you in order to get that state bill, syllabi literacy into this system, it was actually, you know, we had competing interests at that time.
So to get just a yes or no programmed into the statewide data system is actually quite a big deal.
And we are so excited to have not only that, but the merit diploma collected and available at the student level for us to use for this purpose, looking at the college career indicator and how it can be incorporated.
For the leadership military science, this is something that has been brought up time and time again with the CCI work group.
We've been collecting this data actually for quite a bit of time and member Holliday brought up that we were calling it ROTC and at the high school level it's actually JROTC.
So we've tried to correct that where we can but in the recommendation the error remains.
And that just as similar to the articulated career technical education courses, those are done through the course section completion records in CALPADS.
So just as a reminder, how we conduct our analysis to make sure that these measures meet the validity and the reliability test is we're looking against Smarter Balanced summative assessments.
We use that to help us inform and place measurements across the three college career indicator levels, prepared, approaching prepared, and not prepared.
And so as an example, we're looking at how do the students who earn the state syllabi literacy perform on the summative assessments versus those who did not earn the state syllabi literacy.
So we always get that comparison and that's what you've asked us to do to make sure that we've done a thorough analysis.
So as an overview for each of the measures, the first column you can see the measure name, and then you can see the number of students who were awarded the measure, those that did not in the cohort, and then what the total cohort size was.
Of course, it's the same for all the measures, the total cohort size.
But you can see far and beyond is that the largest amount of student group that, or rather the largest
population of students who earned one of these measures was the Golden State Seal, which is almost 20%, 19.4%.
The next were the articulated course and then followed by the syllabi literacy and then the smallest with our JROTC.
So I'm going to move into the first piece, and I believe after I present this piece, I can pause for technical questions.
So the syllabi literacy is offered to students who demonstrate proficiency in speaking, reading, and writing in at least one or more languages in addition to English.
There are some minimum requirements in terms of this.
the SBAC summative, which I will describe as we get through the next slides.
We are proposing that this measure be for both career and college.
And of course, recalling our conversation about two years ago, when you asked us to remove the well-prepared category because we didn't have enough career measures, I think it's really important to point out in each of these elements that we're adding, which of them are career and college and which of them are either college as a standalone or career as a standalone.
So the red box here on the right hand side are the current requirements, rather the requirements under the state syllabi literacy that students must meet.
So the students must score at least standard met on the grade 11 summative assessment in English language arts.
So you see there are students that were also in the categories of earning the state syllabi literacy that had standard not met and standard nearly met.
You can also see as a comparison, as I mentioned, this is our data analysis, we're comparing against those that did not earn a state syllabi literacy.
So you definitely have stronger performance by those that have earned a state syllabi literacy in assessments overall for English language arts.
This next slide is the mathematics piece.
So while there is not a requirement in the state syllabi literacy, the proposal today is that students must receive at least math on the math portion of the summative assessment standard nearly met.
But looking at it, again, compared to students who earned the state syllabi literacy versus those that did not, you still see stronger, especially in those two latter categories, standard met and standard exceeded, students that have earned the state syllabi literacy doing far better than their peers.
I think that's really important to note.
So just briefly just to mention, there were some students who earned a state syllabi literacy.
They were, as we mentioned on the previous slide, they needed to score at least standard met.
We saw it roughly a little over
close to 2,000 students who earned a state syllabi literacy that did not meet that minimum threshold for the Smarter Balanced standard met.
So those are schools and districts that we will follow up with to remind them of the criteria.
But again, we only collect yes or no for each of those students on whether or not they met the requirements of the state syllabi literacy.
There are actually four different requirements that you have to meet in order to receive the state syllabi literacy.
We also see that the state syllabus was awarded to students who earned, as I just mentioned, standard nearly met and standard not met.
And then finally, we did have a small number of students who did not test at all.
So those were removed from the cohort.
So this is the proposal that we are recommending to you today, that in order to be in the prepared level, the student that earns a state sealed by literacy should, of course, score at least the standard met on English language arts.
And then we're proposing additional criteria that they score at least standard nearly met on mathematics.
This would result in 35,982 students in the class of 2017 meeting the criteria.
This would also represent of those who earned the state syllabi literacy, 86% of those students would be considered at the prepared level.
We also received feedback actually at the California Practitioners Advisory Group that we should think about adding approaching prepared level.
So the suggestion was to remove the mathematics requirement and simply leave it as is with the
just the standard amount on English language arts, which is of course a requirement of the state seal of biliteracy.
The stakeholders that we obviously had a lot of stakeholder input on this issue over the last several months, first with the College Career Indicator Workgroup who met in May and
felt strongly about the prepared level and what you see today as the recommendation.
This was discussed at length with the California Practitioners Advisory Group.
And as I mentioned, they had the suggestion about approaching prepared.
There was one member on the dais who did not agree with the mathematics requirement.
So that was expressed as well.
And then we did run this by the Technical Advisory Group who concurred with the recommendation and then finally shared it with the LCFF Stakeholder Work Group.
who is made up of education and equity advocates.
And there wasn't a lot of discussion about this particular issue at that meeting.
So with that, I'm happy to turn it over to President Kirst for technical questions on this measure.
Well, thank you for that description.
Board member questions on this at this point?
Board member Bruce, go ahead.
for holiday thanks mike
Thanks for correcting the JROTC, although I think it was in one of the first slides you have here, you still had ROTC instead of JROTC.
I think it was in the recommendation, yeah.
I'm a fan of having this be a part of the College and Career Readiness Indicator, but there are a number of different flavors of leadership military science that exist in the state of California in different schools right now.
And if this is... Are you going to talk about this later?
Oh, I'm sorry.
We're doing biliteracy first.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
I do have data for the JROTC.
Each of these are so complex in themselves that... I'm sorry.
I jumped the gun.
I hear you.
I'll be back.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
I agree with CPAC.
I don't understand why we're adding mathematics to the syllabi literacy.
When you mentioned the criteria, there was one bullet point, but there is actually, unless I'm mistaken, there is a GPA requirement to earn the syllabi literacy.
There is multiple criteria already that must be met.
And so I was reading a letter from LPI and I want to read, if I could find it, I want to read one of their quotes from their letter where it urges us to really think about the application of mathematics in a more consistent way across the CCI indicators so that we don't signal out a particular racial or linguistic group.
And I am scared that we are moving in that direction by adding an added layer of rigor to this indicator of the CCI versus others.
If we want to move later to well prepared, I think that would maybe an appropriate time, but it would also have to be consistent because it hasn't been consistent the use of mathematics.
So I would agree with CPAC that we should remove it.
Can you comment on the consistent point?
I mean, we've had an additional requirement for other indicators.
So I'd like you to clarify that and that this is not something that is required to get the seal of bioliteracy per se.
Sure.
Now that you've indicated that there are other criteria, the slide was getting very word heavy.
So there is a handout that we provided to the California Petitions Advisory Group, but I know that we've referenced this criteria before.
just so everybody's on the same page when I read it out loud.
The student must demonstrate completion of all English language arts requirements for graduation with an overall grade point average of 2.0 in those classes.
Passing this California assessment of student performance and progress for English language arts or any successor test administrated in grade 11 at or above the standard met achievement level or the achievement level determined by the superintendent for any successor test.
Third, proficiency in one of our languages other than English demonstrated through one of the following methods.
A, passing a foreign language advanced placement examination with a score of three or higher or an international baccalaureate examination with a score of four or more.
B, successful completion of a four-year high school course of study in a foreign language attaining an overall grade point average of 3.0 or higher in that course of study.
and demonstrating oral proficiency in a language comparable to that which is required to pass an AP or IB.
C, passing a district test with a score of proficient or higher.
This is, again, if no AP examination off the shelf exists.
And then D, passing the SAT II foreign language exam with a score of 600 or higher.
And finally, in addition to the requirements mentioned above, if the primary language of a pupil is other than English, he or she shall demonstrate English language, English proficiency on the ELPAC, the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California or any successor assessment.
And to go back to, again, the data analysis, I would
Probably the best slide to walk through this, unfortunately, is this one, which is somewhat hard to read.
Looking at what we have considered standalone in the past in terms of prepared.
The items that are standalone are Smarter Violence Assessments with a score of 3 or higher on both ELA and Mathematics.
Advanced Placement with a score of 3 or higher on two AP exams.
And while we don't specify in the AP exams or the IB exams that it needs to be in Mathematics or English Language Arts,
We definitely made a conscientious decision and ran this by the technical advisory group and stakeholders that we weren't going to allow just one exam to indicate that you were prepared.
It needed to be two.
That was the threshold that we had evaluated that we felt met the rigor.
And then finally, the dual enrollment piece.
So again, you're looking at that higher level of preparing students for college and career.
And I empathize with the point that is being made, but if we're recommending this for college and career, you need to at least have a minimum amount of math knowledge to be eligible to go to college.
or to be successful in college, I would say.
So scoring a level two on the mathematics exam is the way that we have suggested that the board move.
And with 86% of the students who've earned the SEAL being eligible with that criteria, that's how we came up with our recommendation.
Yeah, but we're not singling out this measure for, you know, an additional thing.
It's woven throughout the other measures.
That's correct.
So, you're right.
Some view that we're, you know, picking this measure and putting extra things on that aren't on other measures.
Well, so I think I should have followed up with the last two pieces.
That is a great point, because the A through G requirements we know from multiple studies that just by completing those alone doesn't mean you're going to be successful in college.
In fact, a large number of students need to take remedial education, as we know from Professor Kurlander's work.
So we have said that that cannot be a standalone measure to show you're prepared.
They need to show additional criteria.
So additional criteria are one of three options.
again, looking at Smarter Balance results, looking at whether or not they've completed dual enrollment, and then finally, if they scored the three or higher on the AP.
The other measure that I would consider it to be similar to is the Career Technical Education Pathway.
And again, as a standalone, we didn't feel that it was appropriate, wasn't rigorous enough, and needed that additional criteria.
So this meets the same, where I would say this follows into the same requirements as the A through G requirements and the CTE requirements.
Okay.
Board member Rucker.
So, let me begin by saying I have some concerns about this requirement as it relates to specifically the state seal of biliteracy.
I was at the CPAG meeting and I was at, if my memory serves, I believe I was the only board member
who was present for that.
Oh, okay.
So I'm concerned that, I'm concerned because I'm a little confused.
While this is, the CCI is in the architecture of what I thought we were putting together.
This was supposed to give us a composite picture of what LEAs are doing across the spectrum of their programs, both academic and career programs.
to offer access to students to create this definition of readiness for college or to enter the workforce when they leave these high schools.
And so these metrics, however, are beginning to take on an outsized impact on defining that has an impact on students individually.
The change that's being proposed in particular on this state seal of biliteracy is going to have an impact on students who will graduate next spring who made a multi-year commitment when they entered high school to do the work and be on the pathway to earn this certification.
adding this criteria or looking at this criteria in the aggregate, which is what you want us to consider, changes what this, what attaining this state syllabi literacy will mean in particular for the students who are going to graduate in the spring because
They started with that program.
They contracted with their high schools and their counselors for what work they had to do to complete this program based on what they understood this criteria would mean.
And suddenly, they won't count.
And none of the work that they have done is going to count.
If we're taught, I think that there's two things that are operating at cross purposes here.
What our definition and intent is and defining by literacy and recognizing that accomplishment for students and what we are trying to do in monitoring and reporting what districts are doing and creating access for college and career readiness in the course of study and the access in the master schedule that students should have.
And I think that there's a conflict here that's occurring, particularly for this upcoming graduating class, that's unanticipated.
We see that difference in the statistics you've already given us in this chart in showing that there were districts who made a local decision to award the state seal based on far more narrower criteria focused solely on
English language literacy and not necessarily considering the math.
So I have a concern that even though it's a small number, as you point out, of students who would not be considered and would not be awarded and would not be reported.
I just need to say, even if it's just one for that one student, that's an important and significant change that tells them what they've done for their high school career,
really and truly didn't amount to what was promised to them.
So there has to be something done.
I don't believe this conflict is going to go away for this single year because of this single year.
I believe that's a conflict we're going to have in looking at the application of this criteria for these two very distinct elements from year to year going forward.
But it is very clear and very apparent for this year that is definitely going to happen to this graduating cohort.
And I think we need to hold ourselves accountable for what that's going to mean.
Again, I'm wondering if we're confusing what the individual student gets with a career and college indicator.
And I don't think we're affecting at all what the individual student gets.
Maybe you can answer it.
Maybe board members can clarify it.
But this has been bedeviled this argument all along that we're confusing students with an indicator.
So there are no additional elements being added to the state Zillow bi-literacy.
I understand that.
What we are suggesting is in order to demonstrate that a student, for the purposes of being in the accountability system, which of course is a reflection of the school and the district, non-individual student, is that there is a demonstration of scoring at least a level two on the mathematics piece of the SBAC.
Okay, so let me be clear.
I am not confused about the difference between how a student or the criteria for how a student would earn the state seal and what it is an LEA reports.
What I am saying is that because there is a difference, there's this added criteria for what the LEA reports.
I am saying it's going to inform the decisions the LEA makes
in their individual relationship with those individual students.
That is a conflict that we are going, I'm saying that there is a clear conflict between the accountability requirements for reporting and what LEAs are supposed to be making sure they appropriately counsel their students to do.
What I am saying is that we need to hold ourselves accountable for making sure that difference is not something students end up being penalized for.
I'm not confused about what the requirements are.
I am saying there are a lot of people who are in charge of education who don't read and follow those same directions and we need to be careful about that because I am certain there will be students who will be affected if we're not clear.
Board Member Strauss is next.
So first, Cindy, I want to thank you and your team that has been working so hard on the analysis.
And I know that we have a lot of details that we still need to flesh out.
And first, I want to say, I think this chart is actually more helpful with the assessment and coursework code.
That was kind of a nice piece that you guys added there anyway.
So just appreciate that and look forward to working more on the column that we have not
added yet in the future.
So with that, I want to talk about the seal of biliteracy.
And I appreciate you sharing with us all the requirements for getting the seal.
And my understanding is if students do all those things that you read, they will get the seal.
My question is, where did we decide?
Was it staff that decided to add a math requirement in order
for it to be included in CCI.
So that's one question.
And two, let me just say, I do think math skills going forward is a lifelong skill.
We know it's a gateway and a gatekeeper to future success, college completion, income for your life, all kinds of things.
So I'm totally supportive of us needing to want students to be at least approaching preparatory math.
But I just wonder, where was the decision made to propose putting math
added to CL by Literacy in order to get counted in the CCI?
That's my first question.
I have a few more, so I'm not... Do you want to take them one at a time?
Yeah, do that part first.
So that decision was made by the CCI work group.
They felt very strongly that math was an important indicator for success after high school, so they added that criteria in.
So Jenny, just thank you for clearing that.
But we didn't add that for other, like, so if you get an A to G, did we say you also have to be approaching prepared in math?
Is math, so where else is math added into other indicators that go into CCI?
Let's clarify that.
So it is added in A through G and it's added in through the CTE pathway completers.
So in the CTE, A to G, and bilingual literacy, you're recommending that they have to have at least approaching prepared in order to be counted as college and career ready.
Correct.
Okay.
And then the feedback from CPAG, and I do have on my notes and I was there for that discussion, there was some concern and some, not a hundred percent, but some requests to pull it out.
So how did you all decide to take, that's our advisory commission on accountability.
We have a really committed group of people, five superintendents, county and school district teachers, leaders, principals.
It's a wonderful group of people who really are committed.
How did we decide to discount that pushback?
We did not discount the pushback.
Let me state that very clearly.
We took their advice to heart.
We revisited the fact that we didn't have a proposal prepared and added that.
I will say one thing about the California Practitioners Advisory Group.
They do not vote on any matters.
That's right.
There is no vote.
There is simply a sharing out of individual members.
So we are never able to say with confidence that the CPAG as a whole said this because it is made up of individual members who have individual opinions.
There's not been a vote to my knowledge since it was incorporated.
We also talked to staff internally and with state board staff and ultimately this is a recommendation from the superintendent to the board.
I'm sure they're, you know, ultimately it's a policy decision from this board about how you want to proceed.
This is a very complex indicator.
There are multiple ways to arrive at prepared and I understand Member Rucker's point about unintended consequences and
We are seeing that with other measures in the accountability system.
If it's not in there or if it doesn't exist, then it doesn't count.
Or maybe it's pushing policy in a different direction.
That's not the purpose of the accountability system.
It's to talk about what is currently happening in the system and show where things are doing really well and show where there are improvements that are needed.
And so we are getting to the point where at maturity in which the tension is now
been building.
And in this particular measure, I know that this has been very difficult to proceed with.
There's a lot of decision points and this is now going to be high stakes with a color added this fall.
So my understanding, first of all, I appreciate you reading all the things a student has to do to get the seal of biliteracy.
It's an important life skill, as Superintendent Torlakson said in his
opening comments, and I think those of us who recognize the diversity of California and the world recognize what that takes and also that what a great preparation for life going forward.
That being said, my understanding from your chart on your slide was
that of the students who do all of those criteria, they get the seal of biliteracy.
And those that are now going to be excluded from under this proposal for the college and career indicator would be 9.7 percent, am I right, of students who earn the seal of biliteracy, but did not meet at least nearly met in math, would then that those students and then those
those LEAs would not get credit for almost 10% of the kids who got the sealed by literacy.
They wouldn't be considered college and career.
They wouldn't get credit for that under this proposal.
Is that the way I understand it?
It would not meet the prepared category as it is currently recommended in this proposal so that
That's correct.
But they would be reported as approaching prepared if that is the only measure that they meet.
You know, we see overall these students are doing quite well.
It is likely that they would meet another measure as prepared.
Who's next?
Board Member Sung.
So I'm going to have a kind of a opposite conversation regarding the state's sealed merit diploma for the next item.
But what I wanted to talk a little bit about is just what I'm hearing from the conversation is that we have some holes in the architecture of the CCI.
And we need some clarification here because originally we said this was a college and career indicator.
Then I've heard that it's college or career.
So the measures that go in are college or career.
And then this particular measure that you're proposing is college and career.
So I can see the argument for adding the academic pieces of it.
perhaps, but then when we're looking at some other measures, we're not adding, as in the Golden Seal state merit, we're not adding additional criteria.
And I feel the criteria for Golden State Seal is much lower than the criteria for getting a
seal it by literacy.
So I'm not quite sure how some of the decisions and some of the recommendations are coming in.
So I do have concerns about how we're defining this indicator.
Is it college and career?
Is it this amalgamation?
And the pieces that go in there, does that make any sense?
And then the other concern that I have,
is around our data collection overall.
We've got current measures in this indicator that we haven't fully flushed out yet.
And like an example is the completion of dual enrollment.
right now to get that information into CALPADS is extremely technically difficult for us to do and we haven't collected that data well enough to be included in here.
So we've got a lot of work on each of these measures and the quality of these measures, what goes in, looking at the validity and reliability.
I'm afraid that if we keep adding these things, adding these measures into this indicator and
what we put in isn't really clean, it's going to just be a bunch of noise.
It's just not really going to give us the information that we really need on an accountability system.
So that's my kind of overall piece of it.
And as we talk about these individual measures, we're considering to add into it
I want to make sure that we're very clear on what we're doing before we approve to get these in because we're going to be working.
When we add the well-prepared, we're just going to be working on sand.
So I feel like we need to get some of these measures that we've got in there already more solid.
Okay, next.
Board Member Valdez.
So first of all, thank you for the work that you're doing and I love infographics and these kinds of things and then the additional criteria key really is very, very helpful.
So I thank you for that.
A couple things.
I agree with board member Ting when she talks about the and or the or and the rigor or the expectation.
If math is important, I feel like it should transcend all of them.
not some of them.
If we look at, for example, dual enrollment, you could have a child who doesn't take a math course for dual enrollment.
They could take English and they could take History, and they would never take a math, but yet they're meeting, and I think as I'm reading it, prepared is just one thing on there.
It would be considered prepared.
So, I just have a concern that we're asking rigor on one item and we're not asking it for the others.
So, I think we should be all in or and not.
So, thank you.
All right.
We've had two comments of this type.
Can you address that directly?
I mean, I thought we were more uniform than
I think what Member Valdez and others are discussing is the fact that the advanced placement exams, international baccalaureate exams, and the completion of dual enrollment don't specify it needs to be mathematics and English language arts.
It can be a component of any of those.
Now, we know that advanced placement and international baccalaureate are based on
you know, academic measures.
As an example that we use for dual enrollment, we would not give credit for physical education.
It needs to be academic or CTE subjects.
So there is that standard there.
And to Member Ting's point, we have had a very, sorry, excuse me, Member Sun's point, we have had a very low amount of districts who have been able to submit data saying that they have met the dual enrollment requirements in CALPADS.
And we have spent the last year
doing a data boot camp for folks, getting ready for the college career indicator.
And so I want to make sure that I give credit to my colleagues who have been out in the field talking to data folks at districts and at schools about the importance of making sure that they are tagging courses appropriately so that students can get credit for what they've been doing probably for a number of years.
So, what has brought to light over the last year, because we've been able to display this information in the dashboard through some additional reports that are available on the department's website, is you can see how many students have met each of these measures within the cohort by student group.
So, if you haven't seen those reports, they're very powerful.
We've gotten a lot of good feedback from schools and districts that are, I think, a little surprised about where they have gaps.
And maybe some of the gaps are really due to the quality of the data they are submitting.
We also are limited, to go back to my first point, we're limited by the data we collect.
So, we do not collect wage data.
I don't know what a student who has gone into the Army now makes four years later, five years later.
I do not know what a student who is a translator is making four years later.
So, we do not have access to wage data.
We also do not have access to course completion data.
That is a paid service from a national nonprofit that we, for the first time, were able to purchase a subscription this year.
So we will be doing some data analysis.
But that's a one-time subscription.
And it is very expensive.
That has been cost-prohibited for the last 10 years.
So we can think about those things.
But again, this is looking at a student's four-year career.
It's 70-plus million data points.
And so, it's been a challenge.
I think it's definitely been a challenge and I, you know, the measures that we have recommended to be put in have gone through the vetting process that we have, you know, expressed for each one of these.
So, we have followed what we have done for other measures.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
If you look at the title is college slash career, clearly not college and career.
So that answers the question, are we looking at this as college and career?
No, we're not.
Right now, my understanding of our previous conversation was that will be the well-prepared and we're not there yet.
And so until we get to well-prepared, this indicator is a slash, college or career.
And I want to go back to a point that was made earlier about now, why we didn't put the entire criteria of the CIELA by literacy, because it would take the entire slide.
So that just tells you that it is already rigorous, right?
And so I'm kind of hearing that, well, we need to validate it with something else because on its own, it's not as rigorous.
But there's a lot of research that shows a correlation between college career readiness and bilingualism and biliteracy.
So there's already a body of literature that substantiates that.
And if you look at your graphs, you know, we already have a good understanding that a lot of the students would also meet, nearly meet, meet or exceed math.
But adding the layer just seems like it's disproportionate.
Carrick, do we have to bring the big dogs?
What's happening here?
Yeah, I'm taking you to church and it's only Thursday.
So I don't believe that we have a consistent criteria that's been applied.
And again, right now, by our own definition, this is a college slash career.
Unfortunately, it is not college and career, which I think it's the goal that we all have.
Can you speak to that first, college and or college or, and whether all of them are one or the other or
So Carrick Ashley, deputy superintendent.
So I think that's an important distinction here.
We purposefully have it at college slash career.
It's not an and, it's not even an or, but it's a slash.
And it's simply because when you're setting up an accountability system, what you're trying to do is make it fair for all that are playing in that accountability system.
which is why we have a separate but related system for our alternative schools.
We want it to be fair for all of these schools.
So we know that all schools don't emphasize the same thing across, which is a good thing.
Right?
In terms of college and career versus college and career, career tech ed, what a school emphasizes there to meet students' needs may not be the same.
So we don't want to disadvantage schools that may have a specific emphasis in some kind of a career track, or a school that is very low on their career side, and they do all the emphasis on the college side.
We want to make sure it's fair for all.
Having said that, maybe I can help lower the anxiety here in that this is a policy decision.
It's not a right or wrong decision.
So you have a recommendation, but I can make an argument for either side of this.
And the argument goes like this, if you're going to call this a
college-related criteria, then certainly scoring level one at mathematics is not being prepared for college.
It just isn't.
That's not enough rigor to consider that prepared.
On the other hand, if you consider this a career indicator,
For careers, clearly, bilingualism and biliteracy prepares you well for certain careers.
There are other careers that won't be enough alone.
But there are clearly careers out there where biliteracy and bilingualism does prepare you well for that career.
So if you as a body decide not to include the mathematics criteria, I think it would be just our job to make it clear that this is a career criteria in the CCI, and it's not an indication that the student is prepared for college.
because a level one for college is not prepared.
It doesn't mean the student couldn't be successful, right?
It means there's a lot of work, but at this point in time, with this score, they're not prepared.
Okay, who's next?
Board member Holliday.
So I do think that if we look at the slash as or, which is what I've always been thinking.
And that we look at this as a multiple measures approach as we've been talking about forever and ever.
that it is perfectly acceptable to record and to distribute that information about the number of students in that school that have the seal of bioliteracy regardless of
other academic performance.
I care a great deal about science performance.
I care a great deal about social studies performance.
I care a great deal about all sorts of academic performance.
I want a child to be well prepared in all of those realms.
And yes, maybe math and ELA stand out for all sorts of reasons.
But I do think this, the approach that I've taken, and thanks Member Sung for really articulating this much better than I am, but the and or is, I think, at the crux of this issue.
And I've always seen it as or.
When we do this, though, it doesn't necessarily mean that that school is being entirely successful in all respects with every student.
But in terms of the seal of bioliteracy,
they're doing a pretty good job, and that's worthy of celebration.
And just as you said, Carrick, just now, schools do place different emphasis in different areas, and that's important to parents, and that's important to students, and ultimately to everyone.
So I tend to lean toward keeping each of these measures
clean and simple without an underlying baseline, if you will, unless that's going to be applied for every single one.
Yeah, just to remark the slash to me is not clear.
I mean.
Well, there's a long debate as to, I mean, I don't know what a slash means.
So, it could mean and, or, you say or, I could say and, you know, how we could argue about what a slash means.
But we have some, it's not that clear to me anyway.
But who's next?
Sorry.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so I'm a little alarmed by what I just heard from the Department of Education concerning bilingualism.
That somehow or other, there's a difference between what it means to be bilingual if you're trying to prepare for entry into the workforce and what it means to be bilingual
when you're trying to prepare a student to go to college.
Because the legislative intent of the law that created the state seal of biliteracy put a very heavy emphasis on academic preparation and coursework.
as well as achievement on some very specific academic assessments aligned to that coursework.
So to stand here and say that bilingualism, as documented for the performance of a student, is not about college preparation
is something that I'm concerned about because I absolutely disagree.
I don't have to read research to say that I would disagree on that.
I would have to just go back to my own memory as a student taking a foreign language, both in high school and college.
And for any parents who are working with and watching and monitoring their children,
who are currently in high school taking that foreign language.
I don't think they are thinking about which job their child is going to get.
I think they are paying attention to what this means as an advantage for their child to have options to make decisions, not only about their career, but about college when they graduate.
So I'm concerned that the way this conversation has taken on a different
dimension that
seems to be bifurcating the privilege of being identified as biliterate, not based on access, but based on something that's a little bit more unconscious.
And I'm concerned about that.
It's not fair that the state syllabi literacy, which has a very rigorous academic component, is being treated differently because we're suddenly now saying that that's a career indicator and not something else.
That's not what I ever voted for.
If that's the intent, then the indicator is not fair to any student or school who has created this opportunity.
This is supposed to be a public policy.
Nobody is going to remember this discussion five or six years down the road when none of us around this dais are on this dais anymore.
They're only going to remember what the indicator defines.
they are only going to remember what the indicator means and what the indicator is intended to report.
So let's be real clear.
If the indicator is intended to report college and career, college or career, and I thought I was voting for a balance that would report what districts and schools are doing to create access for all students so that students are ably able to make
a choice among those two options for themselves, not dictated by public policy, then the indicator needs to be simple, straightforward.
And as this conversation matures to being able to define what well-prepared means, we're not solely talking about well-prepared for college.
but well prepared to enter a career.
So I do not want to see and I did not believe I was voting for indicators or elements to be added to this indicator that were going to be used in separate ways for one type of it for college and in a different way for career.
Again, that gets to a level of unconscious bias that's being written into this particular indicator that I do not believe I ever voted for.
Board Member Burr.
Back to the technical questions.
Can I just have you do the... Go back to the slide that shows the percentage across the... Because I just want to make sure that I... Not that one, the one that shows... There we go.
What the recommendation is.
Because I wasn't at CPEG, so I didn't hear the feedback.
But what I thought I heard in this conversation and based on what Member Rucker and Member Strauss said was that
There was a recommendation at CPAG, recognizing they don't vote, that you expand what your initial staff recommendation was, that you include not only math, the standard met or exceeded, but also nearly met.
So that those students who would not be counted for purposes of this indicator would be the 9.7%.
Is that accurate?
The recommendation to CPAG was the recommendation... No, no, I know, but I'm asking out of CPAG, how did you modify the recommendation that's now before us?
Thank you for clarifying.
The recommendation was modified to add an approaching prepared level so that a student who earns the state syllabi literacy achieves approaching prepared.
So there would be a math component, but it would be broader.
There would be no math component for the approaching prepared level.
There is no math component for the state syllabi literacy.
There is, for students who don't meet it, I'm getting confused between the chart and what the proposed criteria, I guess.
The proposed criteria for prepared is not only to have met the state syllabi literacy, but to add a component that they need to score at least a level two or higher in mathematics.
I think it's important to note that the state seal of bioliteracy requirements as a state seal do not include mathematics for coursework.
It is all English language arts.
Everything in that references that, as well as foreign language.
So the approaching prepared level, which is the recommendation that came from a member from CPAG, was to add an approaching prepared
category to this measure.
That is not something that the College Career Indicator Workgroup advised or even came up with themselves.
It came out of a rich discussion at CPAG.
So that is what we have added since the CPAG discussion and vetted again through not only a technical design group but the LCFF stakeholder group.
It has been shared over the last several weeks prior to the formal recommendation in the item you see today.
So if we were to take the recommendation that I see here, it means that every student that earned a seal of biliteracy would be included in the CCI, either in the prepared level or approaching prepared?
That's correct.
And of those that earned a state seal of biliteracy in the period, we see that it's 86% of them that would meet the additional requirement under the prepared level.
So I'll just say for me, I really am respectful of the seal it by literacy.
I think it's a wonderful tool.
It's a wonderful achievement for students to have met it.
But I worry a great deal about our mathematics performance in this state for every student.
And to the extent we're trying to send messages to LEAs and schools about needing to improve academics across the board, I think it's important to keep kind of reinforcing that message.
So I'm just a little bit, I'm on the cusp or on the fence here about whether or not to send a message somehow, being very cognizant of member Rucker's concerns about not creating unintended consequences for students.
I do also just want to say to Member Sun's comment that I think we probably need to go back.
I feel like every time we go to do the CCI, we have to like start all over again just to make sure that all of us understand it, how we got there, what the interactions are among these indicators.
And I think that we are, we're really, now we're sort of hung up on, is it college, is it career, is it both?
Maybe we need to step back and say, it's about high school success.
Have we been successful at the high school in preparing students for whatever they're gonna do next?
Because otherwise, I think we do get these sort of unconscious bias conversations going about, oh, you care more about career or more about college or whatever.
No, we want to have a very well-rounded, effective program for every student that goes through high school.
So I'll just put that out there for you.
Thank you for the clarification.
Okay.
Go ahead, Board Member Cardenas.
Is it on?
Yeah.
Oh, OK.
OK.
Sorry.
And sorry if I speak is kind of repetitive.
So a little closer.
Sorry.
So I agree with a lot of the things that other board members said around the CCI, the CCI, because college and career indicator is like very confusing.
Because when you have that gray area, when it's undecided what this title means, that means when it comes to accountability, people could do it the way they feel it could benefit them.
So there needs to be a very specific title to this.
If not, people could just bend it how they want to.
And I understand about like, you know, this school might concentrate on this career and that.
But honestly, when I see the
purpose of the college career indicator.
It says the CCI was developed to emphasize that a high school diploma represents the completion of a broad rigorous course of study that prepares students for success after high school.
So maybe thinking of a title like post-secondary readiness like something like that instead of college or career because to be honest not every student wants to go to college and sometimes the career that students want to go into is not provided by the education system for a lot of students.
So really thinking about what that title means and what
post-secondary readiness means should be added to this because it needs to be a really strong definition to have great accountability and great success because we can't have all these criteria that keeps getting added because there's a lot of confusion.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Valdez.
Over time we are just getting clarification.
I appreciate what appreciate what member Cardenas is saying and I Know from a couple board meetings ago I was surprised and I'm going to go back to the and or just for a second because I brought it up I didn't realize that it had changed or and I was confused so and that had been in a memo But it's how we message this out and how we try to bring clarity so the slash and eventually might become a dash But that that's semantics, right?
Well, it is to a point, but my question is, we've got a CCI workgroup and we've got CPAG and we've got different recommendations from both groups and conversations and meaning is greater over time, right?
So when we are going to report this CCI indicator as a district,
or, you know, you're going to get a color, correct?
And the district is going to get it and the school is going to get it.
But is it going to be broken down?
So I know my percentage of in all five, the report will show that.
OK, so the exact same thing we are showing currently on on the department's CCI report, which actually breaks it down by indicator, but then it further breaks it down by student group.
So it is it is diving into the data that's included in this measure to each of those different measures that were in it.
So then just finally, I just feel like, again, I think math is important, but if we're going to do it, we should do it for all of them.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm still not sure where we are on college and career or college or career.
And I know different people have different views, so I'll give you mine, which is that college and career, as I participated in the national debate, so it's not just California.
I have been active in the national debate on this.
In the national debate, there's one people in a camp that say there's absolutely no difference.
And therefore, for example, the Smarter Balance Test is equally good for college and career.
They're the same.
The National Organization Achieve has advocated that all along.
And then there's a college or career group, which I'm in, which is the view that they are different.
I think Kerrick Ashley presented that pretty accurately.
Many states have a separate system of career and technical colleges.
They don't have a comprehensive colleges.
my home state, Pennsylvania.
The community college system is a career tech system.
It has no transfer links to it.
That was true in Ohio.
I don't know whether it's true all through the South.
There's a gigantic system in Georgia called technical colleges, which is below the community colleges and run by a separate board of technical colleges.
Texas has the same system.
And so there is nationally a, I believe, a distinction between college or career.
And the slash doesn't do much for me in clarifying this debate.
So to me, we are proceeding without clear definitions or understandings of the basic underlying concepts we're dealing with here.
So this discussion, which is on a particular indicator, I don't associate this with this.
It opened up bigger issues is what happened here to me.
And so this is not just a discussion about this particular indicator.
It's just a good one to elucidate.
And I suspect that
JROTC is going to be another one when we get around to this as well.
I'm not sure how strong that is for college preparation, but that's to come.
I don't know much about it.
Go ahead.
So I appreciate those comments.
And going back to what Member Ortiz-Lacombe said, one of the reasons we went to the slash, which can be considered or at this point, was the discussion of the well-prepared category in which
If, when we come to that discussion, you'll have a lot of people who are going to advocate for it to be an and at the well-prepared level.
I wouldn't be one of them.
But there are some that feel very strongly it needs to be and.
The reason I prefer the or is from the student level.
Because what we do here does incentivize
districts and schools to do certain things.
And so if it becomes an and, and it incentivizes high schools to try to diversify as much as possible what a student does in their high school career, which is fine for students that want to do that.
But I can tell you, as a parent of three that went through high school, it was very difficult for us to make decisions about what my sons were going to take in high school, because there were all these criterias that went along with it.
He wanted to do jazz band.
Well, the school had a rule that says, to do jazz band, you also have to be an orchestra.
So there goes two electives.
And so when schools do that, it eliminates the choices that an individual student has.
And if a student wants a strong emphasis in some career tech ed or some fine arts category, we don't want a school
trying to push them into, no, you need to take things that go across the entire curriculum because we have an indicator here that says and, and we want to get as many students in that and category as possible.
So we want students and families to make those decisions of where the emphasis of their education is going to be, not coming from the top down to the families.
Okay.
We need to, we'll maybe need to move on soon.
Board Member Rucker, you end up the last word here on the technical questions.
We're not acting yet.
Yeah.
I am so happy I get to have the last word.
So let me, so let me just say, Mr. Ashley, I absolutely, Director Ashley, I absolutely agree that with everything you just explained about how this policy needs to operate at the student level,
so that we maximize the opportunity and the choices that students and their parents have.
That requirement is still in statute and that requirement is the basis for my understanding about how this indicator is supposed to work so that it would be a college or career indicator.
What concerns me is that each time we have this discussion, there is a nuance that is added that is something I don't agree with, which is, as we look at the different levels, approaching, well-prepared, prepared, that there is somehow a difference in how the indicators will be applied.
Some indicators won't be applied, for example,
at the well-prepared level, including by literacy, if by literacy doesn't also have this mathematics element.
That's not what I believe we should be doing.
We should not, if the indicators need to be uniform and consistently applied and understood in reference, in a context at all of those levels, which is what I thought we were developing and maturing
in the creation and addition of each of these elements into this indicator.
Today, I'm hearing that there's going to be a difference in how some indicators will be applied at the well-prepared level and some may not be included or considered at all.
I don't agree with that.
And if that is the purpose of the action we are contemplating today based on this recommendation, this is not a recommendation I'm ready to support.
I think we need to take a step back
and make a clear decision, are all of the indicators being included going to be considered at each level?
Or are we really and truly building an indicator where some of the elements in this indicator won't be applied at all levels?
That's not something I can agree with.
because if it's truly going to be college or career, that definition and how that criteria needs to be applied needs to be looked at at all levels, not just at some.
And as it relates particularly to this indicator, choosing not to include biliteracy and bilingualism means that we're making a policy statement about bilingual students and college preparation as a policy in our indicator.
That goes back to the days when it used to be okay
under our old accountability system for students of color to perform 20 points lower than the other students in their school and the district was still considered a high-achieving school district.
That is not something we should be doing today.
All right, I think we're ready to move to the next indicator.
And I think all of these will help us because we're really searching for some common policy and common definitions here.
The discussion's been very rich and good, I think.
And so, Golden State and then, yeah, go ahead.
Thank you.
So the Golden State Seal Merit Diploma requirements requires that, and again this was a long one too, it's a full page.
I'm not going to read it unless we need to go down that road again like we did for the prior one.
Students must complete coursework under a broad course of study.
And specifically, there is six subject areas, with the minimum of the subject areas being English language arts, mathematics, science, and US history.
Above and beyond that, the two additional courses have variants to it, a higher level science class or something beyond US history, those kinds of things.
There are minimum grade requirements for those courses.
Typically, it's a B+, although for U.S.
history, it's a B. So with that in mind, it is similar to A through G, but it's not A through G. A through G has specific requirements for each of the subject areas.
And it looks at really a student completing A through G throughout the four years.
There is some that have made comments that the Golden Seal's merit diploma could be completed earlier than four years.
So it's not necessarily looking at the full complement of the student's
the students work.
The other piece is that test scores may be used in place of course grades.
So there is that mechanism in Golden State that's written in there.
It is considered, we are suggesting that be considered a measure of college preparedness.
So of the 91,206 students who earned the Golden State Seal, again, we're looking at the comparison to the Smarter Balanced, English Language Arts, and the next slide will be Mathematics.
So for those that earned it, you do have students, and again, there's not a,
There is an and or, so you don't have to have a certain level, which is why I don't have a box around this like I did the prior slides for the state seal by literacy.
But you can see on average that students, especially in the standard exceeded levels and
levels are doing quite better than their peers than those that did not earn the Golden State Seal.
And this is done, you know, it's an evaluation at the local level of a student and so there is some requirements on the local level to determine that the student has met these criteria.
We've only begun collecting this information at the student level in 2017.
So again this is
Level 3 or level 2?
Level 3 would be standard met, so that's the 29,071 and then standard exceeded is that 55, the bulk of the students, 55,657.
You do have students that earned the Golden State Seal, as you can see, that scored level 1 in English Language Arts and level 2 in English Language Arts.
As a comparison for mathematics of the 91,078 who earned the SEAL and took the exam, you see not as high of figures as you did in the prior version.
So the prior version had close to 55,000 students earning and getting that highest level math standard exceeded.
In this, for mathematics, you see them at 38%.
But again, it's above those that did not earn the Golden State Seal Diploma, which is just 6%.
Again, with standard met, you are seeing higher performance in math in that level as well.
But this is not a requirement.
This can be used in lieu of a requirement.
So this is an or option in the criteria.
So just to complete out, there's just a couple more slides.
This one is comparing Golden State's Merit Diploma and A through G completion.
Again, this is not the same thing.
But just to give you a comparison of how they did, of the 93,000 students that took, or rather that earned the Merit Diploma, 87% also completed A through G. And of the entire cohort of the class of 2017, nearly 200,000 completed A through G.
And of those 200,000, about 40% earned the Golden State Seal.
So it is not something that is universal statewide.
I'm obviously with the amounts.
But it is something that a group of students is working on and has earned and is considered an important piece on their high school career.
So the slide that I'm showing you is simply the data that we've just spoken about in a table format.
So we're looking at those that earned a Golden State Seal, that completed the A through G requirements, and those that did not.
So there were some that earned the Golden State Seal that did not complete the A through G requirements, but the majority of them did.
And then of the total cohort, those that did not earn the Golden State Seal that completed A-G versus those that did not.
So A-G of course is not a state requirement.
It is something that is adopted at the local level for some high schools and some districts.
The Golden State Seal does capture some additional students.
So we know, based on the data that we've run, that 12,206 students who earned the merit diploma but did not complete the A through J requirements.
90% of students earning the merit diploma who scored the level three or higher on English language arts.
Also, we have a very high percentage of 78% scored a level three or higher on the mathematics piece.
So there is a high correlation of these students doing well on the Smarter Balanced assessments.
And so finally, the recommendation is for prepared that is a standalone measure.
And of the students who earned the Golden State merit, you would see 12,206 students in the class meeting the criteria.
Okay.
A little history here for people that may not go back so far.
I think this started when Delaine Easton was superintendent.
The idea was in an era when we had very few incentives and markers for higher achievement, was that the Golden State exam was and will and was clearly linked to a set of rigorous end of course exams.
It was the first move the state had in end-of-course exams and then we continued those under the California standards test when we also had end-of-course exams and then abolished them, the end-of-course exams with the overhaul towards smarter balanced test.
So, this had real coherence and you had to pass these assessments
And it was an entirely different concept than it is now.
What the rationale was for preserving it after we dropped the test escapes me.
But that, I guess it's in statute and code, right?
Yeah.
And so it was really that we're going to set out subject matter assessments and, of course, assessments.
And that was what it was all about.
So I just want to point out that history.
I didn't even realize till this came up that this thing was still around.
And so because the original rationale was undercut.
So with that, Board Member Dasan, we'll go.
Okay, so I have two concerns with this measure.
One, I don't believe the measure itself is ready for prime time.
I don't agree with the comparison to A through G, broad course of study, because the requirement, you know, as President Kirst mentioned,
This used to be, a student earned this by taking a rigorous end-of-course exam that was given by the state.
It has since been replaced with making a grade of B plus or better for two... Or B in some cases.
Yeah.
B in one place.
B, okay.
So in a single course each semester for one year.
So it is just one year.
So a student could make, in a very introductory math course, a B plus or above, and in English language arts, a science class, et cetera, without any understanding of the rigor and consistency in the grades.
But they could do that technically and earn this seal, this Golden State seal.
and be what we're calling prepared on our CCI.
So now this goes then to the second piece.
First of all, I don't feel like the measure itself is really rigorous and does not represent a broad course of study as we are looking at in a preparation.
And the second is the lack of consistency.
I feel that the measure we just talked about, the seal by literacy, has a much more rigorous aspect to that than the Golden State Seal Diploma.
And it is much, much less rigorous than A through G, which we are requiring additional measures
Additional criteria on top of that and that was based on some that That there was research on a through g that a through g ended up itself It's not enough and therefore that's why we added the additional criteria.
There's no research that the seal of golden seal merit diploma
guarantees that that student is going to be prepared.
And I am very concerned that it's a standalone.
If we were to go with it as a standalone, we technically
give the prepared level to a student who is, well, excuse me, 22% of those students are not meeting the math level, right?
22% of the students who earn GSMD are not meeting the math standard level.
That is a much higher percentage than what we saw with the students who earned this seal of biliteracy.
So, it's around the inconsistency of what these recommendations are and what's going into this particular, the measures that are going into this indicator.
Who's next?
Board member Rucker.
I agree with what Board Member Sung has pointed out.
I won't repeat the things that she stated, but I will repeat my concern that the criteria that is going to be used in this indicator need to be uniform and consistent, need to be uniformly and consistently considered for each of the levels of prepared, approaching prepared and well-prepared.
And if this is going to be the definition of what well-prepared means, it definitely should not be less rigorous than the indicator we have for the indicator that is not a standalone for the state seal of biliteracy.
There needs to be a level of rigor considered among each of the criteria at each of these levels that looks comparable and this does not.
Board member Burr.
So Cindy, I guess, could you just answer the question I think that was embedded in board member Sun's comments about, as I understand it from the agenda, that the technical design group, which we try to rely on in terms of validity and reliability, supported the inclusion of what we just talked about, the seal of biliteracy in combination with mathematics to maintain consistency with other criteria.
including CTE pathway completion and the A to G measures.
So why did they recommend that those two be linked?
And there is no other recommendation like that for this Golden State.
One of the things that the TGE looked at was to look at the percentage of students who are scoring at least a level three on both ELA and math.
And when you look at the Golden State Seal Merit Diploma, the percentage of students who are scoring well in both areas are very high, just as is so with the students who are taking AP and IP exams and scoring three or higher.
So the percentage of students scoring at the higher levels are much higher for that.
And there's also, they're very well aware that we want to put some measures into the CCI that are not strictly based on test.
We've been hearing that very clearly from the state board that we should have something in there other than test scores.
And so that is the reason why they chose to support that.
I think I'll just say for me and I think I'm picking up this vibe from everybody.
There seems to be a level of inconsistency here and things that are kind of counterintuitive to us non-data nerds that where you think A to G is a pretty rigorous requirement
since that's what UC is expecting completion on, that to say that A to G needs to be linked with something else, but not the Golden State Merit Diploma, it just, it doesn't ring true in my little head.
So I think that's what we're struggling with here is how we're maintaining consistency across these indicators.
Yeah, sorry.
Board Member Sun.
And this is where I go back to the measure itself is not ready for prime time because the difference between counting an English course
grade versus actually meeting standard at 11th grade is very, very different.
And the LEA can choose one or the other.
The measure itself has such wide range that I'm not sure how we ensure any kind of reliability validity to this particular measure within the index.
Right, and I understand your comments.
And that's one reason why we always go back to look at how students are performing on the Smarter Balanced Assessment.
And when you're looking at students who receive the diploma, you have a very high percentage, 90% that are scoring high on English language arts and 78% on math.
That is solid evidence that the diploma is actually producing students who are doing well in both subject areas.
Right.
I agree.
I think it's we're backwards mapping it.
We're saying right now there's a correlation.
However, the standard in and of itself will not correlate.
And if we continue on this, we will have LEAs that will choose the path of leach resistance, if you will.
And that's where it will start getting very mushy.
Board Member Holiday.
Once again, Member Sung, I think you're spot on with this.
But we do have to remember that all of these things are apples and oranges, right?
And if you want to find some sort of level of consistency among all of them, the criteria, that's going to be a very difficult thing to do from a data perspective, I imagine, or a statistical perspective.
It might be an argument for why minimum academic performance should be the underlying factor in all of these across the board.
But the difference between the field of bioliteracy, the A through D courses, the military science stuff,
They're all different.
And for some students, one may be more rigorous than another.
And for another student, it may not be that rigorous.
I mean, if you're already a bilingual student, the seal of biliteracy may not be quite as difficult as for another student.
So they're all apples and oranges.
I'm OK with that.
I'm OK with the or.
I'm OK with schools having this be something that they're proud of and they're preparing students well for that.
But if that's not where we want to go, then there has to be sort of an underlying evening leveling data thing, such as test scores or whatever.
And you did wear red today for a reason, didn't you?
Okay, maybe we're ready to move on to military science at this point.
I just wanted to add one comment that my boss reminded me of is that this board, maybe not these members, did set the criteria for the Golden State Seal Merit Diploma.
So...
We can have a conversation.
It wasn't under my leadership either.
This predates me, but I just wanted to make you aware of that.
And since we're batting zero for two, let's try with number three.
The other thing Jenny reminded me of is as we think about these things and you look at what's currently in the CCI, we are very heavily dependent on Smarter Balance if none of these measures are adopted.
And so we do have a three-year plan to build out this to make it more career measures and we've had great success.
Great work with our College Career Transition Division and the community colleges.
So we think we're going to get there on some other measures, but I want to put that in perspective as we go through this last item of, rather last piece of this first part of the recommendation.
So this is Leadership Science, again, Junior ROTC.
So the J is added in these slides.
And high school students can participate in JROTC each year.
Some participate one year, some participate two, three, or their entire high school piece.
Finishing the four years does not automatically qualify them to join the military.
They also must meet the academic eligibility criteria, the ASVAB, or the Armed Services Vocational Aptitude Battery Test.
JROTC provides advanced rank if the student enlists, which translates into work experience.
So for example, our research showed that the Army, Air Force, and Marine Corps provide six months, and I think the Navy was upwards of nine months.
So we have this table which shows you the number of years a student participated.
I don't know which year it is, maybe their senior year, maybe their freshman year.
Only if it's one year or two years, maybe it's sophomore and junior or sophomore and senior.
But we do again look at the measurement against the Smarter Balanced because that's been our
are benchmarks.
And so you can see of the students that have taken the, or rather who have taken this coursework, again this is a course enrollment in CALPADS, you see by years, by total years, how well they did on English Language Arts.
And so the number of students who, you know, standards exceeded versus standard met, standard nearly met, and so on and so forth.
We did, in our analysis, we found that the distribution of the English language arts scores for the four years of data signals that a better performance on the summit of ELA had, of course, was with more involvement in JROTC, they were doing better.
So just to go back to that chart, you can see the levels do increase as we proceed with the years of JROTC.
So the recommendation from the department to the board is for the prepared level, the student completes at least two years of JROTC, that there's a minimum assessment requirement of at least standard met in the English language arts or math, and the student scored standard met in the other subject area.
So it could be English or math, and then English or math in the second piece.
So, we have half a percent of students in the graduating class of 2017 who met the criteria.
For approaching prepared, again, about half a percent who meet the criteria, which is just that they complete the coursework.
So, it's just a simple coursework, no assessment requirements.
And with that, I'm happy to turn it back to President Kirsten.
Well, we'll have board member Holliday since he won't speak.
Thanks.
That chart is very interesting to me.
I think it is really clear that for the handful of students that we're talking about, when they stay in JROTC for four years, that their scores really do go up.
And that's a great thing.
That's a nice reality.
So there are other military science leadership programs in California, including the California Cadet Corps.
Did you take time to think about whether or not, is there a reason why you stuck with just JROTC and eliminated other sorts of leadership military science course work?
Because actually, the governor's military school does not follow JROTC, but it is a military school.
I'm going to ask Jenny to come up since she did the actual analysis.
I thought it was just based on the actual course name.
It was based on the actual course name of military leadership.
Most people are familiar when we say military leadership.
They're like what is that.
And so we reference JROTC.
But there are other that doesn't necessarily mean that a school can't have something a little bit different and report it in the military leadership.
That's the only course that we collect in CALPADS.
Yeah, see that's what I was actually thinking was the case, is that what you're talking about here is a course code, right?
And you're not talking about necessarily a specific curriculum that is offered by the United States military service branches.
That's right.
This could be very misleading, I apologize.
Okay.
So I do think that's very misleading.
And I do think that using the exact terminology of the course code, whatever that's in there, is what you should do from beginning to end on this.
Lots of people toss around ROTC and these other things, but it's got to be a lot more clear than that.
And if we were to leave this as JROTC period, then it would eliminate, I think, really good programs that are doing good things for students, and we don't want to do that.
So you're batting zero for three.
Just a little joke, just a little joke.
You're out then.
Great.
OK, Board Member Rucker.
And I'm glad to follow up with Board Member Holliday's question because the course code was going to be my particular question as well.
Because I know we have already had, you and I had conversations about how CTE courses are being coded and the difficulty the department is having with capturing
how districts are reporting it.
So, the other part of the question I had, a lot of districts, including the district where my brother took the California Cadet Corps course, it was listed on his report card as a PE course.
It wasn't even identified.
as a California cadet core course.
So because students can take those courses to exercise the option for PE, I'm wondering if we're also losing some of that reporting.
The reason why I'm concerned about that course code is I want you to look at
As you look at this chart and you look at the difference and I would expect from year one to year four that we would see an increasingly smaller number of students who would elect to choose this course of study.
But I got confused when I looked at the change in enrollment between year two and three and then year three and four.
If you had 240 students
who met the standard in year three, who exceeded the standard in year three, where did the extra 108 students come from who met the standard in year four?
So I don't understand.
So there's got to be something going on.
There's a ghost in the coding that's creating some confusion.
I realize that's a very small concern, but that's consistent in what's reported for year four across all of the categories.
So I'm a little, except for the first one, standard not met.
I don't get that.
So what I think it's important to note is that year three may not be their 11th grade.
Three years may not be that they were enrolled in JROTC during their 11th grade year.
This is at any point during their 11th grade year, we grab their Smarter Balanced scores.
They may have been in JROTC for four years.
They may have been in for three years.
So whenever they, it's not,
I think if you take it out of the context of when they were enrolled in the course versus grade 11 is the only time we offer, by law, required to offer the Smarter Balanced assessment.
Got it.
OK.
That helps me to understand.
And I appreciate the comments about the course coding.
And again, I apologize.
We were trying to make it friendlier to folks.
And it's obviously caused some confusion.
And that's the first time that this has been brought up.
So I do appreciate the comments.
And we will take that to heart moving forward.
when we bring measures to you for inclusion in the college career indicator.
Yeah, I'd like you to go to the last slide.
And so I think this goes back to college and or career.
I think this might be a good measure for career.
I'm not sure.
Yeah, you're right.
I'm not sure it's a good measure for college and now we're back to that
Slash.
So I would have a heading proposed JROTC criteria for career CCI levels.
I see.
Where are the math scores in here?
Why just ELA?
To convince me this is a college ready, I need to see some math scores.
Good point, and I skipped over this.
So we are only recommending this for, where does it pick up?
I guess I didn't really recommend this for a career.
So we are treating this as a career measure.
But because in order to join the military service, you have to meet some academic standards, we are also putting in the academic standards for ELA and math.
So you have to score at least level 3 on one and nearly met on the other.
So you can score level 3 on ELA or level 3 on math.
And then the other subject area has to be at least a level 2.
Hmm.
Okay.
I'm a little lost, but I'm... Anybody have any comments on that?
I'm confused.
Well, it's both college and career because it's hooked to Smarter Balanced.
I would like to go back just for a second to sort of two comments one by member holiday That these are apples and oranges and we should treat them as apples and oranges but we have to communicate in a way that's clear about it and
And I just want to offer my highest compliment to our new board member on her suggestion that we call this post-secondary readiness.
Because we're just hung up on is it college?
Is it career?
Are we sending the wrong messages?
And we really need to have a very helpful subject or title for this that sends the right message.
and lets users, whether it's students or parents or community members, use the information in a way that's meaningful.
And I'm afraid that we have gone down rabbit holes here that we're never going to get out of.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Yeah, I think it's apples, oranges.
It's a fruit salad, really, because there is too much going on.
And when I voted for this, I voted for college and career readiness.
And then it started evolving.
We started seeing and or.
Then we started seeing the slash.
And I think that a lot of things went
I don't know that we all had a common understanding and that has been a little bit of an uphill battle for me because I've asked for clarification on is this and, is it or, and at times it has been well it could be both.
At times it's been no it's or.
When we get to well prepared it will be and.
And so I think that even if we change it to post-secondary success, which I think is
perhaps more encompassing, we still need to deal with the fact that the criteria tends to be a little bit all over the place for different indicators.
So I think there has to be some consistency across it.
If we're saving, if we think that math needs to be valued, which I agree, but it's not consistent across indicators, then maybe we can consider making it consistent at the well-prepared level once we get there.
But again, I do think that we need to standardize the way that we are giving weight to this, even if we change the title, which again would have to be a policy decision because right now we voted for a college career readiness indicator and there are very passionate camps on both what it means to be and and what it means to be or.
We can't just pretend that it's one thing.
Okay.
I think.
Yeah, let's take it.
All right.
Then we'll have public comment and we'll take a break.
No, excuse me.
We still have three more items.
Yeah, I know, but we're going to take a break.
I'm back.
All right.
Sounds good.
Okay.
So we will reconvene at 1040.
Okay, the board will convene and we're on the second of items on the accountability system.
Good morning again, President Kerr, Cindy Kazanas, the Analysis Measurement and Accountability Reporting Office Director.
I have one slide left for the prior piece, and that is the one that we're not recommending to you.
But I wanted to put it in a slide to talk through how we came to that conclusion.
So the final one that we had in our plan for this year to bring to you was the CTE pathways with articulated courses.
And we reviewed the data.
And you have that information detailed in the August information memorandum.
And we're not recommending it because we felt the data showed that the courses could not be treated any different than CT pathways without articulated courses.
So there was no distinction between those with articulated versus without articulated.
And because there's not a distinction there, we didn't feel it had
merit to move forward.
The college career indicator work group agreed with us as did all the other stakeholder groups that we presented to.
So this is not one that is coming for recommendation but I wanted to close the loop because we did present to you four items for this year that we wanted to consider recommending approval.
So that is college career indicator and I'm prepared to move on to chronic absenteeism.
So chronic absenteeism data, as you know, was collected for the first time last year.
We just received our second year of data about a week ago from our local educational agencies.
We have conducted multiple analysis on that one year of data and determined that the data is of good quality.
And to identify, we did look at it to see if there was any potential anomalies and did not find any.
The analysis also indicated that we felt confident that we could put it in for the dashboard.
So what you will see today is a methodology.
This is a two-parter methodology.
We will come back when we have completed our analysis and run simulations for proposing cut scores for that second year of data in November.
So similar to College Career Indicator, we're working on that data now to propose cut scores again for November.
So I thought it was important to take a step back because when we talk about chronic absenteeism data, the student has already potentially left the school or the district in which they were affiliated with.
And a student is determined chronically absent if they miss 10% or more days of their expected attendance.
So what is the purpose of this data collection?
Because that is a lot of schooling, that is a lot of lost instruction, and these students probably are most vulnerable for dropping out.
So I like this slide because it shows you what this data can be useful for at the school district level and then at the state level.
So at the school district level,
This statewide data collection was never meant to be an early warning system.
That is something that is meant to be on the districts and on the schools use of daily attendance.
There was a proposal several years ago that we do do a statewide attendance data collection and in fact that measure, I can't remember whether or not it just didn't make it through the process or if it was ultimately vetoed, but we don't have that in place.
All we receive from our data collection is how many days a student was expected to attend and how many days they attended.
That's it.
And this is after the fact, right?
This is after a year's worth of being in school.
And we're not reporting out on it until three to four months later.
So what is the actionable data at the school level?
Well, they should be using, again, their daily attendance to identify and address issues regarding attendance issues.
It's California state law that students attend school.
The data at the chronic absenteeism level, though, can be used to look at trends statewide.
So looking at schools that may require assistance in addressing attendance problems early.
And in fact, we do have a report in the student-level data system in CALPADS that shows throughout the year how school districts are
how students are progressing as far as, again, number of days they were supposed to show up versus number of days they actually showed up.
And then finally, school districts are required, this has been a part of the local control and accountability plan from day one.
This has been on that.
They have to set goals with specific actions about chronic absenteeism.
And I neglected to mention that Superintendent Tarlekson just reminded us via a news release that September is Attendance Awareness Month.
So we are ripe in talking about this topic today.
Finally, at the state level, what is the purpose of the chronic absenteeism piece?
So for the first time, we were able to report out on this data through our data portal, which is DataQuest, and provided that information at the school, district, and county level, as well as the statewide level.
I have to tell you that using that publicly reported information, Attendance Works, partnering with UC Davis, put together a very interactive storyboard through using geographic information system that is very powerful.
So that is, I think, an automatic success of somebody's used the publicly available data and they've created actionable
things for for districts to do and they have an action plan behind it because there are advocates out there that are steeped in this issue and most other states are actually Ahead of us on this issue.
We are very late in this data collection piece So finally, we of course have adopted you adopted the chronic absenteeism as a performance indicator back in July of 2016 and then of course our
Every Student Succeeds Act State Plan requires states to report it.
And we, of course, quoted it in our state plan.
And to that point, there's been some questions that have been raised about why the recommendation is just for the K level.
And so before I go into that, I just wanted to show you at a glance what measures that have been adopted and their applicable levels, grade levels, grade spans.
So if I'm in an elementary school district, you will see,
three different measures that you'll receive performance categories on.
And keep in mind that English language arts and mathematics are separated out on the dashboard, so it's actually two measures for that first one.
They'd see chronic absenteeism as well as suspension.
For high school, we're going to be picking up academic with your decision to add it into the SSA plan.
And then college career, graduation rate, and suspension.
So the balance that you see there is that there is more measures actually for high school than there are for elementary.
With that in mind, the approved plan, the ESSA state plan that you all approved on multiple occasions, included the chronic absenteeism rate as grades K through 8.
We will continue to report high school data on DataQuest.
That is, DataQuest is always going to be a standalone reporting functionality.
That is the purpose of that system.
For accountability, though,
We believe that graduation rate and the college career indicator shows the impact of chronic absenteeism.
If they don't come to school, they are not likely to graduate.
So we know that by the graduation rates that we have seen and the dropouts.
And although they've decreased over the years, those measures still show that we don't have 100% graduation rate at the statewide level.
So with that in mind, we did a survey of other states.
As I said, many of them are ahead of us simply because we weren't able to put this into our data collection system until recently.
And so looking at what kind of methodologies they use to incorporate this.
And so we came up with two that we have now run the data through.
The first being that we included students enrolled in at least 31 instructional days and we assigned them the same weight to each student who met the chronic absenteeism criteria.
Again, expected days if they have been absent at least 10% of instructional days that they were expected to be there.
The second methodology assigns different weights to chronically absent students.
Students enrolled 50% or less of instructional days would be assigned a proportional weight.
So for methodology one, you can see the mean absenteeism rates for LEAs is at 8.7% and 8.9%.
And for methodology two, it's slightly higher at 9.4% and 9.7%.
When we discussed this information with our technical design group and others and stakeholders, and I think it was a very rich discussion at the California Petitions Advisory Group, but more because of terminology.
We really walked them down a road of trying to understand how the data was collected.
And unfortunately, that got them off on a side road, on a journey that we took to heart.
So they didn't get through, I think,
as rich of a discussion as they could have had on the methodology piece.
But there was support for this methodology from the California Petitions Advisory Group and others.
And one of the main reasons is it's easier to communicate this methodology to the public.
And so both of them are valid and reliable ways to measure chronic absenteeism.
But the department is recommending that the state board approve the first methodology based on minimum number enrollment of 31 instructional days for the calculation of the chronic absenteeism indicator.
So with that, I will turn it back to you, President.
Technical questions.
Board member Strauss.
So Cindy, first of all, I know you guys have been working really, really hard on all these data runs and ways to approach it.
I think we need a clarification on the history of how we got from K-12 chronic absenteeism to K-8.
And just for a couple of comments is that I know you addressed it by saying chronic absenteeism of students not in high school, they're not going to be
likely to graduate, and obviously districts have data that they should be using a lot ongoing, and this is a report at the end of the year.
But I think having led schools at elementary, middle, and high school, it becomes far more serious as kids get older, and obviously counselors and administrators need to be following that.
But I think there's quite a surprise, by the way, among some board members and the public and school districts about,
how it ended up going to K-8, which I believe aligned more when we were doing our ESSA indicators, but why we can't or are not planning at this point, the recommendation is to not include it in high school.
So just a little history and discussion, I think just would be helpful to clarify in the whole conversation.
I'd be happy to do so.
So the application of the grade span has been something that this board voted on in July of 2016.
The grade spans were included in a chart.
And I wanted to make sure I referenced back to it.
So it's attachment four in that item.
I think because we have not had data to share with you, this indicator has not had the data
sort of light shined on it until recently.
And so these kinds of conversations about why are we changing our minds, it's not changing our minds, I just don't think we've been as out in front about the K-8 piece of it.
But it has been in the state plan since the first iteration back in September that you all voted on as a K-8 measure.
That said, one of the interesting things we heard when we talked to stakeholders after the board item was publicly posted was that there was an inference because we included the data reporting on the dashboard currently.
Right now, if you were going to go to chronic absenteeism,
for any school that has a dashboard, it takes you to DataQuest.
And so I think there was an inference that that would be what the indicator would be applied to.
So that is a lesson learned on our part that perhaps this whole inference of data being posted, even though it's just raw data, like we would do, for example, for LPAC.
And LPAC is different because it is applied to the entire grade spans.
And I realize that I missed the state indicators by grade span, but of course the English LP would be on here as well.
That was my oversight.
I apologize for that.
But that is something that we've learned.
And I think that is going to be a tension as I show you the new redesign of the dashboard, is how much information is important to explain, you know, why is certain measures being only applied to certain grade spans?
And so this is one of them that, you know, stands out.
The graduation rate in college careers seem a little more intuitive because it's usually applied, you're thinking about high schools.
So to follow up, to finish out, we have, you know, this has been on the table from 2016, in which, again, you all voted on, and we see college career and the graduation rate in lieu of chronic absenteeism, that is what we see it being used for, is attendance as well or academic performance.
Yes.
Did that answer your question?
Clarify, but I have a little for a few more comments after my fellow colleagues comment board member holiday I don't know.
I don't remember the 2016 vote But I'd like to revote Because I do think that the chronic absenteeism if you are collecting the data as you say is there I don't I do think that it should be reported and Mr. Sapp is going to
Explain how I'm, but I do think having it on the dashboard makes sense to me for high school, middle and high.
David Sapp, Assistant Legal Counsel with State Board of Education.
Just one point of clarification due to the interaction between the actions the board takes on the dashboard as well as the federal state plan for the Every Student Sees Act.
You all may recall from the board meeting in July, there was an extensive discussion about a federal requirement under the federal law about the overall weighting of indicators that are used at the school level for federal accountability purposes.
There's actually a requirement that the, I'm going to use the shorthand of calling them academic measures.
They're actually not defined that way in the federal law, but
the overall weighting of academic measures must be greater in the aggregate for the academic versus non-academic.
Because of the way Congress wrote the law, chronic absence cannot count as a academic measure at the high school level.
It can, and the federal government approved its use as an academic measure at the K-8 level.
strong research and evidence to support that approval.
It was included in the state plan, which is how predictive chronic absences at early grades of future academic performance for young learners.
So right now, the balance of indicators at the high school level is close.
Essentially, we had a very extensive back and forth with the federal US Department of Education staff in the course of negotiating the final terms of that plan.
And this is one of the areas that we did spend some time discussing with them.
And they ultimately were satisfied that the weighting of indicators at the high school level under the approved plan meets that requirement.
If we were to add chronic absence at the high school level,
It is my view that I do not believe it would anymore.
So I think that's something the board would need to consider, is the use of the indicator in the dashboard versus whether it could be used at the school level for school identification.
There would be a choice either of having to go and argue for a waiver with the federal government.
That might not be granted.
This is a pretty significant issue that they emphasized throughout the process as being very important in their view of what Congress intended.
versus the option of the board could, of course, approve something in the dashboard and not use it for federal purposes.
But I think one thing that I think staff has heard from the very beginning is the desire to not have different indicators apply, one for federal and one for state.
One final thing that I will add, Cindy was actually out on parental leave at the time, but I was here during some of these discussions.
I believe actually board member Burr at the very earliest discussion of the indicators for the evaluation rubrics, which is now reflected in the dashboard, was the goal and the board took action about a concise set of indicators.
And at the time the terminology was different, but a concise set of indicators to be used in the evaluation rubrics for accountability purposes under LCFF.
So I think that's another thing the board should be aware of and keep in mind in looking at the overall number and balance of indicators is that original goal in adopting the rubrics was to maintain a concise set of indicators that met the federal requirements because that was in the context of knowing what ESSA required at the time.
There were a series of information memos that were posted and a number of items that were successively discussed through the course of January through September of 2016 when the board actually formally adopted the evaluation rubrics.
And so the question of adding new indicators, you know, there's in the broader context the question of revisiting the original goal of maintaining a concise set of indicators for accountability purpose under the local control funding formula.
Go ahead.
I just want to finish up with one last comment.
Thank you.
And I didn't really understand a lot of that.
But I understand how it has to fit together.
I apologize.
But just one other thing.
Whether or not chronic absenteeism ends up on the dashboard for high school and middle school or not is another story.
But if it doesn't.
Think what efforts are being made to make sure that school districts and and schools are taking very Serious and close look at this data on a regular basis in your purpose for chronic absenteeism data
you state very clearly the first statement is not an early warning system.
Well, that, I'm not sure that's necessarily how we want to start off, how we communicate with schools about how important this information is.
Instead of saying it doesn't do this, I think we should start with this is something that's really helpful, could potentially be really helpful to you.
For example, in the next one you say,
Another third bullet point you said addressing attendance problems early in the school year, right?
to identify and address emerging attendance.
And in other words, words like repeating early and emerging, that to me is sort of an early warning system sort of language there.
And the fact is, I think schools and districts can use this information early on to identify where they're having issues with certain subgroups, with individual students and all the rest, and that can be really helpful to them.
Once again, whether or not the ESSA plan and our plan work this out for the dashboard is not as important to me as being able to have the department communicate very effectively with schools and school districts how important this data is and how they can use it.
If I can clarify, President Kirst, and I appreciate the feedback on how to start with a positive versus a negative.
As a data person, I should know that a little better.
what was the quality of the data we were getting.
Because our student-level data system doesn't require districts to enter information in every single day.
We only have three certifications that they have.
And the third certification is the end of year, which is when we grab this data.
That's why it's so important that our local
educational agencies use their student information systems locally, their daily attendance locally to do this.
And in fact, Superintendent Torlakson's press release dated the September 4th of this year reminds us of chronic absenteeism.
I think what it does is it adds another level of insight
again, on a statewide level, because we've never been able to do that before.
So it's really given a statewide perspective of where we have pockets of students that are chronically absent.
The other thing that Attendance Works, when we talked to them early on, very strongly advocated for us to do in DataQuest was to have a filter for just kindergarten.
They said that kindergarten is the first piece of your student's entry into school.
And if they don't show up to kindergarten,
They may be chronically absent as grade ones through three.
And so we do have the grade span filters available in DataQuest.
The dashboard is not meant to do that.
The dashboard doesn't isolate grade spans, right?
It looks at a school, and it doesn't tell you within that school, oh, grade one did better than grade two.
That's going to be, again, on DataQuest as raw data, not applying the methodology that we are using.
for the accountability system but I appreciate that and I do have to acknowledge my colleague Gordon Jackson has a great staff who has spent a lot of time on this.
They have an amazing statewide presence with the school attendance review boards.
The state SARB does a great deal of work on this and I would be remiss if I didn't acknowledge that we do have technical experts here in this building that help districts on a regular basis to reduce chronic absenteeism
and to work on attendance.
And in fact, there are model SARBs, model attendance districts all over California that the superintendent recognizes on an annual basis.
But for the accountability purposes, we just get this sliver of information and it's really too late, right?
This is not an early warning system.
This is really after the fact.
And some of these kids may have dropped out by then.
And so that's just trying to provide a little bit more insight into the data.
We're a member of ALDEZ.
So I appreciate that the chronic absenteeism data that we have is really lagging, a lagging indicator, right?
Because it's over and it's done with.
And when we think about DataQuest, it's also a lagging indicator, but we can disaggregate.
And one of my comments was about kindergarten, because it's not compensatory.
And it is the largest, when you look at district profiles, the largest offender, if you will, of not having kids in school.
So for me, that one recommendation is somehow or another to make that
a grade level that is required.
I mean, I just think that that's got to be out there because that's one of the things that the data is telling us.
So how we use this data moving forward is going to be important.
Today in Riverside County, in fact, they have a countywide conference on chronic absenteeism.
So I think what the conversations that we're having and as we look at just a K-8 narrow window, at least it's creating
chatter and really intentional bringing together people to see what they can do in concert with DAs and SARB and SART and all of those things.
So I think the processes are in good place.
I do feel though that last year there was the release of reports that came out every district and it was a K-12.
So when I have conversations with different principals and district level folks and said, oh, it's only going to be K-8, because I do remember originally when we were looking at what would be an elementary, because I was a K-8 district at the time, I paid a lot of attention to it.
But then because that report came out last year and it wasn't from, you know, CDE, but it was a
you know, we were ranked across the county and, you know, how was your chronic absenteeism?
Everyone felt like it was going to be a K-12 at that point.
So I think that there's going to be people who are going to be disappointed that we're not looking at it as a K-12 indicator.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
One of the letters from LPI referenced that 34 other state plans included this indicator as K-12.
So if ESSA is the piece that is prohibiting us from looking at this as a K-12 indicator, we ought to figure out how 34 other states managed to include the K-12 chronic absenteeism as K-12.
Let me finish, Dave, before you approach.
I was like, there should be music sound effects as you're walking up.
So, and I'm glad to know that we are really truly looking to this coherent system of accountability because I am sure that I will have comments about that as we look at the data dashboard.
We are also leading up to some rounds of addendums that will be submitted in November for the ESSA State Plan because some things have changed on our end.
And so this could be something that we could add.
Now they could always say no, but at least we know that 34 other states have done it.
And so we should also look to include this as one of our addendums that we're looking to submit in November for the ESSA State Plan.
Because I agree, I think that this is something that's critical and it looks different from graduation.
I know there's some correlation, but those are not telling us what's happening in the secondary levels or in high school.
So the board obviously can amend the state plan and any actions the board takes over the next, this meeting and the next meeting could be reflected in an amended plan.
I think one issue, and this is from the work on the federal ESSA plan, our state plan is quite different from most other states, not all but most, in the fact that we don't have a composite index.
that we have each indicator is treated equally with equal weight.
And therefore, most, based on my review of state plans, which is not comprehensive, most states that have factored in, they give quarter, half, 8% weighting sometimes to some of these indicators relative to others, which is a decision in a direction this board has not gone up until now.
So I, you know, I think this is, you know, would be a much broader discussion as opposed to taking action on a specific indicator because the implications of this overall system as a whole would be very profound.
It would impact the criteria the board's already adopted for LCFF as well as the criteria for school identification under federal Every Student Sees Act.
All the modeling that's been presented to the board up until now in terms of the impact analysis and school identification.
would be very different from what it would ultimately be if the board were to make substantial changes to the indicators that are included in the grades to which they apply.
So I think all the actions the board took up until now in developing the state plan, we wouldn't really know sort of if that would be the baseline going forward if we're talking about major changes in terms of the composition of the indicators that are included in our state plan.
But that is definitely something if the board so directs that staff would be able to take back.
Wait, Dave, the criteria for identification under ESSA is only based on academic indicators.
That's not what the law provides.
The law provides that the identification of schools has to be based on all the approved indicators and that at the, what I'm, again, the shorthand is academic indicators.
They're spelled out in statute as actually the two subject matter assessments, English language arts and math, at the high school level graduation rate.
English learner progress, those are what I'm calling a shorthand academic indicators.
The other indicators have to have substantial weight.
But in the aggregate, the academic indicators have to have much greater weight in the aggregate than all the indicators together.
But actually, the law provides that all the indicators must be using the identification of schools.
Okay, I'll have to look at that because I know it was for the summative but not for identification.
And I guess another point of context that Mr. Sapp brought up, we are one of 14 states in the country that are non-summative.
And in fact, our peer group, the Council of Chief State School Officers, has put together a group because we are on an island of our own of non-summative states.
And so we've actually
had about five phone calls with those other states, which includes New York, Pennsylvania, trying to think of some of the other, Maine has presented as well.
So those are just who we are in company with nationally.
Board Member Sun.
I just have a question about the data collected.
Cindy, remind me if we, in collecting the information about students, do we also ask for reasons why?
Or, and I'm referring to the fact that we have students who are increasingly have health issues, are hospitalized for one reason or another.
In just looking at my own schools I went through, because of this topic, I went through and looked at 40% of our high school students who are chronically absent, it's because of hospitalization, they're on an IEP, anxiety.
There's all kinds of very legitimate reasons, not just because they're not coming to school.
And a lot of them on
on IEPs and 504s.
And then with our K-8, it's about 30% of those students who are chronically absent are due to chronic illnesses or something to that effect.
So do we have any kind of information on that?
And I realize that you're operating a charter school, which is a little different than a district.
And a lot of districts, they actually have a district program that students are transferred to for home hospital.
And in fact, there's a piece of legislation that has gone through
talking about that related to home hospitals.
So there are pockets of this, and I think actually in Oakland has been one of the main points because they have a very well-regarded children's hospital.
So there becomes these students that move from all over the state to stay at these hospitals for months at a time.
And so how are they counted against the school?
That's why they have these programs set up.
But Jenny can definitely talk you through how we looked at that information specifically.
So there is a way to report in CALPADS if students are participating in a home hospital program.
And if they are participating in a home hospital program, we are not including them in our calculations for chronic absenteeism.
But they must be reported that way in order for us to exclude them.
Thank you.
So just a couple things.
I do want to kind of reaffirm something that Mr. Sapp said that this does go back to our very first conversation or one of our very first conversations about how many indicators are we going to have and how do we, as much as I hate to say it, align it with the federal government.
so that we don't have multiple indicators counting for one system and not the other.
So that's how this chart really came about.
And it also reflects the balance, as Cindy said so articulately, between elementary and high school.
And left on their own, almost all the indicators would be high school, because they're a lot easier to measure.
And as you'll recall, just as a little side comment here,
We've also wanted to talk about high school readiness.
Can we get an indicator at a lower level that will predict whether or not students will be successful in high school?
But again, to try to balance out the way these indicators are going.
So just by way of background, I do want to reaffirm what Dave said, and I agree with him.
The other thing just about chronic absenteeism, and Cindy touched on this when we had our liaison call in just a minute ago,
It's a lagging indicator.
It's just telling you what has happened in the past.
The issue about student attendance is squarely a local issue.
And not only that, but we have all kinds of programs in place.
In my view, chronic absenteeism is a fancy word for truancy.
We have had truancy programs in place from the get-go to say, if you have children who are having a hard time getting to school, we're here to help you.
We're here to help make sure those kids get there.
So I think we're having a fascinating conversation about data that's not necessarily linked to actually programmatic supports for students who don't attend school.
So I just want to put that out there because I think it's easy to get hung up in, oh my gosh, we want this data to be so precise and somehow,
it's going to change behavior at the local level.
That's exactly backwards.
It has to be at the local level to start with and attended to on every single day.
So I just want to say that I support the calculation, the recommendation, and I support the inclusion for K-8.
and that the high school issue about, I'm gonna call it truancy, is really closely, if not identically correlated to graduation rate and CCI.
So I think it's taken care of without adding yet another measurement there.
Thank you, Member Byrne.
I just wanted to follow up on that comment because, as Cindy Kazanas has mentioned a number of times, this data is available on DataQuest and we should not underestimate the data that is made public through DataQuest.
We publicized suspension rates for three straight years before it was put into an accountability system.
And we saw a dramatic decrease in suspensions by simply sunshining the data.
So we shouldn't underestimate that.
And let me suggest to you that if there are suggestions that you have for us putting other data up on DataQuest that you think might encourage the right drivers here,
to make change, then we can certainly put that in the queue.
Yeah, but if the board wants to pursue this, I think member Burr's comment is good.
I remember in the prior board, we spent a lot of time with student, the SAR boards, Students Attendance Review boards.
This is, you know, there's an indicator and then there's a whole bunch of other legislation and local boards.
If we want to, you know, we might get into this more holistically rather than just the indicator as the policy thing.
And it's probably something we had to look at.
Next is...
I think it's been covered.
I think there are a lot of programs.
Member Holliday started the discussion.
Maybe we'll compile a set of those programs that are taking place.
And you just mentioned it, Member Burr.
There are a lot of programs and the data is driven attention.
The Riverside Workshop, just as an example,
driven attention to the data and schools compare each other's absenteeism.
And within counties, the county superintendents are taking a role to try to convene their LEAs to look at how they could help.
The other driver, you know, coincidentally is the money.
If you get those students back in school, you get more ADA.
So that's also changed the picture as administrators are looking at that data.
They're looking at dollar signs that they're not taking in as well.
So let me begin by saying it's axiomatic that student attendance is very important, not only to school student success, but to the work that schools can do when the students get there.
So the decision to include or not to include all grade spans in the accountability system does not rest on whether or not we believe absenteeism is important.
But I think we're at a point now that our accountability system is reaching, this is a real inflection point for us on the policy work that we've been doing on the development of this accountability system.
And we're beginning to see this work have some impact and some influence on decisions that LEAs are making and on the actions that the field is taking.
So I think it's important for us to
look at when we start talking about the data, what is it we're asking the data system that informs the dashboard to do or to inform in the dashboard.
It's really clear to me in reading the letters and in reading
the articles that are being published about our dashboard and about our accountability system, there is still a great deal of variance in the continuum of expectations about what the dashboard is supposed to be doing.
And this is one of those conversations about chronic absenteeism.
There are people who think this is supposed to be part of an early warning system.
You can't have an early warning system to define actions on absenteeism using data that's a lagging indicator.
So those things don't mix, but it just sounds good to say we should have all of those elements included.
But I think the other point that has to be looked at, as has been pointed out by the department staff, we have more granular information available
to everyone, to all districts, to anybody in the public who wants to see it, that will give you the kind of actionable data that the dashboard is not intended to be used to do.
So, I think it's important when we have this data conversation
that we remain constant and vigilant in making sure the dashboard is used and the data that informs what's reported in the dashboard is used for very specific and articulated purposes that are different from the data reports that are available to schools to inform not only their LCAP, but to inform those decisions they need to make about this very important issue of absenteeism.
Otherwise, anything that's reported on DataQuest, there's going to be some rationale for saying it needs to be added as part to define an indicator on the dashboard.
And in the end, that will not be helpful and it will not create information that ultimately will be useful.
So it's not that I believe we should, less is more.
I just believe that whatever more we do,
needs to improve what the dashboard is intended to do and not muddy the water.
Because that's the reason why we're so confused and concerned about the development of the CCI because that's the conversation about data that we have never resolved.
Okay, I think we're on to the next item.
Great, we're on to attachment three.
And I'm going to introduce this attachment and then Jenny Singh from our accountability unit will walk you through it.
So this is, of course, the one-year graduation rate is specifically for our alternative schools.
So keep that in mind.
And maybe we need a name changer for it to say it's Alternative Schools Graduation Rate or something along those lines.
But for now, we have one-year graduation rate.
And you approved in May the use of the one-year graduation rate, of course, for our alternative schools.
The Dashboard Alternative Schools Status is what we're calling them, DAS.
in the methodology you also approved back in May.
So, we're at a point now, this is the first that you will again have as action for cut scores, and in November we'll bring a series of cut scores to you, but this is the only cut score decision you're making.
today.
So we have the Alternative Schools Task Force which of course members have presented to you in the past.
Roger Rice from Ventura County and we have representatives from Shasta as well as our colleague from the Gardner Center who's been
been so gracious with this task force.
They have recommended the status and change cut scores that you see today.
We've also vetted this, of course, through our technical design group and we've shared this out at the practitioners advisory group as well as the LCFF stakeholder group.
I did want to mention that there were a couple of letters that talked about the end size.
And for those of you that may not have been at the main meeting, you can go to YouTube and you can look at the video and it starts at four hours and 17 minutes.
And there was an exchange between member Burr and Mr. Sapp.
And the question was about, you know, why this wasn't a part of the recommendation or could it be part of the recommendation to lower the end size for these schools to 15.
And part of the concern that and Mr. Sapp can represent his opinion on his own, but what I took it as and what I
Affirmed in that statement after we had the exchange was that we did not have a legal It was not They we didn't have a legal measure to allow us to reduce cut scores That was an action taken by the legislature that allowed for that smaller subgroup or smaller and size for specifically for our foster youth population and our Homeless, excuse me
It's been a long morning already.
It's only 1130.
So that is the end size discussion and we thought that that was a very transparent way to have that.
We neglected to follow up in a memo or in our board item in July as we said we would in mentioning why we did not bring it back to you because it was done in a public setting.
So again, for those of you that ever want to watch this board and the interactions, we are on YouTube.
This is being filmed.
It's live streamed.
And it had 500 views already.
So maybe it'll grow to 1,000 by the end of today.
But that is the end size piece that I just wanted to introduce before Jenny came up and talked through the technical details of this attachment.
Good morning.
Again, my name is Jenny Singh.
I'm the Administrator and Accountability Office here in the department.
Just wanted to again thank our Alternative Schools Task Force.
They met several times, five full days, to actually go over the methodology and they provided us with
some really good feedback, thoughtful feedback, and they really helped us increase our knowledge about the challenges that alternative schools face.
So as they approved the methodology, we asked them to help us propose cut scores.
And so you can see here on this table that for the status cut score, the very low, the graduation rate is 67% or less.
That is consistent with non-alternative schools because that is set under ESSA.
ESSA says that any school that has a graduation rate less than 67% must be identified for comprehensive support.
So they kept that cut score where it was.
You can see if you go to the other end, the very high, they've also changed that cut score for non-alternative schools.
That cut score is 95%.
But for DAS schools, they set that at 90%.
90% is the statewide goal.
And they thought that it was very appropriate to set the 90% at the very high, considering the distributions of their graduation rates that we currently have.
And then there were some adjustments made to the low, medium, and high.
So for the change cut scores, a little bit different again for our alternative schools versus our non-alternative schools.
As Cindy alluded to in her comments, we have a lot of the alternative schools really serve small populations and that's the way they're designed so they can actually provide more direct services to students and more individualized services.
So their end size for the graduation rate limits the number of schools that will actually get a performance level.
And because the end sizes are so small, that does mean that there's going to be some, the changes are going to be greater from one year to the next.
There's more flexibility in that data.
So for the decline significantly, they set it at decline by more than 10%.
For our non-alternative schools, that's 5%.
And they did the same for increase significantly as well, so that it's equal.
And then of course for declined, it's three to 10%.
For maintained, it's increased or decreased by 3%.
And then for increase, it's increased by 3% to less than 10%.
So, it's slightly different than what we have for our traditional schools, but it does meet, it is based on the distributions that we have currently for our alternative schools.
So we have been getting asked a lot of questions about, are these one-year grad rates going to be incorporated into the district data?
There's been a lot of concern that because alternative schools did not have a dashboard for the 2017, and their data wasn't included at the LEA level, that that would never happen.
And we've always been very consistent that as soon as we develop a dashboard for alternative schools, their data will be rolled up at the LEA level.
So for the one-year grad rate, we're going to roll it up and we're going to take the data for all the traditional schools and we're going to take the data for our alternative schools.
We're going to take the number of graduates.
for the alternative schools and the number of graduates for the non-alternative schools, and we're gonna add them together.
That's gonna give us our numerator.
And then we're going to look at the number of students in the one-year grad rate at the alternative schools.
So that includes all the students that meet the business rules, so the graduates and the non-graduates.
We're gonna add them to the number of students in the four-year cohort.
And of course, that will give us our denominator.
We'll divide our numerator by our denominator to get a new rate for LEAs.
As we've said in the past, we are going to be looking at enrollment data this coming year.
There has been some suggestion that schools will start to transfer students to the alternative schools.
And we said that we were going to go ahead and monitor the enrollment, especially after fall census day and especially towards the end of the year.
So if we see a lot of transfers happening in the spring, then we will have to come back and bring a proposal to the board on how we want to address that issue.
But we will be monitoring that and we want to make everyone aware of that.
We are using the same five by five color table approved for our non-alternative schools.
And you'll see in the next slide that table three shows the number of schools that would receive performance colors if you adopt the proposed cut scores.
That's based on the class of 2016-17.
So you can see here that we have 553 alternative schools that would receive a color.
So we currently have, let me see.
953 high schools, 953 alternative high schools but only about 58% of them are going to receive a color because only 58% have 30 or more students.
From that you can see that a large percentage of them
Almost 60% are going to be in the red performance level, so they will be identified for comprehensive support under ESSA.
And then you can see that we of course have fewer schools that are at 80 that are green and blue.
We do think that this will change over time as schools start reporting their data that in regards to the 12th grade students.
So we are very hopeful that the number of schools that are red will go down and the number of schools that are green and blue will go up.
So we are recommending that the State Board approve the proposed cut scores described in Tables 1 and 2 for the one-year graduation rate that we will apply to our alternative schools.
And with that, I will be happy to answer any technical questions you may have.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you.
And I wasn't here in the May, during the May meeting, but if I'm reading this correctly, we would have 400 schools that would not be reported for accountability purposes because the end size is lower than 30, correct?
Well, that's the number of schools that will not get a performance level.
You may recall that we will report data on any school that has between 11 and 29 students.
So data will be reported for them.
They will not get a color.
And it will be reported on the dashboard?
The dashboard.
OK, thank you.
Any other questions?
I'm wondering if we can change this to alternative schools.
I mean, one year graduation rate, that may be a nice technical term, but I don't think it conveys to the public what's going on here.
So can we call this the alternative schools graduation rate?
We most certainly can.
It's a technical term because people who are technical came up with it.
So we are always happy to take recommendations.
Yeah.
I mean, I do a double take about these students going to graduate in one year.
I mean, it's just it's counterintuitive.
So board member Strauss.
I just want to share, I was in San Diego County in May and North San Diego County meeting with 20 different school district leaders and they are very, very supportive of our alternative measures based on the challenges and the different type of education support students in these type of programs need.
So just a positive support for us considering that.
I just wanted to share that.
Board Member Burr.
So Jenny, can you go back to the table that shows the schools?
And I just wanna make sure I understood you right.
The idea is that for the dashboard, we will include these schools in whatever LEA they are part of.
That is correct.
So any school, all 953 DAS high schools, their data will roll up.
Just because a school doesn't have enough students to get a color, that doesn't mean that we're not going to include their data at the district level.
We will include all schools' data at the district level.
And you'll be producing a five by five grid for the schools as well as the LEA so we can identify the schools just like you have them here for purposes of additional support?
Yes, that is correct.
Thank you.
Board member Valdez.
So this might not be within this indicator, but it also, I think, bleeds a little bit into chronic absenteeism.
So for alternative schools, how they calculate attendance, which I know is, you know, we're talking about one year, but also this, it's just occurring to me now.
The difference between hours that they need to be completers as opposed to positive attendance has caused some problems for districts where students are completing their hours, so they don't, the fifth day is mute because they've done the hours that they're required for the week.
Is that something that's more legislative?
Because it's still being reported on DataQuest in terms of chronic absenteeism.
So for these alternative schools, they're still getting penalized, if you will, for that.
You know, alternative schools are different.
Many of them do report hours and there is a calculation that they need to do to convert that into days.
So we do know that that has caused some problems for alternative schools.
We also know that when students come to alternative schools, their attendance probably
It's one of the reasons why they're there.
So the attendance when they get there is many times is very poor and that's one of the things alternative schools work on is building up, making sure that those students understand attendance is really important.
So yes, that does cause a little bit of a problem for alternative schools.
Most of our alternative schools are high schools though and that information then will not be rolled up to the district level.
But it's still reported in DataQuest and that's my concern.
Yes, it is still reported in DataQuest.
Okay, next item.
Okay, now we're gonna move on to attachment four, incorporation of a five-year cohort graduation rate into the dashboard.
So many of you know that ESSA does provide the option for states to include a five-year graduation rate into the accountability system.
And this also states that if you do that, you need a long-term goal that is more rigorous than the four-year rate.
This is nothing new.
This was allowed under NCLB.
And under NCLB, we actually did calculate a five and a six-year rate for AYP.
So this is really, this is not new to the accountability system.
So we did a thorough review of all 50 states and their approved plans.
Actually, our student that we had, our intern student from Stanford did, of course.
She did a wonderful job.
And we found that many states created a combined four and five year graduation rate.
And when they did the combination, it was either a simple or a weighted average.
And it looked like they did not have to create a second more rigorous long-term goal.
So we believe, based on the information that we've looked at, that a combined rate would allow us to take a five-year rate into account without creating separate long-term goals for a four- and five-year rate.
So, one of the reasons we've been asked to look at a five-year rate is because it does incentivize non-alternative schools to keep their students enrolled for another year.
Remember, our alternative schools have their own rate, so this would only apply to non-alternative schools.
And so we do know that we have some students that take a little bit longer to graduate.
Specifically, we have sometimes students with disabilities and English learners who may need extra time.
So this is incentive for those traditional schools to keep their students at the school site instead of transferring them to an alternative school or an adult ed school.
So we have developed some business rules on how to calculate this five-year rate so that it actually reflects increases in graduations.
So we're gonna kind of hold everything, we're gonna hold everything the same for the four-year and the five-year.
And one reason why we do this is because, as I said, many schools transfer their students to an adult ed program.
So if you transfer students, your denominator goes down.
If your denominator goes down, your graduation rate goes up.
But you haven't actually graduated any more students.
So we are developing a rate that would actually capture the increase in the number of students who are actually graduating in the fifth year.
So we did explore multiple options for incorporating the five-year graduation rate into the dashboard.
We detailed that in the August 2018 memo.
And there were some options that we could implement in 2018, and there were other options we could not implement until 2019.
And one of the reasons why, because people are really confused when we said we couldn't implement until 2019, they go, well, we've had four-year cohort rates for many, many years.
That is true.
Unfortunately, we did get some findings from a federal audit that actually required us to recalculate our graduation rates for the class of 2017.
And we're going to apply those business rules to the class of 2018.
And we put that information in a June memo.
So we only went back to recalculate the class of 2017.
We didn't go back to other graduating classes.
So anything prior to the class of 2017 are based on the old business rules and are not comparable.
So, option one, we could provide a performance level color for the four-year rate only, and then we would just provide the five-year graduation rate for informational purposes only.
And of course, this certainly could be implemented for the 2018 dashboard.
Option two would be to calculate a simple average that would combine the four and the five-year rate.
And what a simple average means, it doesn't matter if you're a four-year graduate or a five-year graduate, you're gonna count the same.
This requires two years of five-year graduation data.
So we don't have that yet.
We won't have that until 2019.
So it cannot be implemented until 2019.
Option three would be to calculate a weighted average for the four and five-year.
And the states that are doing this, they traditionally give more weight to the four-year grad rate, to the four-year graduates, more weight to them than the five-year graduates.
And of course, this of course requires two years of five-year data that we won't have until 2019.
Option four would be to report the four and the five-year rates and assign a performance level to the higher of the two rates.
And this is something that we can certainly do for 2018, but with this methodology, we would have to create a higher goal for the five-year graduation rate.
Oops, wrong one.
So, we are recommending that the board improve the inclusion of the five-year cohort rate into the 2018 dashboard for informational purposes only.
Because there are really a lot of different policy implications for incorporating the five-year rate.
We thought that we had some really in-depth discussion with our technical design group and our technical design group said there are many other options out there that we should probably explore and consider before finalizing how we want to proceed with this.
So we would like to just display it this year and then have you direct us to further explore options for incorporating a five-year rate into the 2019 dashboard.
And with that, I'm happy to answer any questions you may have.
I just want to make sure I'm clear on what you're suggesting.
First of all, thank you very much for all the work that's been done on this.
And you're right, California has been exploring four-year and five-year graduation rate reporting for quite some time.
So this is not new.
And actually, this is an area that state has actually gotten quite good at.
So I congratulate your department, not only for all the work, but for the level of expertise that's been developed on this.
So I just want to make sure I understand what is being suggested by the department.
The department wants us to implement one particular way of reporting the graduation data in the dashboard that would be reported this fall on the 2018 dashboard.
And then maybe down the road, consider making a change that would switch from the four-year reporting to the five-year reporting at some year down the road.
and that would have the net effect of changing what the dashboard data actually reports at the end for accountability purposes.
Is that correct?
Partially.
It could be that the board decides that they don't want to combine the four and five year rates because of policy issues.
and come up with a methodology that would display both.
I mean, one of the options is to display the four and the five-year and assign the color to the highest.
What I'm asking, your recommendation is not all those things you just said.
Your recommendation is to implement a four-year report
and then have the board consider down the road doing something else.
Is that what I heard?
That's correct.
Okay.
I just want to make sure.
And the reason you're recommending that is because you believe some of the policy considerations about making the decision for doing the five-year reporting still needs to be worked out or still needs to be clarified.
Yes, I believe that.
I think that the board needs to have further discussion on some of the policy.
And some of the specific clarification would be what the reporting could look like.
So part of the reason why you're not ready to make the recommendation for the five year reporting is you'd actually what the bottom line is, you'd really like to have the chance to collect the data and to understand what the data says and what it will inform us of before we jump into doing the five year reporting.
That is correct.
I have this more.
I'm not as sophisticated as some of you really smart Ph.D.s in your department.
So I would just like somebody to say we ain't got the data.
So we don't want you to adopt something.
We don't know what it's going to say.
I got the data.
Vote member Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you.
And I do agree that for now, we should probably just report it since you need two years of data.
And it would be good to know how what each of these options means.
When I look at calculate a simple average for four and five, I don't know that that adheres to ESSA because we're asking for the five year graduation rate.
It has to be something more rigorous.
So I don't know that a simple average is actually an option to consider.
But also we know that the CCI is based on students that attain a four-year high school diploma in four years.
So what would that mean when we're looking at the graduation rate, if we were to combine it, and then we're looking at the CCI.
So just looking at how that impacts other indicators.
Thank you.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
Great.
So I am here for the closer.
And this is attachment five.
And this is really it's been amazing work.
And we will be talking a little bit about that actually a lot about the dashboard redesign in this attachment.
But first I just wanted to give you sort of the lay of the land for the next couple of months for what districts and schools are experiencing.
So the first is is that we have refreshed our
Coordinator page for the dashboard and what that means is the individuals at this at the district level or the charter school Because of course there they are an LEA under our system now have access to input their local indicators So that information or that that access opened up in August.
They needed to get their superintendent or their approval saying that they are the appropriate designee
My colleague, Jeff Breshears, and his team have started a Tuesday at 2 webinar series for six weeks on the local indicators.
They had almost 600 participants in their first webinar last week, and so they have been already hugely successful, and they're putting up a bar for us to reach when we start our webinar series on the state indicators in November.
But prior to that, we are pleased to be collaborating with the California Collaboration on Educational Excellence.
They have graciously agreed to spend some time in October to do a training or a module on our dashboard alternative school status.
So we are excited to leverage their presence statewide to do that and get the word out about how DAS will now impact the dashboard.
And then, just to close out, as we reach our holiday season, we reach really the fun time for data, when we will have gotten far enough that we can start sharing data with our LEAs during a private preview.
Now, the beginning will be limited to those in which you've already taken action on.
So, for example, suspension rate.
Those that are pending action from you all in November, of course, are academic, is everything else, chronic absenteeism, college career indicators.
So we will not be able to actually produce that until you take action, which means we're going to be hitting up against the Thanksgiving holiday yet again.
But we'll be done well before Christmas with the public release and the identification of our districts that first week of December is our anticipated release date.
So with that all in mind, I'm going to switch over to the dashboard redesign.
And this has been something that we've been talking about really since we started sharing views of this dashboard almost 24 months ago.
So this has really been an amazing process.
I would say, when I look back at those old materials, because you've heard a lot of us looking back today, that Wayback Machine,
I remember and I read that you all wanted this dashboard to be focused on parents.
And when I think about what we produced, and we have a different frame of mind now looking back on 18 months worth of work, I think this first dashboard was a great tool for educators.
And we have now moved into a great tool for parents.
And I hope that you will put on a parent-friendly hat if you're not a parent and you
you interact with parents like we all do, put on that parent-friendly hat as you look through the next couple of slides.
Because I get technical myself.
This is what I do, is data.
And I had to even step back and say, oh, yeah, I guess that's not a good word to use to describe change.
So that's how I'm going to lead.
But this is a slide that we used.
when we did stakeholder outreach between board meetings.
So between July and today, we reached almost 1,000 individuals through our stakeholder outreach.
We had a very broad group of individuals help us at a webinar.
we had done actually a week's worth of stakeholder input.
And over that week's worth, we were able to do iterations of the dashboard that you're going to finally see today.
So these are the reasons why we're looking at enhancing the dashboard.
And of course, this governor and the legislature approved a $300,000 allocation to do specifically that.
So Collaborative Communications is the subcontractor of San Joaquin County Office of Education, who is, of course, our web developer and maintains our website.
And so just to give you a flavor for who Collaborative Communications is, they've worked with the Council of Chief State School Officers, the Data Quality Campaign, Foundation for Education, Excellence in Education, Learning Heroes, National PTA.
They've also worked with DC Public Schools and New York Public Schools.
So when we talked to, or rather when Collaborative Communications came out and did a stakeholder input session, they had the work that they, the design that they had done, we shared with them all the feedback you had been giving us and others have been giving us over the last 18 months about what was working and what was opportunities for improvement.
So as you had heard from, I think from Paul Richman and others from the CDE Foundation, they did a parent focus group and
They came up with some of these broad statements, like student group breakdown, they like.
They like the color ratings.
They may have liked the pies, but they like the color ratings.
So those are just a couple of things about what was working, and then opportunities for improvement were on the right.
I have to say that
When collaborative communications came on, the statement that we had shared was it was going to be very hard to move away from the pies.
And after the first week of sun shining the new design, the pies were still a distraction.
And so we took that to mean that there was a sign that we needed to move away from the pies and move into the land of gauges.
So you're going to see that in just a minute.
So this is a new friendly homepage.
We're going to look for some pictures that are maybe a little more California specific, but you can already see at a glance the color and the impact that that makes.
this site will be fully accessible.
So we actually had to change the color from what the designer had suggested because it wasn't meeting color standards.
So that's just an example of things that we adhere to and that San Joaquin County Office of Education implements on the back end.
So this is the new landing page.
And if you didn't get a chance to read one of the articles yesterday that talked about the new dashboard, it did quote Mia Sane.
And this is what the designer shared with us, is there's a reduction in pages by 80% from the current dashboard to this dashboard.
So if you think about the pages I'm going to show you in succession, this is one long scroll.
But since we're on our mobile phones or we're on an app, we don't necessarily think of things in pages anymore.
We like to scroll.
So think about this as scrolling.
So this is a made-up school.
This is made-up data.
I should say that from the get-go.
And what you see at a glance from the first, before you start scrolling, is you see how they're doing on each of the indicators, including the local indicators.
So we heard from the get-go, from that first session, it was really important to bring local indicators up aligned with the state indicators.
They're on the same level.
They're just as important.
We may need to change things like adding the words priority one.
What does that mean?
So we had the opportunity to go over across the street to meet with our governor because he's very interested in this product.
And that was one of the things he mentioned.
What's priority one again?
So it's nuanced for us because we're living it every day.
But what does the public need to know?
What do they need to know about priority one?
They need to know, you know, it's about school facilities.
It's about making sure we have teachers that are qualified to teach and those kinds of things.
And so as you see these slides, there are things that I'll mention that we know we still need to improve the language to make it, again, accessible to all parents.
So this is, again, same page, landing page.
We've scrolled just a bit.
We come up with this tile format that you saw previously.
The tile format, just functionality-wise, is neat.
It's because when you decrease it, they start to stack up.
So if you're on a mobile device, of which many of our parents depend on to access things like the dashboard, you would see it really neatly stack up.
So this is information that is currently included on the dashboard.
At the summative level, we show the student groups included in LCFF, which, of course, are socially disadvantaged, English learners, and foster youth.
We then are going to show you a backslide.
So what we've been able to do is keep the user on the same page and simply turn over the card.
So it's interactive.
So what we had done before was, if you want to learn about what this means, you'd have to go to Glossary that took you to another page and got you really distracted.
So the designer tried to use parent-friendly language.
We know that we need to improve the word socioeconomic disadvantage still.
We still haven't quite gotten it there yet.
But really, it's a nice feature to keep somebody's interest on the page.
We then go to the categories.
So currently, it's done on a dashboard.
It's done in a row format.
To make this digestible, what the designer has suggested is to break it down between three categories, which is currently on the detailed report.
So the first category is academic performance.
And of course, that includes English language arts, mathematics, English learner progress, and college career.
What you see for English Learner Progress is different than the others because we're showing you a sample of how we could envision the LPAC data being shown for fall.
So I wanted to point that out.
That's why it looks different.
We need to start vetting this out.
We have not been able to get out to stakeholders in the last week or so since we mocked this up, but this is an idea of how we would be able to display that data in lieu of having a color for this year.
The academic engagement pieces that are built out would be chronic absenteeism Assuming that you approve the cut scores and in November and the graduation rate
And then finally, conditions and climate.
And we have, as you saw with the academic indicator, we have the three local indicators listed there as well.
So they fit into the categories in which they're appropriate.
So what I wanted to dig into was what is this card, baseball card for lack of a better word, what's involved in it?
So what we've done is we've streamlined what you saw previously as a status and change report, as a detailed summary into this one card.
So there's a lot of information here, a lot of rich information.
And if you wanted to learn more about the indicator and what it meant, the first words about this indicator would be something that you would click on.
Now, folks have told us, that's not intuitive, actually.
I want to say, learn more, or something along those lines.
So I do have a slide towards the end that shows some of the language choices that we have heard are still, people are stumbling on.
So the other feature that we've heard a lot from the field on that we are going to be able to implement this year is being able to show a state summary.
And what the designer has suggested is show the state summary for each indicator and for student groups.
So you can see the toggle right now is between all students and state.
And all students is highlighted.
So you can toggle back to state to see how that school or district compares against all students in that district.
For this district, they're in orange, which means, this is the clue, we're not using the word status, but that means that in this year, this past year, 78% graduated within four years.
So we're talking about it being an active voice versus saying, this is status, because people just get, what does status mean?
So just tell us what you wanna tell us in plain language.
The other piece is telling us what, trying to tell the public,
what this school or district did compared to last year.
In other words, declined with an arrow has been something that people are seeming to embrace.
Now the next baseball cards are things we've gotten quite a bit of feedback on.
So I wanted to walk through that as well.
So for this district, they have 13 student groups.
So you see the 13 student groups spread out amongst the five different colors in the cards.
What is interesting about this, and I believe this is based on real data, actually I was told it was, is that the overall performance level of this district is orange, but the majority of the student groups are either in yellow or green or blue.
So it's really telling a story about the full breadth of student performance
And how certain student groups can, depending on their end size or what have you, can actually drive the color.
And sometimes it masks the other way.
Maybe it'll be green, and you have the majority of student groups, and red or orange.
So this is showing the full breadth of student performance.
If I want to dig into the data, I'm going to click on View More Detail.
And we're going to move to a new page.
Now we're leaving page one, and we're moving to page two.
So page two, and I'm switching to a different indicator, and this is because this is still a prototype, so only certain things have been updated with the new look and feel.
So English language arts, what we see is all students overview.
So for this district, they're yellow.
What we need to make sure we do between our different cards, our tiles, is we use the same language.
So we should use not only, this only includes change, we need to use status as well.
It gives a brief description of what English Language Arts is, so it gives you a frame of reference.
Moving down just a bit, this is a mock-up we've created because we haven't been able to change the prototype, but really just a list at a glance of where the student groups fall.
So I can see, and again, this is for English Language Arts, that we have two student groups in the red, three in the orange.
It lists the student groups by name, and then on through yellow and green.
I can then dig into the data through these pockets, these tabs here at the top.
Red groups, orange groups, yellow groups, green groups, blue groups.
And we need to have another group that's no color or students who fall between the 11 and 29 marks.
So they may not have a performance color, but we want to give their data out there.
We want to make sure that those student groups show up somewhere.
So we need to figure out, we need to land on something that makes sense.
I still haven't gotten there yet myself.
But as far as digging into the data, again, these cards probably need to, they will be updated to make sure that the language is consistent using status and change.
But we've now introduced the number of students that are in each of these student populations.
So for white students, it's 5,200.
For students with disabilities, it's 25,000.
So there's quite a bit of difference in those student groups.
And so it tells you a lot of information.
Still on that same page, you would get to additional information, some tables that we've created that show trends year over year, information about, for example, for academic, for Cal Alt results, and then for our English learner performance within the English learner student group.
So just a flavor for word choices that we still have not arrived at decisions on.
And I'd welcome if you have any additional ones that you've been following as well, because I know that some of you have been introduced to this redesigned dashboard over the last month.
But options that we've heard from folks, and again, this has been a list we've been maintaining,
is for parents, the distance from level three is still just a real stumbling block.
It's not intuitive.
So these are just, they're not exhaustive lists, but we put up three options.
Distance from standard, distance from target.
Let's keep with the same thing, distance from level three.
The other is we heard that equity report, student group performance wasn't intuitive either.
number of student groups in each performance level.
How many student groups fall in each level?
And then finally, just student group, that name.
We had a parent session one evening, and somebody said, that sounds like they're in a club.
What club are they in?
I'm like, that's not what student group means.
So that's
That's real.
That's a valid understanding of what the term student group means.
And so while this is a much more friendlier version of the dashboard, we're still going to need to make some of these tweaks.
And so I'm happy to answer questions, but we are really appreciative of your support and feedback and are very excited to be able to publicly release this come December.
Okay, Board Member Strauss.
So, first of all, Cindy, to you and your team, I mean, I've been in conversations probably every week with you and this has changed so many times to you and to Sarah and to the whole team that's been working on this.
The field is saying it's much better, although there's still some areas, obviously, that you've highlighted that we need to tweak.
So if you go back to that tile, I think it's improved with the equity report and
how all the groups are doing, and the reason I say that is it tells you in a district, and I thought you illustrated this really carefully, like, this district has an orange rating, but they still have five groups that are doing well in green, but you got some red and oranges you gotta pay attention to and some yellows.
So I actually like the fact that we're able to see where all the groups are.
The only thing my recommendation would be is that, and I know it's about font and how much space there is, but it seems to make more sense to me, personally,
is the number of student groups in each performance level.
Like what does that mean?
So it says student group performance.
I think we just need a few more words there and I know there's some issue of space.
So I just would say it's much better.
I like equity report number of student groups and I like all the groups being, I think that's really reflective of the whole.
how a whole school district is doing, but I would like to have a little more descriptor there.
And my colleagues may have some other opinions, but just student per group performance by, I don't know.
So your two choices, that to me just makes a little more sense.
So just wanted to add that.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
So I know you've been waiting for this because you've had you said it was 3, 4, 0.
This is actually you're getting to base.
You are.
Yeah.
There's some compliments on this.
And I want to I want to say thank you for hearing my feedback when the equity report was not previously outlined.
And so I like it.
I do think it needs to be spelled out a little bit more.
I understand the issue with real estate space here.
maybe bolding equity report.
It doesn't, the whole thing doesn't have to be bolded, but I would like to see bolding equity report for consistency with the other eye grabbing numbers like 78% graduating within four years that grabs my attention.
And so we need to bold equity report so that it also calls my eye to that.
But I think that this is nicely done.
It's such a huge improvement.
I know that the Spanish translation is also
being translated properly.
So kudos to you, the department, and everyone for working on this.
Thank you.
I should mention that San Joaquin County Office of Education also maintains the electronic IEP system for the state, which is SACE, and they have a group of Spanish translators who translate Spanish IEPs, and they have committed to using that same team for the dashboard.
So folks that are familiar with, if they have students who are receiving an IEP, this will be a Spanish translation that is familiar to them.
Board Member Holiday.
I think it was a couple years ago I made a snarky comment in here about the state needing a graphic designer.
And I think you've got one now.
And this is so much better.
I hated the pies too.
And this is so much clearer, so much easier.
I do agree with all the comments being made about word choice.
And I'm impressed that you have, all of you that have been working on this, have the courage to actually make such a dramatic change in the look and the appearance of it.
Because that's not an easily done thing, you know.
But you did it and it's going to be great.
It's going to be so much better for parents as well as educators.
About the priority one, priority two, priority three, I don't really think you need to mention the words priority one or whatever.
That doesn't mean anything to parents in particular.
And then we see we've got priority one, two, and three, and then we could jump to six.
Wait, where's four and five?
And so I think that, so my recommendation would be getting rid of those.
But I'm just, I'm so happy with the effort and the outcome that is going on here with the dashboard.
Remember Valdez I'm very excited.
I think you did a beautiful job though the work that's being done I think it's going to be well received as it has been already as you've rolled it out I just want to give kudos to that you were doing this in a phone format because that's going to be so important because most of our Parents don't have home computers anymore and the phone is their computer And so I think that was really really smart and I think that's going to be very well appreciated.
So, thank you Remember son
Thank you.
So I wanted to add my kudos as well.
It's a great way to end this presentation with all the poking we did to you today over this last four hours.
So it really kudos to you.
And this is I was also very, very excited to see this.
It's a communication tool for the parents, but it's also a communication tool to our teachers, my governing board.
It just makes the information so much more accessible to everyone.
So, yeah, just wanted to add my kudos.
Thanks.
Board Member Rocker.
Well, so I'll begin by saying yes, thank you.
And I also want to thank you.
Something else that folks don't know is the amount of time that you put in working with not only stakeholder groups, but with each of the individual board members to do the preview and to get their feedback and to make sure
the work from stakeholders was strongly represented.
And what we're seeing today is really important.
I know that you're still working on the nuances of the language, the exposition that's going to be given.
And that's something that you can continue working on even through the preview period.
So, what's really important here is particularly on the definitions of what an English learner is and what a foster youth is.
is that not only are we giving a consistent explanation, but that explanation is consistent with the intent of the indicator.
So that we're not promising in the description of what the indicator says more than what the indicator actually is going to report.
So, again, I'm happy to see the changes that were made.
As to the criticism about the pie, I'm just going to quote our former president and say, well, who doesn't like pie?
But...
But that's okay because this does give a more visual and immediate way of seeing and understanding the comparison.
I am really pleased and I agree with what board member Ortiz-Lincoln said concerning the equity report.
It is really important that that also has a level of prominence that is retained as we make this transition from the previous reporting format to this one.
Okay.
Any other comments?
No?
Okay.
Yes, I know.
How do we want to handle lunch?
Okay.
So we'll move then to public comment on these items.
Will the following people please line up?
Doug McRae, Mary Perry, Martha Diaz, Jan Corner, Sergio Mendez, Danny Espinoza, Brian Rivas, Jessica Succo, Efren Marcado, Samantha Tran, Martha Alvarez, Anna, I think, Fontes, Andrea Ball, John Affeld.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired test publisher and required education measurement specialist.
Given California's multiple measures status and change accountability system, we should have a fair amount of focus on the stability of the system over time, particularly the change part of the system.
One policy principle that Ed Hartle drilled into everybody 15 to 20 years ago was, if you want to measure change, then don't change the measure.
The mantra of continuous improvement applies nicely to curriculum instruction, but it flies in the face of this principle cited by Hartle for the assessment and the accountability portions.
This conflict does not bode well for a smooth rollout of California's new status and change multiple measure system for the next few years until the change component settles down for many of the multiple measures involved.
I say that despite the redesign, which I also think
as you did, that it was very well done.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Martha Zaragoza Diaz representing Californians Together.
We support the inclusion of the state seal of biliteracy in the college and or career readiness indicator.
However, we adamantly oppose the addition of math as a requirement to the prepared designation of the state seal for the following reasons.
The state seal reflects the attainment of high levels of language and literacy in English and a second language.
Mathematics doesn't.
It is unrelated to the proficiency goals of the state seal.
If the state board wishes to send the message to the field,
that math and ELA scored at three or higher level is necessary for college and or career readiness, then make these indicators requirement for the CCI and allow LEAs to choose one other proposed measures for inclusion in the CCI.
This would provide consistency across the board regarding the CCI with respect to math and ELA.
We request that you not add or not support the addition of the math requirement to the state seal of biliteracy and include it as a standalone measure.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Mary Perry.
I'm representing the California State PTA.
And one of the conversations earlier this morning talked about the purpose of the accountability system being to incentivize and bring focus to those things that you as a board and the state as a whole thinks are most important.
The dashboard is for parents to be able to focus on those things.
That's why we really encourage you to include that high school chronic absenteeism measure and also to flag for people the upcoming inclusion of the science assessments in the dashboard and do it now.
We know implementation is an issue in the field and really hope that you take that into consideration.
Hello, good afternoon.
My name is Jan Correa, Chief Executive Officer of CABE, the California Association for Bilingual Education.
As you know, CABE and our partners, Californians Together, have been key supporters of the state seal of biliteracy and have worked side by side for its implementation with the CDE under the leadership of Superintendent Torlakson.
CABE supports the inclusion of the state syllabi literacy in the CCI as a standalone measure, and we strongly oppose the adding of the math requirement to the state syllabi literacy.
The state syllabi literacy's intent, as per legislation, is to measure and award the attainment of academic, bilingual, and biliteracy skills, speaking, listening, reading, and writing in English and another language.
The academic criteria that has been discussed and shared, as we've seen earlier today, is extremely rigorous.
Research by Patrice Aganda and others have shown that biliteracy itself is a preferred skill across 10 sectors of our economy, and students who are biliterate are seen as successful in college and career readiness.
Tom.
While success in math achievement is a skill we strive to attain for all of our students, it is not an appropriate measure for determining biliteracy.
Again, CABE supports the inclusion of the state seal of biliteracy in the CCI as a standalone measure and we request the State Board of Education not approve the inclusion of the math requirement to the state seal of biliteracy.
Thanks very much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sergio Mendoza, not Mendez.
I wish I was related to him, and hopefully that doesn't start my time.
I would like to get back in the circle, but we'll see what happens.
I'm here.
I'm the current secretary for CASQA, which is the California Association of Supervisors for Child Welfare and Attendance.
So, I'm that person now.
I also am part of the board for San Joaquin section.
We have four sections in our state and we do provide a lot of professional development annually as well as during the year at each of our sections regarding
attendance and SARB and I'm a practitioner of that process also and I'm in the option for the 31 days.
I believe that the six-week period that we would have with students and individuals will give us enough time
to implement some of the necessary steps to ensure that they graduate, ensure that we find out what they may need to be successful in school, or even recommend another location for school within our schools that we have presently.
And again, with Ed Code 48-240-4824, it allows us to do that child welfare in attendance.
So, thank you.
Good afternoon, thank you for the opportunity to comment.
Anna Fontes, great pronunciation with the Link Learning Alliance.
Hundreds of schools are using evidence-based approaches such as Link Learning California Partnership Academies and other high quality
college and career pathways to prepare their students to be successful in multiple paths beyond high school.
We appreciate the board's commitment to remain on track with the inclusion of measures such as work-based learning, industry certificates, and urge the board to continue to seek the input across many stakeholders, including employers in the business community.
We feel the current structure of the college and career indicator, college slash career indicator, excuse me,
strongly favors students who thrive in traditional academic settings within K-12 and doesn't incentivize schools and districts to create programs that authentically align with the workforce as well as post-secondary needs.
The unintended consequences referenced by members are already occurring and will continue to inequitably track students and perpetuate achievement and skills gaps.
under this accountability framework.
Thank you for your time and thank you for your efforts.
Good afternoon.
Michael Flores-Castaneda.
Honored to be back here again this year representing the California Teachers Association.
CTA supports the addition of the State Seal of Biliteracy, Golden State Seal, Merit Diploma, and the JROTC to the CCI indicator on the dashboard.
We do have some concerns.
I would ask the board to consider the unintended consequences, which Board Member Rucker and a couple others have addressed this morning.
to the 2019 graduates who are on track to earn the state seal of biliteracy this year.
And we would just ask the board to consider postponing the adding the math criteria this year.
Thank you.
Hi, Angela DeRamos, also representing California Teachers Association.
And while we appreciate and like the streamlining of the student data on the new card system, sometimes the usability for different stakeholders, there's something to be lost.
One significant piece that is lost is the equity report that shows the different groups on one page.
When we're planning things like programs and LCAP and how we're going to
address the achievement gaps between different groups.
That piece of information is lost, so we encourage either putting it back or finding some other way to give that data.
Thank you.
Hello, Jessica Sacco, California Science Teachers Association.
Two days and five years ago today, the State Board of Education voted to adopt the California Next Generation Science Standards.
That action elicited applause and even a few whoops from those in the audience that day.
Since then, the state board, the department, teachers, businesses, higher ed, nonprofits representing a huge range of perspectives have come together in one form or another in an effort to help realize a vision of a high quality science education for all kids K through 12.
Standards implementation requires a systemic, multi-year, multi-faceted approach.
That is why I'm here today to urge you to include a placeholder for science on the 2018 California School Dashboard.
It is a critical piece of our education system.
Simply put, the dashboard informs LCAPS.
LCAPS should advance standards implementation, and the lack of science on the current dashboard is leading to a lack of investment in NGSS implementation.
You've heard from PTA.
You'll hear from others today.
The field is ready for this information so that it's public and available for all in order to inform these multi-year plans to support NGSS.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, my name is Efren Mercado here on behalf of the California STEM Network, which is a statewide network as well as 13 regional networks who support science education, STEM education for kids across our state.
We will echo the comments of Jessica Sacco from CSTA.
The main priority for us for the CAS to be in the dashboard is knowing that the dashboard drives the LCAP.
LCAP drives the investment.
Investment has not happened in science across the states.
We want to make sure it's in there.
We all know that science education and STEM education is going to be key for our kids as they move forward into the future and as a key equity driver.
So we wanted to advocate state board to include that placeholder in the dashboard.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
I first wanted to start by thanking CDE and the State Board staff for all the work on the system to date.
We know this is a big lift and there's been a lot of good effort on that front.
In particular, I want to call out CDE staff on the website redesign work.
It's been very collaborative and we've been appreciative of that.
I'd like to echo the Science Teacher Association and California STEM Network
comments about the dashboard and the inclusion of NGSS as a placeholder this year.
In addition, the chronic absenteeism rate issue is something that we care deeply about and would encourage the board to include a color coding rating on the dashboard for state accountability purposes if we can't figure out the federal ones.
We looked at some of this, the publicly available data, and found that for high schools, over a quarter of them, half the kids are exceeding the rate of chronic absenteeism.
And so this is clearly a statewide issue.
It's an important issue for locals to focus on.
And in addition, we know that it's impactful for the children's outcomes and is actionable at the local level.
Thank you very much.
Daniel Espinoza from the Learning Policy Institute.
I'd like to offer comments today on three indicators, the five-year grad rate, the CCI, and chronic absenteeism.
We appreciate the progress towards including five-year graduation rates into the dashboard, and given current data limitations, we support the staff recommendation to report five-year graduation rates for information purposes only in the 2018 dashboard.
However, we reiterate the importance of moving swiftly to include five-year graduation rates for accountability purposes in the 2019 dashboard, as 36 states have done.
Additionally, LPI supports the inclusion of additional measures into the college slash career indicator in the fall 2018 dashboard.
With respect to the state seal of biliteracy, research shows that biliteracy is a strong measure of both college and career readiness.
We know, however, that other measures are prepared on the CCI has been commented today do not require a mathematics standard.
We urge the board to consider a more consistent application of a mathematics standard across the CCI so as not to disproportionately impact a single racial, ethnic, or linguistic subgroup.
Finally, of the 36 states in the District of Columbia using chronic absenteeism as an indicator under ESSA, 34 are using the indicator for all grades K-12.
Only three states, including California, are limiting its use to specific grades.
California should consider including these rates for all grades, not just K-8, in the state's dashboard.
Thank you.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First I want to say thank you for the work to improve the dashboard.
We think it's greatly improved and like what we see.
This morning I was concerned by the conversation around the CCI, the College and Career Indicator.
Seems like some more work is needed.
We think among all the indicators, CCI is the single most important.
And it would seem that we need to be crystal clear on what it is, what we want it to tell us, and then we can turn to how we measure it.
Seems like somehow, and I know they're building, they're doing a lot of work in building the new system, but it seemed like the staff jumped to how to measure before those first two points were addressed.
On the narrow point about math and the state seal by literacy, we agree with our partners at Caltog and CABE that the state seal is rigorous in and of its own.
And we think the dashboard would have a big hole if you leave chronic absence out for high schools.
John Affeld from Public Advocates.
Appreciate all the hard work that's been done and the conversation on the CCI in particular.
Public Advocates in the Equity Coalition see this as a college and career indicator much in the way that board member Rucker and Ortiz-Lacon mentioned it and we expect that the
indicators will prove worthy of both outcomes and not one or the other.
In that regard, we are concerned with the inconsistency of the application of different indicators.
AP alone, IB as a standalone, dual enrollment as a standalone can currently be done without a math component.
And maybe we didn't realize that at the time, but that's a hole that needs to be addressed.
And either you drop the math component from the state sealed by literacy or we have a nearly met math across the board, including for the Golden State Diploma.
Tom.
Also, we just saw data for the first time that 6.5% of Golden State Diploma holders don't reach the nearly met math level.
So we think the overriding concern is one of consistency.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
First, I also echo that thanks to the CDE and state board staff on the improvements to the dashboard.
We definitely are encouraged by the new display and think will be a great resource for parents to understand the progress and performance of students across the state in California.
Second, we also provide our significant appreciation to CDE staff and state board staff for the memos, trying to provide information about the development of the future indicators and how they'll be incorporated into the dashboard.
With that said, our members continue to be interested and supportive of the college and career indicator.
They do see it as an and, not an or or choice for students.
We are encouraged by the addition of new indicators to the CCI, as well as other indicators like the five-year graduation rate down the road.
Despite of what the board action will be today on the new metrics that will be added, we do encourage you to think about the dashboard and the indicators in totality, not thinking them out in isolation or one by one, but coming back at some point in the near future and thinking how they all work together comprehensively, given that it is one single accountability system.
Thank you.
Good morning, Andrea Ball on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
Three brief comments.
First, we're very pleased and support the recommendation to add the additional measures to the college career indicator.
We think this makes it a much richer and more robust indicator.
We do share the concerns with CABE, Californians Together, and others about using math as part of the state seal of biliteracy and would urge you to not include that.
Second, we really commend the department and you all for the improvements on the dashboard.
As local governing members continue to improve their use and dialogue in using the dashboard, it's a really vital communication tool, and we think these improvements really are going in the right direction.
We do echo and agree with the comments from the California Association of Science Teachers and Children to Get Children Now.
We would like to see a placeholder for the California science test.
I think this really does send, again, using the dashboard, it's an important communication tool, sending the message to the field that the science tests are coming and very important.
Thank you.
The board will get lunch and come back and reconvene at quarter of one.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're done with the public comment and the technical questions.
So I'm going to turn to our liaisons.
on the accountability area to make the next move, but we can have a comment.
Go ahead.
I'm sorry, just I know the liaisons need to help us work through this.
I just want to make one quick comment.
I do appreciate the great concern that I think all of us in the room have about the science NGSS standard rollout and progress being made there and the test scores.
Cindy?
I'm sorry.
Do you have, remind me again, when is it possible for science test scores to be displayed on the dashboard?
What's the prediction?
I'm sorry.
The earliest would be 2020.
We could bring, you know, we can start, we've already been talking about this obviously to date and we were invited to talk to the science CISC.
group about the challenges of leaving it as a coming soon because we don't know where it's going to be incorporated.
Whether or not it's going to be incorporated into academic indicator or it's a standalone measure.
So the hesitation on our part too is what we've seen with chronic absenteeism.
We send you a link to the data and then it applies to things that it may not, you ultimately may decide it doesn't apply to.
Understood.
So there's lots of complications to it coming down the pipe that we have to talk about.
And people have been using this word term placeholder, and I don't know what that would mean.
I mean, we'd have one of those little gauges without an arrow in it, you know, or something like that, which I don't know would be very helpful to people.
But I'm wondering whether or not it wouldn't be possible somewhere.
on the dashboard to have a note to have and some bit of information that explains that the Because teachers educators parents even kids even have heard about the science, you know tests and scores and all that
So having some sort of explanation somewhere on the dashboard that would give public recognition to the fact that the science test scores will be included on the dashboard, but it's not sure when or how or that sort of thing.
That might be helpful.
Let me follow up.
So we've been doing a lot of talk about where we are in science and will be in November.
having a comprehensive item for the board and our stakeholders on science.
And on that, we want to review over the five years where we've been from the standards adoption, the framework writing, the materials recommendation will come to the board in November from IQC.
Most of the materials that have been
The submitted were recommended for approval, but not all.
We also want to hear from the early implementers on what's been happening with the implementation of standards.
We also want an update from ETS on our science assessment, where we are, what data they're telling us, what the reliability is.
We hear a lot about that and we propose because we're going to do a whole comprehensive science discussion.
Remember that the discussion of the dashboard placeholder be done at that time based on the fact that we'll see what the reliability is, what's happening with the pilot, what they can inform us.
So just for the public and for all our stakeholders, we want a comprehensive.
We've been already planning this item and we think that maybe all of that at the same time might be the best time to talk all about science.
Board Member Williams.
So I support member Holliday in his request as it's an alternative for consideration for us in November.
An alternative to a gauge that doesn't have any data behind it could be a notation somewhere that explains about NGSS and when it's coming and that it will be on the dashboard and reported out publicly.
I appreciate the fact that the board
staff and leadership have decided to do a November session that is going to really focus on science.
It's the first time we've had a major focus on NGSS in a long time.
And I know that CDE staff has been working with
Science Teachers Association and K-12 Alliance at WestEd and a lot of others to do professional learning workouts, rollouts, not workouts, rollouts.
But I think it is true.
I do believe that it has been the fact that it's not on the dashboard and that it's not, we haven't done a session focusing on NGSS at the state board.
There's been a very weak signal, in my opinion, from the State Board about the importance of NGSS up until this point.
Not intentional.
We've had a lot on our plates and a lot of other stuff going on.
Totally understand that.
But this is, since the next test is supposed to be the first operational test.
in the spring of 2019, it's really time that we go ahead and do this.
So I appreciate the board leadership for making that a priority for November.
And I think in the context of getting all of those updates, we can decide then what's the best way to send a signal on the dashboard about NGSS.
Yeah, while we're on this, I'd like to request a report in November on the pilot test.
Those of us that have been close, not now in November, those of us that have followed this, this is quite an innovative assessment.
And I'm reluctant to move to some policy conclusions till I see what happened with this pilot test.
It's very innovative, three-dimensional,
And so you're making projections, but I'm not sure how you can do that solidly without knowing what the pilot test showed.
All right, thank you.
Carrick Ashley, just wanted to clarify, I'd be glad to do something in November, probably will not include actual student data.
No, I want to know how it went.
Correct.
Is it, it could be the test could be delayed if it, you know, a lot of the items don't work.
I mean, to me, this is a different test conceptually than anything we've dealt with.
I'm not interested in student scores.
I want to get what the projection is for getting this online.
And I don't think we have the information now to give an answer to that.
Thank you.
By online, I mean, making a decision about how soon it's going to be phased in.
Okay.
So Cindy, I'm getting ready to make a motion.
But I want to ask a question about the first item.
So the recommendation is up on the screen for people who are needing their memory refreshed.
There's some concern raised by both board members and also from our public commenters about the first item.
And so I want to just ask a question about what the downside is or what would happen if we asked to delay that first inclusion of those indicators in the CCI and have you come back and do a little bit more conversation with us about, you know, the correlation between different indicators and why decisions were made and the consistency issue that was raised today.
Because my concern is I don't want to delay it because I know a number of people really would like to see one or more of those items included in the CCI so it becomes more and more robust.
But I also don't want to, you know, not be successful in a motion to include those.
So I just want to know a little bit about what would happen if we asked to delay action on number one until November.
So what we will be doing between now and November is using the class of 2018 data and running Our simulations against that to recommend cut scores if if the board You know is asking us by way of your question to create two different sets of cut scores that's of course a lot of additional work with again 70 million records and
My suggestion would be maybe we do not include the information.
We keep it to what you've already approved.
Because in a lot of these groups, it's not large numbers of students.
And perhaps there's students that are showing that they're prepared through another measure.
I need to talk a little bit more with Jenny, but you saw it was on our workload for November.
I do hesitate to have an option A and an option B ready, but I think the cut scores potentially could be considered valid and reliable, the recommendation, if you decided to, at the last minute, put them back in.
But if you delay it altogether and don't move on this come November, the major category that students will demonstrate preparedness is by the Smarter Balanced assessment because that's what we see in the current data set.
So it is truly going to be the test driving this measure as well as our new academic measure for grade 11, which is Smarter Balanced.
So just want to make sure that that's shared.
I'm prepared to make a motion.
So, I'm going to recommend we approve the CD recommendation with the modification of the inclusion of the sealed biliteracy removing the math requirement.
So, everything that you've recommended with the modification on that number one.
Second.
Okay.
Any further board discussion?
I am concerned about the ROTC language that appears right here instead of JROTC.
I mean, if this is a on-the-record motion, don't we have to be precise about the terminology here for this one?
What would you like to change to?
Well, honestly, I don't know what the course code language is.
The course code language is Leadership Military Science.
So if we eliminated the words Reserve Officer Training Corps, ROTC, it would more accurately reflect the full breadth of programs that students are in that course for.
So I'd accept that as an edit.
I accept as a second.
So this is leaving aside all the issues about college and career and the consistency.
So we would be approving the, under this motion, the Golden State as proposed?
Yes.
And we would not be worried about the consistencies among the measures if this is approved?
Well, I mean, I think a follow-up would be, I would request that the staff do continued study and bring back to CPAG and our advisory groups the issue of consistency and follow-up.
But it allows us, if this passes, to get some other indicators than what we currently have in with the understanding that we have the benefit of revisiting it next year and looking at the issues of consistency.
I could support it with the exception of taking the Golden State Seal merit diploma.
Yeah, I think we need to look at that particular measure.
All right, well, so I'll modify it.
So we've got number one, the inclusion of SEAL biliteracy with the removal of math.
Remove the Golden State SEAL diploma completely and modify the language for the leadership military science and approve the rest.
Do you accept those edits?
Reluctantly, so I will second the amended.
I just ask that the department again come back and talk about the interactions between the inclusion of certain indicators and how they're using it because
Well, I'll just say what I'm concerned about, about taking out the Golden State seal is that all of this, they ran through all of our advisory committees.
They ran through TDG, which is what we really rely on.
We rely on those technical folks to say, yes, this meets our criteria or it doesn't.
And we're overriding TDG by doing that.
And that's what makes me very concerned.
Board member Rucker.
I'm not concerned about overriding the recommendation of the TDG because it is only a recommendation.
I'm concerned that the internal consistency of all of these elements needs to be considered, needs to be clear, and it needs to have a common consensus among all of us about what that consistency should look like.
We're not ready to do that with all of these elements.
So it is important to remove or at least edit some of these.
But also, if this motion is being contemplated, knowing we can go down the road and change it, I'm not comfortable with just voting the motion so that we can move forward knowing it's, you know, a year from now, we'll change our minds and do something else different.
We also need to tell the field that this is the direction
the development of these elements is taking, we're not going to step back and say, oh, I want to change this again.
So if we're doing this motion so we can move forward, knowing that we're going to ask the staff to go and do some data runs because we may want to reconsider it.
The motion's not of much value today anyway.
I'm also concerned about this college and career issue and interested in pursuing discussion of post-secondary education.
I think college is vague to people.
Typically, in a lot of circles, it implies four-year colleges.
So, we've, you know, this flash career, it's dodging the issue.
So,
I think there's some fundamental problems here.
I'm still uneasy about as board member Rucker is about the whole enterprise.
Not that I don't support it, but that we have everything thought through here and we're adding measures here and there without the...
I'm conflicted because I want to support the Golden State.
I mean, I want to say seal of biliteracy and have some other indicators in the CCI.
But at the same time, I think we have some fundamental issues we haven't resolved yet.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I honestly don't know what our options are because if we just keep it, if we say we're going to delay this and keep the CCI as currently, as we currently have it, there is still inconsistency across the criteria for that.
So we are still leaving something that is inconsistent.
And then we miss opportunity of adding these two elements to the indicator for the December release.
Now, the bigger picture, I think we've had so much coming at us, but there has been a lot of letters, a lot of groups that have pointed out
the issues with this indicator.
Maybe we're the ones that are kind of late to the party of having that sense of, oh my, what are we building here?
But there's been a lot of different folks, scholars, researchers that have pointed at this and have said
What are you building?
Because what we initially heard presentations was around college and career.
And then it started drifting into something else to the point where now we really are saying, well, it could be either or.
It's non-bindery.
You make it what you want.
And that's not OK for us to tell the field
Just make, you know, define it as you may, because we're the ones setting the policy here.
But I don't know what other alternatives we have, because we would have to essentially say, let's shut this down and start all over.
And I think we're too far down the road, although we do have a system of continuous improvement.
I don't know that continuous improvement means that we completely go back and say the last two years has not been a good use of anyone's time and we have something that is not a viable or reliable indicator.
Just, I appreciate the rich discussion this morning and it's, I also am very supportive of the proposed motion as amended.
I think that we do need to go beyond standardized test scores in our accountability system.
We have to look at multiple measures.
And I think there's a research foundation that's very strong for including the state seal of biliteracy.
I also want to avoid the perception that we're adding other levels.
And I know that by including math, it doesn't prohibit a student from earning the state seal.
This is just for accountability.
But if there's even a perception or a signal out in the field or in the public that we are singling out one particular measure unfairly or inconsistently, then that's a problem.
So I think that your revised motion addresses that and I think allows us to have another measure.
So I would, I'm very supportive of the motion.
I don't want to delay
adding other measures because I think we have to demonstrate how well we are preparing our students for life beyond high school graduation and we need multiple measures to be able to tell that story.
Board Member Valdez.
So I can support the motion as it was made, but I also think fundamentally and what President Kurtz talked about, I think the elephant in the room is that out in the field, we're saying we are preparing students to have options, to have a college and career choice.
That's their option.
It's not an or, and the or for me relays more tracking and this is the pathway you're going and you're stuck on that pathway.
that the conversation I think still needs to happen about post-secondary or whatever we're going to call it within all of this but for now I think we need to move forward.
I think the other problem the motion doesn't address is what came up during the conversation today that somehow the name of the indicator or the meaning of the indicator itself seems to change between one level or the other.
If we're talking about the approaching preparedness, it's college and career.
If we're talking about prepared, it's college or career.
And then if we go to the next one, well prepared, it's college and career.
That's not what I voted for when we actually implemented this indicator.
So now we're going to add indicators
and add criteria for those indicators in two of these levels today, and we're still not clear on what it means.
So if we're going to add this data, that's nice because adding the, what I'm hearing is I want to move forward on the motion because we really want to send a message to the field that these elements are important.
Well, we need to send a message to the field.
These elements are important and here's how you're supposed to apply them in the decisions you make and creating access for students and giving students advice.
And we're not doing that.
We're not adding any clarity with that.
So I'm actually not ready to support this motion because there were more questions actually put on the table in today's conversation that this motion does not resolve.
If we could divide the motion, I know you attempted to amend it, but if we could divide the motion and make an affirmative statement on what will be added and what won't be added, that's one thing.
But if we're going forward to saying that this motion further defines how this is going to operate, which is what was implied in the conversation, that's something else and I'm concerned about that.
Okay, go back over what the motion, I think we're ready now.
After you accepted the friendly amendments, where are we?
What?
Council will attempt to restate the motion subject to the two amendments that were made, accepted and seconded, as I understand it.
This applies only to the first part of the CD recommendation, so the
The motion to approve the city recommendation as to parts 2, 3, and 4 remains unchanged.
So I'm going to repeat back and please confirm that we all have the same understanding of the modified motion is to approve the inclusion of the state seal of biliteracy.
and leadership slash military science as additional measures in the college career indicator.
So striking Golden State SEAL merit diploma and striking the colon reserve officer training courts.
And removing the math requirement from the SEAL.
And then also for the SEAL biliteracy striking the inclusion of the additional math level to approaching prepared or nearly met.
Okay.
We're straight on the motion.
Clerk will call the roll.
Unchanged.
Okay.
So, Bruce Holliday.
Yes.
Emma Cardenas.
Vicki Sandoval.
Yes.
Trish Williams.
Ting Sung.
Yes.
But can we please bring back the discussion about the infrastructure?
Okay.
Mike Kearse.
I'm in the same yes spot.
Eileen Strauss.
Sue Burr.
Feliz Ortiz-Lucon.
Karen Valdez.
Patricia Rucker.
Okay, it's unanimous.
Thank you.
All right, thank you.
All right, now we're ready to move on to item two.
So we made it to the second item.
But the first one had about six elements in it.
So, I mean, it's not... So, Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
So, we did not have a system of support item for you back in July.
As you may remember, our Director of the Improvement Accountability Division, Melanie Sheppy Green,
went on maternity leave.
She hopefully will return in time for a November item.
So we are presenting an item on the system of support.
It's a joint item between CDE and Westat and CCEE.
Normally we would have county offices as part of this presentation of system support because they're a major part of this team, but we do have current RFPs out there
that relate to county offices and this specific item.
So we wanted to make sure that there was no conflict of having one of them present.
So as you may remember, Melanie Sheppey-Green always liked to start her presentations with pictures of photos of students to kind of ground us and remind us of why we're doing this.
So in her honor, we are going to start this presentation.
with a future student in California.
This is Joshua Christopher Green, who was born on July 1.
As you can see, he's got his little onesie on here that says, my green boy is blue, with a nice little pie here.
So.
So that was my wife's doing, by the way.
So by December, of course, we will release the new dashboard, and we will have outgrown the pies.
And as you'll see from the picture, by December, so will he.
So, to make the presentation this morning, to start the presentation, it's my pleasure to introduce for you Shanine Coates.
Since Melanie went on maternity leave, Shanine has been serving as our acting division director.
for the Improvement Accountability Division.
Prior to that, she was working directly for me as the branch administrator for all of our divisions in our branch.
And she's been very active in this system of support work.
And so she's going to start our autumn off this afternoon.
Suneet.
Thank you, Carrick, members of the board.
The goal for today is to walk us through sort of our system of support journey over the last 18 plus months.
Give an eye into our path moving forward and really California's vision for the system of support and some emerging answers we have from the Budget Act provisions of 2018.
And then walk through what's next in terms of year two planning and development.
with a keen eye on county capacity building and our statewide communications and coordination efforts.
So you have received nine updates regarding the system of support.
The first being actually back in August 2016.
I think that it's important when we talk about the system of support that we really talk about it in context with these three interconnected elements that are all related to our 10 state priorities.
So the California School Dashboard, which we just had robust discussion around in item one.
The local control accountability plans, which is where LEAs work with stakeholders to include goals, actions, and services.
And then finally, the California system of support, which is responsive, designed to be responsive to the needs identified locally.
This draft graphic is from CDE Press and Stephanie Gregson actually commissioned this.
And in response to some requests that we had to present the system of support in a sort of friendlier manner.
And so we're working on various materials.
So this is just one draft graphic just to let you know that we are on that track and we have heard that call.
Also to point out, that August 2016 memo is where we first identified that we would have three levels of support.
So just to clarify, level one being support for all, that foundational support, level two for those LEAs identified for differentiated assistance, and then level three, which is coming soon, around intensive supports.
So you've seen our goal, but I just want to just continue to point out that the system of support really is designed for each student.
It's not one student.
It's not some students.
We're designing this to meet the needs of each student served.
That's our goal.
And it's focused around building the capacity, meaning what resources are responsive to the local needs to sustain improvement and effectively address inequities.
And inequities being whatever unfairness or injustices are currently occurring with regards to student opportunities and outcomes.
In June 2017, you saw an SPE memo that identified the framework for the system moving forward.
And there we actually identified some key questions that have really guided the work.
And I hope that as we go through this item, you'll see the connections here.
So first, we wanted to know what structures are going to help us meet our goal.
We wanted to know, second, how will agencies coordinate statewide while still remaining responsive to local needs?
We wanted to know what research and past experience indicates would be most effective in terms of assisting student groups.
We wanted to know what types of assistance educators would find helpful.
how, excuse me, how we would advance the goal of building capacity, local capacity that is, and then finally how we were going to go about continuing to narrow and then close the achievement gaps and share successes so that could be done statewide.
So what's our path moving forward and sort of what's the why behind the what before we get into the budget?
So I'd like to submit that we've done a lot of work since the passage of LCFF.
We have rolled out the dashboard.
There have been modifications to the dashboard.
We have
local agencies and stakeholders surrounding around the LCAP and those goals, actions, and services.
We have a statewide system of support planning team, which has grown to include our education and equity stakeholders.
And we have this emerging system of support.
And now we have a budget that is really providing some infrastructure to what we've been doing.
So what's different?
Well, we have at its core, our system really insists that local decision makers are owning this process, but we know they can't do it alone.
We know that there's a collective responsibility.
Put simply, the job of the support agencies is to help a district get the right resources at the right time, and that's responsive to their needs.
And so that's really the shift that we're talking about as far as the approach to assistance.
It's not someone else's job.
It's all of our jobs.
And if I, as a support partner, don't have the resource that an LEA is requiring, then it's my job to reach out and to connect that LEA with that resource that's going to be responsive to their needs.
So that connection and that coordination piece is what we've built into the budget, what the legislature has built into the budget.
So why is this different?
Back in September 2017, we did lay out some research regarding our past efforts.
And we found that, honestly, whether they were state or federal, there was a little bit of disjointedness.
And so the plan now is that we're bringing it all together.
We're putting it all in one.
We don't want separate systems, separate regional systems, et cetera.
We want them to work in concert with one another.
So there's no wrong door to assistance.
And again, the right resource at the right place at the right time.
So I just want to go back one second and just say that our past efforts let us know that there was really something fundamental that needed to be changed.
It's not that we necessarily needed better or different resources.
We've created, California has quite a bit of resources that are available to LEAs.
But what we noted is that there's a problem in connecting LEAs and schools to the resources that are available.
And so that's really the issue that we were trying to solve.
So it's been noted that county offices of education are the primary providers for a differentiated assistance.
But when thinking through this, we have to consider a couple of things.
So on one hand, an LEA shouldn't be required on its own
to figure out the underlying cause of low performance, determine what's going to be a potential solution or response to that, locate that potential solution or response, and then finally adapt that solution or response to their local context.
On the other hand, it's not necessarily feasible to think that
every single county office of education, all 51 in the state, know exactly what's going on throughout the state.
And so that's why the question came about, how does the system of support allow agencies charged with support to do their jobs?
And so the state budget answers that, essentially, or begins to answer that, with the structure specifically which
Defines roles and responsibilities throughout the state particularly around the geographic leads and as well as the expert leads providing a primary point of contact for for the County Office of Education or for the LEAs and then also allowing us as a state to identify what gaps and expertise exist and and fill those gaps and
So the Budget Act provisions of 2018, we could say that they are in two buckets, if you may.
One, which clarifies and enhances the existing roles and responsibilities, and then the other that provides the infrastructure to build capacity, to develop expertise, and to ensure coordination.
So, this is a summary of the provisions that are related to the system of support.
The item goes into them in detail, so I won't necessarily go into them in detail, but forthcoming, we will have a presentation regarding the lead agencies.
and we'll also have additional information about how we're going to, what's next as far as coordination.
So that will be coming to you.
But if you do have specific questions about particular elements of this, we're here to, we can certainly answer those questions.
I do want to point out that many of these are ongoing funding, whereas some past efforts were one-time funding.
And so that is one change as well.
So as part of the budget, in addition to the funding that's being provided, there are some key structures and statewide coordination that are required.
So there's a formal communication process that's now required between the agencies, including the geographic lead agencies, the CDE, and the California Collaborative, which will also pull in the various expert leads throughout the state.
And then there's also a formal stakeholder engagement process required.
And then, as I mentioned before, existing initiatives will be linked in.
For example, the Title III, county offices of education, multi-tiered system of support, et cetera.
So the California Collaborative for Education, the California Department of Education, State Board and the Department, State Board staff and the Department of Finance worked together to develop the selection process for the geographic lead agencies, community engagement initiative, and the special education resource leads.
And I would like to invite Suji Shin, the Chief of Staff for the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, to join me to discuss the lead agency selection process.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Board.
Suji Shin with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
Sorry.
Good afternoon, board.
Suji Shin with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
And as Shanine provided a framework for the overall system of support, I'm going to be diving in a little bit specifically and talking about some updates to the selection process for three key lead agencies as part of this process within the system of support.
And the first are the geographic lead agencies, which in the RFA are
Noted as lead agencies and so that is the sort of shorthand that you'll be seeing here The lead agency central goals as you see outlined in front of you are really to think about supporting how we support county offices And their districts to support the continuous improvement of student performance within their state priorities across student groups
to really think about how we are addressing achievement gaps between student groups and ultimately improving outreach and collaboration with stakeholders and engaging in deeper engagement processes to really ensure that the services, goals, and actions described in their LCAPs really do reflect the needs of that local context, especially for the historically underrepresented.
and low achieving populations.
And to support these goals, the RFA currently that is out, outlines a process by which we'll be selecting six to ten geographic leads across the state to carry on these roles.
The responsibility of the lead agencies in this context are threefold.
One is to sort of think about how they are facilitating conversations and work across the counties that they are serving.
To think about how they are
identifying existing, creating new resources as needed and connecting those resources across districts within their geographic catchment.
And then thirdly, thinking about how they are really acting as a hub and a kind of a lead in that kind of capacity building of their districts to support the needs of their students.
As I said, the proposals are, the RFA is currently open and proposals are due on the 20th of this month with the selection process occurring in October.
The second of these, the second of these agency, lead agency processes is the Community Engagement Initiative.
And that is a series of multi-year professional learning networks that build on district and community capacity to collaborate together
with a focus on improving student outcomes.
There are really four purposes or intents around the community engagement initiative.
One is to really think about how we are building capacity in communities and districts to have difficult conversations, to engage in more deeper meaningful engagement with their stakeholders with a focus on improving student outcomes.
Second is to really think about, through this process over the next several years, how we might identify effective models of community engagement that are highlighted up through this process, as well as the metrics to evaluate those models.
Third is in thinking about how we develop effective peer-to-peer partnerships between districts and county offices based on the CCE's professional learning network structure to ultimately deepen community engagement at that local level.
And then fourth is as a part through this process over the next six years, thinking about how we scale up this work to ultimately improve community engagement across the state, incorporate practices that really prove effective towards district and county office continuous improvement efforts.
The RFA on this is out and was due on or is due at the end of this month as well.
And then the third of the lead agency processes I'd like to sort of discuss with you today are the special education resource leads.
And this work is really focused on strengthening differentiated assistance provided to LEAs with a focus on improving the outcomes for our students with disabilities.
And the focus of this work will be identifying, coordinating, and calibrating services that help ultimately support the system's alignment across our state, that deal with supporting students with disabilities, how we incorporate evidence-based practices that ultimately demonstrate positive outcomes for students with disabilities.
There will be two types of special education resource leads that will be identified through this process.
And the first of these is the CellBus Systems Improvement Lead.
In this way, we are identifying a group of leads that will be applying as a partnership of three to four lead CellBus.
That will focus on capacity building through the training, the use of data, best practices, and evidence-based practices in root cause analysis, systems alignment, and coherence.
So again, we're really thinking about the systems alignment piece and the infrastructure around this work to support our students with disabilities.
The second type of special education resource leads, or the SELPA leads, will be the SELPA content lead.
And in this role, we are going to be identifying leads, county or SELPAs, that currently exhibit existing expertise in establishing systems, data practices, using cycles of improvement, as well as expertise in one of nine identified areas.
And these include things like increasing access to inclusive environments,
increasing access to quality curriculum and instruction, increasing strengthening early childhood preschool opportunities, improving transition services, increasing graduation rates with a diploma, reducing suspension expulsion, improving and increasing family engagement, reducing disproportionality across all areas, and improving support for English learners with disabilities.
So quickly across the sort of three sets of leads, we are looking at, in September, the geographic and community engagement applications being due, and the SELPA lead application being released for the systems improvement piece.
In October and November, the lead agencies will be selected, and we anticipate kicking this off in the winter this year.
So with that, I'm going to hand it off to Jason Willis with WestEd, who is going to talk a little bit more about next steps and some of our work around communication across our agency system.
Shanina was going to do the intro, but Suji scooped her.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
As Suji had mentioned, my name is Jason Willis.
I'm a director with WestEd.
And I'm up here today actually representing the California Comprehensive Center.
We were asked by the State Board of Education to help facilitate the kind of envisioned coordination and collaboration amongst the state agencies as they pursue the kind of design, build and implementation of this system of support.
So today, as Janine had prefaced before, just want to touch on some of the year two planning and development and give a little bit of context for some of those comments before we dive a little bit deeper.
So this is a look at currently all of the represented organizations and agencies at the system of support planning meetings.
We have between 30 and 40 folks that will show up every other month for these meetings.
A large majority of them, I would say, near 75% or 80% are consistent attendees, which is an important indicator for us as we think about the consistency and people understanding the history and development and participation in this work.
I'll point out a couple of distinctions here.
At the very top are the state agencies here in California that are considered the kind of primary purveyors of helping to design, build, and implement the systems.
You've got the State Board of Ed, the Department of Education, the CCEE, and the representative county agencies, CESA.
Those set of icons, logos in the middle, really represent the mix of both education advocate organizations as well as education associations that attend these sessions.
Importantly for the education associations, one of the requirements that we have for the planning group
is that they not only send a staff member, which, you know, if they're here in Sacramento, they can consistently attend, but they also bring a sitting member representative.
So if I'm from CSBA, I'm bringing a board member.
If I'm from CTA, I'm bringing a teacher, so on and so forth, which really kind of leads into that last set of logos you see there at the bottom, is that we think it's paramount, and particularly the state agencies think it's paramount importance, to ensure that practitioners are in the room.
These are the folks on the front line that are implementing this work and ensuring that their voice is in the room as state agencies consider the configuration of the ways in which they're deploying resources is important to the state agencies.
And so incorporating their voice, not just during the meeting, but also in some of the items that we go through is also really important.
So one of the things that we have consistently opened the planning group meetings up with is this diagram, and this is really indicative of the direction that
the state board of education, the other agencies really want to move.
That in years past, there has been almost outright competition that's existed between state agencies, resources, time, attention, et cetera.
And that we progressively want to be able to move along a continuum where they are communicating more regularly.
And those structures that have been set up through the planning group and some work group structures, I'll talk about a little bit later, have helped to push that along.
into coordination, right?
So you're able to actually start coordinating the work and the resources you are using to help support, in this case, districts and district leadership and their work with schools and teachers in the classroom.
And finally, arriving at this notion of collaboration, that this is
penultimate place that you would want to be in, which you can see in that kind of very brief working definition that two or more people, a team, are working together in a very coherent process towards a shared set of goals.
So the planning group has a set of goals.
And the state agencies and the associated organizations and practitioners have been moving towards them.
And we've seen some certain progress over the course of the last year with this group.
And that has been reflected in the year one feedback that we were collecting both from
state agencies, but also from districts and counties.
So looking forward to year two of continuing to deepen that by really bringing to the fore some issues that the field has brought to the planning group as things that need to be addressed.
So as a means to help create that vehicle and to create that action, the planning group designed five work groups that were all geared in large part around the needs that were emerging out of the year one feedback.
And I'm going to focus on the first two in a little bit more depth, but want to give you a sense of all five of these different areas.
And I'll talk a little bit more since I'm going to go into communications and county capacity, more about support for all, intensive support, and bright spots.
So the Support for All Level 1 really has been one of the most recent workgroups to get up and running.
In fact, the October planning session that is coming up in just under a month will focus almost exclusively on how state agencies and other organizations are thinking about these Supports for All and these Level 1 resources.
And interestingly, in one of the workgroup sessions, this notion of
perhaps changing the lens upon which we're thinking about support for all had come up, that perhaps it's not about necessarily capturing an entire universe of resources that are out there, but perhaps it's good to focus on mindset and the way that people are thinking about coordinating support to districts as a place to start, right?
So start, get some early wins before you can progress forward.
The intensive support for level three, a lot of their work has primarily focused on what I would describe as kind of early warning indicators.
So one of the realizations that this work group has been coming around to is that if you are looking to intervene with a district that's in that much
they were confronted by that many challenges, that we should be getting there earlier.
And there's probably things that we can identify that would allow us to know that they are already on that path and should be getting to them sooner.
And so this notion of kind of blending level two and three has started to come up.
And some research at a kind of in-person session will be presented next week.
talking about this field of early warning indicators that's been popularized in large part out of the University of Chicago, but has also been picked up in places like New York City and other states across the country.
And Bright Spots is the last of the five work groups.
Just briefly to touch on that, that this work is evolving what we have
had tried to do under NCLB in identifying those places, schools, districts, different programs and practices that have been effective in driving student achievement.
And one of the big lessons learned in our research review out of those previous efforts is that many of the schools or school districts that were identified, when you dig in a little bit deeper, it was almost more randomness.
than it was actually systematic.
And so one of the things that kind of reflects the principles of this work that the state and the state agencies are trying to support with districts is a systems approach.
That is that you're doing things very intentionally and you're doing it with a purpose that gets you an intended outcome.
And so the bright spots allows the state to not only tend to those that really do need the support, but also to raise up those
school districts and schools that can offer some insight for populations they're working with in circumstances that might be similar enough to other districts and other schools that they can really adopt those practices.
And again, thinking about this from the perspective of how is the system organized itself to create routines in which they can better predict those interventions and the outcomes that students are getting.
So I want to go a little bit deeper on the County Capacity Workgroup.
There's been two primary efforts that have driven the County Capacities Workgroup over the course of the last five or six months.
And again, this comes from the feedback that was presented to the state agencies in June.
First and foremost, that this notion of an improvement capacity framework, there seems to be some consensus in the planning group that while there's a lot of effort and a lot of resources that have now been put into the system to expect in a matter of, sorry,
in a matter of six or nine months to have student outcomes turn around as a result of that support is unrealistic.
And so one of the things that the planning group has been wrestling with is coming up with some frame to understand what are the things could we measure?
What are the things could we raise up that would show the work that state agencies and the county offices are doing with other adults?
With few exception, the work that state agencies and county offices of ed do are with other adults.
They are not with students.
So part of that work is trying to figure out how do we measure that effort?
How do we measure the changes that are occurring?
And again, going back to the system, this approach for this work, that if you can measure in some way that work, that it would allow us to give us a dipstick.
So we're certainly not talking about adding an indicator to the dashboard.
But this is, again, more about a formative effort so that other adults, as they're thinking about their levels of support to districts, that they have a lens through which they can think through in that regard.
Interim progress, I mentioned that.
And I think another kind of point here is just having that common language around abilities, skills, and mindsets of individuals and organizations.
That there's a common, loose way in which individuals can talk about this work, county to county, state agency to state agency, as they're thinking about how they can continue to orient their time and attention to school districts.
The second piece of this, and this builds on the work that we started last year around the formal feedback plan was kind of year one.
So we're continuing to refine the measurement and the criteria and the questions that we're asking, a lot of which is actually based in the improvement capacity framework.
So continuing, again, this notion of this isn't evaluative in nature, it's more formative, and that one of the things that we are looking to see is that the state agencies and counties subsequently are feeding on this information as places that they need to continue to focus in their own work, as opposed to, you know, you're getting a passing or a failing grade around this work.
So again, continuing to emphasize this notion of using cycles of inquiry to drive the work and process that state agencies are doing.
The second work group that I'll go into a little bit of detail about is the communications work group.
Once again, a very kind of clear need that came up out of the year one feedback that we were receiving.
Many practitioners that we talked to, both those that were identified for level two differentiated assistance, but actually more of those that were not,
didn't have a sense of what the system of support was.
And as we think about things like level one resources, as we think about this as being a critical structure for helping and supporting implementation in our schools and districts,
whether you are getting a type of support from the system or not, understanding what it is, what it's there for, and how it can support you as a district leader or a school leader is critical.
And so the communications work group has developed a communications plan, kind of aims to build this awareness and clarity and ownership, particularly amongst education stakeholders.
excuse me, education stakeholders within the sector, but also to create some cohesion and collaboration in our communication outreach efforts.
I was talking with one of the planning group meetings earlier today.
We were just kind of talking about a logistic of presenting some of these talking points and common PowerPoint slides.
And I said, it'd be great to be able to get to the point where you could swap out any member of the planning group, didn't matter who they were from, what agency, and they could basically provide and give the same type of information about where the system is.
That's part of the kind of inspiration and vision of where particularly the communications work group is trying to go.
And so some of the key documents include talking points on several relevant topics, both specific to the systems of support, but also in relationship to other things, like the LCFF, or sorry, the LCAP, the dashboard, et cetera.
A glossary of terms, again, to have in your back pocket, and this notion of kind of common slides and accompanying talking points.
So one of the things that this work group has laid out for the fall is that there are many associations that are in the room.
They host conferences, events that literally are triple and quadruple booked throughout the course of the fall.
We're kind of getting into that season.
And so it was the decision of the work group not to say, we want to put on our own events, but really to take advantage of
those that are in the room.
And I have to say, the planning group has stepped up in no small measure.
We actually have, this work group now has a very detailed calendar by month between now and the end of the year that identifies each of the state agencies, organizations, associations that are in the planning group, and then what thing they are doing by month.
So again, this is taking advantage of already existing vehicles, like conferences, newsletters, blogs,
other articles, for example, that allow us to push this information out to a broader audience.
So what's next?
I talked, you know, you heard from Suji from CC about the lead selection, design of communication and coordination expectations.
I talked about the communication rollout for the fall, the formal feedback and improvement capacity framework.
The last thing I'll note is just the work that county offices of ed are gearing up to.
to do for year two.
I think one of the very common questions that have come up is what comes next.
The root cause analysis was something that was certainly a very innovative and forward-thinking notion that counties have advanced with school districts.
We saw that many districts really appreciated that different tone that counties were bringing to districts.
And I think right after that conversation ended, people started asking, well, what's going to happen next?
And so counties have been organizing and thinking about how this continued engagement with districts can be done in a way that's consistent with the principles of not necessarily imposing this work on districts, but really listening for the needs that they have and identifying and pairing the right set of resources with those districts appropriately.
Concretely, CISC, which is the Curriculum Instruction Subcommittee of CCESA, has an item on their agenda next Thursday that is specific to talking through both the data collection and organization of this work for year two.
There are lots of things that we would want to continue to collect some information about to kind of feed that back to the state agencies and counties.
And so, CISC will be having that kind of open collaborative conversation.
And that will then subsequently flow to the SESASA general membership meeting that will be occurring in October.
So, the sequence, which is something also that the state agencies have been working on, you know, CISC is going to have their session.
The planning group will have their meeting in early October.
general membership will have their, for success, will have their meeting in mid-October.
And so we want to try and see a much more consistent flow of information back and forth across these kind of critical meetings.
And then the last thing I'll mention is that the counties, particularly staff in the counties, have seen a really great response to improvement science training, which I would describe as a methodology of continuous improvements, not the only one out there, but it is certainly one that
many county offices have adopted.
And one of the things that WestEd has seen across the state and has started to emerge is this discipline, not only of wanting to use continuous improvement as a vehicle to support districts, but also thinking outside of just a single methodology.
So we now have county offices that will borrow heavily from things like improvement science, but are also bringing in other methodologies as a means to adapt it
into their own environment.
So I think we're set up and poised for some great work in year two.
Still very much in a conceptual design and build phase, but excited to see what happens with this coming school year.
So I think with that, Sheena is right behind me.
Thank you.
So this is an informational item.
So I will, if you have questions or comments, I have a team of colleagues behind me that are here to assist with that.
I want to thank you and the team Jason and Suji for coming.
I know that there's a bunch of decisions coming up that CCE will be involved in and choosing the lead agencies and I guess I would like this is an ongoing item and obviously it's continuing to develop and I appreciated Jason's description of the
different ways the players interact, because I think that's what the field is now wondering about.
So and I guess I would like the next step when the team is ready to present.
So what happens?
So I'm in technical assistance and I'm getting support from my county.
But what if I really would rather go to a different agency?
When do I go to CCEE?
Are they the broker for other services?
Will people be working for them?
You don't have to answer those things now, but what I'm saying is I'd like to see the next chapter, and I know you're all working on these pieces and it's complicated, but maybe as the new leads are selected,
And I know you didn't have county office people here today because some of them are applying for the leads.
So I guess I'd love to see a county office exemplar or what that is, how CC, maybe Tom Marolino, our new executive director, could come and that we could see the next chapter.
OK, because people are saying, OK, I'm in technical assistance.
So what's happening or where can I go or?
What if I want this one?
Is this for free and do I pay for that?
So I'm just putting out the questions.
I appreciate this as a foundation of continuing to inform us, but I'd like to request in November that we have that next chapter on the presentation.
Thank you.
I just wanted to express my appreciation to everybody for the presentation.
As Eileen mentioned, our new executive director for CCE, Tom Armolino, who's the former Shasta County superintendent, former president of AXA, came on board in
the first part of July and has really hit the ground running.
And I would like, he's going to be here in November to do more of a presentation about where we're headed with CCEE.
The one thing, a couple things I want to reinforce about this is A, there's a substantial investment from the state in trying to build out the system of support, which we very much appreciate from the governor and the legislature.
But with that brings a number of challenges in my view, because when you look at all of the different leads,
I've said this to Dave, he doesn't like this expression, but I worry that we're moving from what was an old shame and blame situation system under NCLB to we're now going to love LEAs to death.
And we're going to give them somebody from special ed, and we're going to give them somebody from this.
And the LEAs are going to be going, wait a minute.
But Dave assures me that's not the way it's supposed to work and that it's actually supposed to be coordinated through the system of support and primarily through the county offices.
That the county offices are really the, you know, first stop, if you will, to say, let's figure out what's going on here and let's figure out what kind of help you need.
And then we'll be there to help you get that help.
But it is a work in progress, and I think we're going to have to be very attentive to that.
The third thing I wanted to mention, and I think somebody, I can't remember if it was Suji or Shanine, alluded to level three, which is intensive support.
And lo and behold, there are already districts that we consider to be in level three and they're primarily districts that are in severe economic distress and or used to be called bankrupt districts that have come to the state for loans.
And so in addition to the funding for this big system, the CCEE now has been thrust into a very prominent role along with FCMAT and in partnership with our other state system folks around these districts, Englewood being the first one.
There's a couple right behind them.
where the CCEE has been asked to go in immediately to those districts.
So I think it's important to kind of understand that.
I'll just say for me as the chair of CCEE, I get very nervous about that work because it's very intensive work and it's long term.
And I worry a lot about pulling CCEE away from
the level two assistance, which is what I think initially was contemplated for them, at least initially.
So just a little preview of what we can expect to hear in November.
But I really appreciate all the work that you all have been doing.
And I think, just I will say, having watched it over the last year or so, or maybe a little bit longer,
It really has evolved a lot, and I think we're getting a lot more clear on what the respective roles are going to be, what kinds of services LEAs are going to need, and how those will be coordinated so they don't feel like they're being bombarded by a bunch of different folks.
Originally, the Charter School Act was, I believe, a foundational piece of it would be that these schools would experiment with various approaches to education and provide examples of high quality education and disseminate that out into the general public school system.
The Charter School Act has actually provided a great deal of choice for parents, but it has not done a very good job, or the charter school movement has not done a very good job of disseminating model practices and sharing that with a wide variety of public schools.
So because this is still in the conceptual system planning time of support and all,
It might be helpful to take a look again about how charter, I was pleased to see the CCSA is on their logos there somewhere.
I don't know what that means, but their logo is there.
But I think there could be a way of thinking about
charter schools and those that are exceeding expectations, and there are some, and how that could be useful or helpful in this process.
Thank you all for the work that you've done to put this together.
With each successive board meeting, when your division comes to make the presentation, one of the things I'm always listening for is not just the concern about creating and developing the capacity of the LEAs,
But also, I want to know that there is consideration in the planning and implementation of this about the capacity of the support providers.
And so as we go, I'm comfortable knowing that this is a work in progress.
The fact of the matter is all of the work that has been done before this new system to provide support for schools, frankly, just didn't work.
And it was always a work in progress.
We just never owned that it wasn't working.
So I'm happy to see this as a work in progress, because as long as we recognize that, it means that we're going to be paying attention
not only to the building blocks, but what are the essential next steps to take and what they are, what those next steps are going to be defined by.
And so what I really want to make sure I reiterate, as I have done each time Melanie has come to the board to make this presentation and bring county offices up, it's very important for us to continue to hear that part of that consideration are what are the building blocks for capacity,
for the providers as well.
Because we know that differentiated types of support doesn't mean that there's going to be one single system of support provided by a single provider for all the LEAs that they contract with or consult with.
So I want to understand what that capacity building for them looks like as well.
And it continues to be important to hear not just bounded by the issues of funding, but also the issues of personnel access and the types of resources that they make connections to or create linkages for, but also what they do for their own internal capacity development.
I think that remains an important consideration concern that is very important to hear.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
This was a very thorough presentation and I think that just breaking out of silos and communicating across agencies is a goal and a very lofty goal.
I am a little concerned that as we're trying to build a capacity, we're trying to break the silos and figure out communication.
that we may focus so much, and with some of the districts having been in physical crisis, that we're going to focus so much on building this thing and not really focus on why we're building it, which is to address student outcomes and performance, right?
And so I like that we have some measures that we want to consider when looking at the capacity that we're building.
But I also think that we need to consider at what point are we now looking at what we're building?
Is it having an impact with student outcomes and the interim growth targets that we have?
And we have those on the SSA state plan dug in somewhere.
I was at an event at Stanford last week with state local state board members and no one had seen the SSA state plan.
And so I really doubt that people are looking at the estate plan to look at their targets.
Right.
So I think it's important for for us to quickly focus on how do we build it?
How do we sustain it?
How do we support it?
Because at some point we may not have all the funding that is currently funding this.
And if we do it right, the funding should phase out little by little, but not completely.
But at the same time, how do we then focus on the reason we're building this entire system, which is student performance, and what does that look like?
And when we're having these honest or courageous conversations, I would like to know what is in that courageous conversation, because there are some things that may hint at just attitudes towards students.
The other thing that I heard a lot last week was, well, let's look at performance, but then next to it, let's look at poverty.
It's like, yes, we all know that poverty contributes and makes it challenging, but it's not a destination.
And we need to break away from that idea that if you're poor, therefore you will not succeed.
And that's something that I don't know what map or what theory of action will get to that.
Thank you.
Board Member Valdez.
So I like the idea, and I really appreciate it, that we're not going to compete against one another, that we are going to complete in terms of all of those agencies and entities that were on that one slide.
You know, there's that song from Greece, We Go Together, Shananana ding dong, you know that one.
But that's really going to be important because as a consumer, as a district level person, and I'm looking for support, it's still not clear where to go.
And I know that that's coming.
And my fear is that the dashboard comes at the beginning of December and then districts are doing, you know, they probably already know, but then they're going to think of what do they need to do.
And I think we're making those decisions, I think, in January.
So there's this
this time period where I think if we could get out the most information possible to be clear about the roles so that districts have enough detail that we could give them at that point that would really help the journey so that we don't create a sense of panic, people don't go out shopping, that they kind of know that it can be very intentional and we can do some really good work together.
So I think that's really important.
And I also think that
You know with the differentiated assistance the state Accountability if you will and then with the federal accountability coming at the school level that that needs to get clarified as well Within what would be the role then with all of these agencies within that still working through the county probably but yet all of that needs to get Communicated out.
I think that there's just a lot of people who don't even understand that it's coming Okay board member Karnas
Thank you for your presentation.
So one of the things I really hope that happens during the design process is really having student voice included.
I know for a fact that these agencies, a lot of them work with students and they have interns like California for Justice has a huge student voice component and really making sure students are a part of this design process because they will be interacting with the
the people who want to do community engagement and they do show a different perspective on how everyday schools look like, especially since California is so diverse.
We want to make sure students be like, hey, this is why students have these test scores because I'm in this classroom.
And so really making sure that students are represented in this process.
Thank you for that.
My response is that you've got these six key questions are good ones and you're at a very early stage.
But there's very little that I've heard on question three.
What do research and past experience indicate will be the most effective forms of assistance and support to improve student learning and outcomes?
And then the question and the substantive question is what approaches to assistance and support will advance the goal of building local capacity?
So there's a lot of, yearly, it's a lot of organization, coordination, communication, engagement.
But at some point, we're going to have to get down to the, as I said, where's the beef in the hamburger here?
And I think that's where we're, you know, going to have to get.
And so I look forward to hearing more about that and less about the top and the bottom of the hamburger.
Thank you.
Got it.
That's it.
Okay, we can move on now.
Item three.
Item three, yeah.
You need to call for public comment.
Public comment.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Would Brian Rivas and Leangela Reed please line up?
Good afternoon.
I'm from Recovery Children Now.
I just want to say thank you very much for the update from
The planning group and the budget act, those things along with Tom being appointed as CCE, I think the table is set for all this work to move forward.
It's going to be pretty strong for our state.
A couple of quick things to really hone in on.
The idea of level one supports, as Jason stated, it'll be a focus for the October meeting, which is great to hear that there has to be a big priority for us.
One thing on the lead counties is to really identify the idea of current expertise and current capacity for the lead counties to be the best of the best to help everyone else and ensuring that happens and not the political fight that will happen sometimes when people get elbowed out when they really shouldn't be.
And then beyond that, the braiding of the funds is really promising and we hope to see that continue on.
In reference to the August memo on the schools, we really feel that the LEA should always be the fulcrum of improvement and continue that structure.
And that given the confusion around CSI, TSI, and ATS schools, that the funding should be focused on the CSI schools because that would make the most sense to most folks in the field.
So, thank you.
Good afternoon, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
Just a couple of points.
One, I really want to thank WestEd and the department, state board staff for tremendous work on the state system support.
SSDA was fortunate enough to participate in the planning session, planning group.
It was a really exciting meeting, really thoughtful to hear all the voices.
And I think it's overall going to be extremely helpful to LEAs whether they need, regardless of what level of support that they need to be part of this system.
I want to thank you all for such a thoughtful process.
And I also appreciate the work of the governor and state board staff relative to building in the budget, the fiscal and policy supports for the state system support.
They're so, they were so needed.
And I think it will help us to create a tighter safety, the tight safety net that we need while still maintaining the county offices, the hub, which is so important for small school districts.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, John Affel from Public Advocates and for the Equity Coalition.
We also want to appreciate the administration's support for the budget actions expanding out the
system of support in particular, the community engagement initiative, which we are very excited to be supporting, and the extra $15 million for school climate multi-tiered system of support work.
We think there's room for continuous improvement in particular when I call out the involvement of community voice in the differentiated assistance process.
We think there was some effort made toward that in year one, but there needs to be a lot better involvement in going forward.
And this should not just be a conversation between
county staff and district staff, but on the differentiated citizens, we ought to be bringing in more time voice and appreciate member Cardenas calling that out as well.
Thank you.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
We are participating as a member of the planning group for the system of support, and I wanted to share with you, we think it's going really well.
We appreciate the way that your staff and I guess WestEd is organizing the work, facilitating the conversation, and I think it's coming along nicely, so thank you for that.
I do want to ask that you be sure to include ample time and an opportunity for stakeholder engagement.
We think that's very important.
And I'll share, when I speak to community groups and people in the field sometimes,
I hear really this is the most important thing that we're doing as part of the accountability system.
Communities feel like frequently they could tell you in advance which districts and schools need the help.
The question is what are we going to do about it?
So I'm pleased to participate in this effort and thank you.
Good afternoon, Martha Avalos-Axa, the Association of California School Administrators.
Similar to the prior speaker and Leangela Reed from the SSDA, AXA is also a member of the planning group, System of Support Planning Group.
We're very appreciative of the work that the staff has done to have robust conversations about where the system of support is going.
Really, it's been a great collaboration and discussions among the different stakeholders, and we appreciate being able to be part of those discussions.
As we discussed in the agenda item number one, the dashboard is continuing to evolve, the system of support is continuing to be evolving, and we're encouraged by the new funding resource available to county offices to build their capacity.
ACSA does believe that we need to continue to increase communication to the field,
We appreciate the memo on ESSA implementation and how this will also impact the Title I schools identified for support under ESSA and so we appreciate that there will be a stakeholder meeting on October 5th to try to provide more information to the districts on this issue.
Thank you.
Okay that completes the public comments so we're now ready for item 3.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent.
I'm really here only to introduce Michelle Center, who will be presenting this item to you.
I just wanted to say that I know many of you realize that I've been sitting on the Executive Committee for Smarter Balance Assessment Consortium.
My term is ending, but ended.
But I'm pleased to say that just recently, Michelle Senner has been elected by her peers of the other states in the consortium to serve as chair elect.
So along with everything else she's doing, this next year, she'll be sitting on the executive committee as chair elect, getting prepared to beat the chair the following year.
So Michelle Senner.
Wow, I don't normally get an introduction.
I feel so special.
He forgot to mention I ran unopposed, but we'll make it sound really impressive.
So, good afternoon.
The item that I will be presenting for you today is for information only.
It's our CASP update item.
As you know, as you've all read the item, it includes, you know, various pieces of information.
But like I normally do when the item is for information only, I will be presenting just a portion of the information that's within the item.
I do want to make sure to highlight to you all that the CASP summative assessments closed on July 16.
And just to recap what's in there, because when I do that it sounds
impressive, more impressive than winning an election unimposed, frankly.
But it included operational assessments for English language arts and mathematics, a field test for science, a pilot test for the alternate assessment for science, and a pilot test for the California Spanish assessment.
So we did all that last year.
So I think that's pretty impressive.
I also want to let you know that we continue to remind all of our districts to use the data that they have.
And they have the data from the operational assessments.
We've sent them a letter.
We include it in every presentation we do.
So please know that it is a message that we continue to convey.
It is not always heard and I think it's just going to take some time, but just know that we have heard you and we know that you want your districts and schools to use the data and that you can count on us to continue to go ahead and convey that.
So I'm saving the majority of my time here, and I promise to be less time than Cindy, the majority of my time to talk about the electronic score reporting pilot.
And so I'm going to invite representatives up here with me.
It'll be Tom Foster.
He's the executive director of the CASP program at ETS.
Camden Iliff, Vice President of Product Development for ARIES Student Information Services or Systems, sorry.
And Sergio Mendoza, Director of Curriculum and Educational Technology for Porterville Unified.
So those individuals are going to help me present to you information on our electronic student score report pilot.
So I'm really excited to be talking about this pilot.
We started it last fall.
The pilot goes until later this fall.
And what we're really talking about is a transition, a transition away from paper copies of our student score report to instead sending the same student score report to parents electronically.
And I want to spend just a few moments before those individuals come up and share the spotlight with me about the many benefits of student score reports.
And I'm sure that Sergio will also share with you his thoughts on the benefits that occurred in his local district.
First off, electronic reporting is convenient.
Families are now going to be able to get their information from a secure access point that is provided to them by their local school district.
They can get that data via their smartphone, via their tablet, whatever parent portal application that school district uses.
So I do want to clarify, because there's sometimes a misconception on this, that we are not sending a state-developed or a state-sponsored parent portal for individuals and all parents in the state of California to access.
Instead, what we want to do is encourage our school districts, many of which already have parent portals, to use them and to now use them for this additional purpose.
So, electronic reporting is prompt, more prompt than what we have now even.
So, we no longer have to rely on printing and shipping and a one-time mailing process in order to get these reports to our districts.
It's efficient.
District's costs associated with shipping such as postage and staff time to package and mail those reports can now be greatly reduced or in some cases eliminated.
It will allow our districts to redirect those resources instead to implementing parent portals as a year-round resource for parents.
We are not mandating that our districts use parent portals.
So school districts may continue to communicate with their parents as they think is most appropriate.
If they think it's most appropriate to send parent reports, they can choose to do so.
Or if they think it's appropriate to send parent reports to some parents because that is how that family likes to receive the information, they can choose to do that too.
So this really provides lots of options for our districts.
It is engaging and potentially even more engaging in the future.
It really promotes the increased use of our district's parent portal as a one-stop shop for families in order for them to access their child's school information.
So while we are promoting its use for test results, as you can imagine, and I know some of you out there have
students, and I don't have my cell phone with me, it's in my seat, but normally at this time I pull up my child's results in the parent portal and I show it to all the individuals who maybe are not as familiar with what it looks like.
It's good, it's the beginning of the school year, so all of her results look really good right now, so it's a good time to pull it up.
So normally I show that because as some of us may not have children in K-12 right now or may not be involved at a school site, you may be unfamiliar with them.
But as someone who has a child, one child actually went away to college a few weeks ago, but my youngest is still in our K-12 system and I am so familiar with using that system as a way of knowing what's going on with her in school.
And I often refer to this as meeting our audience where they are.
So that's where our parents are now.
They're on their phones.
And so this allows our school districts to meet them where they are instead of trying to get them where we want them to be.
So it's accessible.
So the cost savings from us having to print these are going back into now translating.
So we will have our parent reports in English, Spanish, Mandarin, Vietnamese, and Filipino.
And we will be adding additional languages.
That's good, right?
So everyone should be happy.
I should get a few shout outs from the crowd behind me at that one.
Yeah, so I think it's pretty impressive.
So also, now that they are electronic, they can be used with text-to-speech readers.
So imagine our parents who may be visually impaired now being able to access that information by using an application to do so.
It's also contemporary.
Electronic score reports provide a future opportunity to deliver reports that are even more dynamic than the information we have now.
So we're looking at ways of even modifying them in the future to increase their engagement factor, if you will.
So now I'd like to call up the individuals that will be co-presenting with me and start off, I believe, with Tom Foster.
Thanks, Michelle.
My name is Tom Foster with ETS.
I'm the executive director in California.
And for me, just a few details and background about the pilot.
The pilot had several goals that we set out to
to utilize with this pilot.
But one of the main ones was to collaborate with the LEAs and their student information service providers so we could better identify concerns that they might have, potential barriers that are out there that we might not be aware of.
And this in turn would help us to do better transition planning so that we can get the resources in place, the information in place.
that will help LEAs to make a good transition.
In addition, we wanted to make sure that we had the right kinds of communications that were available to help LEAs not only understand the process but understand which for them was the best option in for the local conditions.
So what we did, we
We started last spring with technical requirements, working with the student information service providers, SIS vendors, and coming up with those requirements so they all can use them together.
So we have one standard that everybody can hook into, not only the commercial providers, but also we have a number of homegrown systems that also access this.
Then in the fall, we selected participants, LEAs, and a couple of service providers to engage in the process.
What we tried to do was get large and small, get LEAs that were technically very savvy and ones that
were more challenged in that area, had staff that, or not as much staff perhaps.
And there's also a different level of readiness.
Some LEAs are out there using their parent portals and are just right on with it, as Michelle was indicating.
Others are kind of feeling this out.
So we did that, we selected those 11 that you see on the screen and then in early 2018, we attested the process with the providers and these people and had a successful testing process.
Then in May, we released live reports to these LEAs so they could start using them.
And what I want to do is I want to turn it over to
Camden from ARIES to do a little bit of a more detailed presentation on how this kind of works with people and then we'll turn it over to our representative from Portugal.
Good afternoon.
Cam Iliff from ARIES Software.
So we've been, we were one of the vendors, of course, that were chosen to be part of the pilot.
And that really comes from our commitment to California.
About half of the schools in the state use ARIES for their student information system.
So we deal with a lot of different types of districts.
So in the needs to find districts both large and small, rural and urban, as well as affluent and low-income districts, our customer base has all of those.
And we've been engaging with those districts for a long time to provide solutions that meet the needs of all different types of districts.
Now, the project goal of leveraging existing parent portals instead of the state, of course, or ETS having to build a new statewide parent portal system, which wouldn't really have been effective.
So we've been providing a student information system-based parent portal to our customers since about 1999.
And it's free.
And all the other vendors in the market, the other SIS vendors, they're just like us.
They provide free parent portals.
And we struggle trying to get customers to use them.
There's like little elementary districts that don't use parent portals at all.
some even larger unified school districts that also don't actively engage with a parent portal.
But for the most part, in our analysis, we found the vast majority of our customers do use a parent portal, do use it very effectively.
We have some very nice statistics on that.
And the parent portals have been providing some great information to parents for a long time, everything from attendance, day-to-day academic information from the grade book, report cards even.
We have some customers who have already gone full digital with no paper, all report cards online, all communications in some form of digital communication.
Recently, these parent portals have become the center point for communications as well.
So with integrated email, integrated messaging, also through apps that are tied into our system.
Now, today's parents, they have grown up in the digital age.
So it's kind of expected that the parents want access to information right now.
They want it immediate.
They want it up to date.
They don't want to have to wait.
So as we see here in the slide, the CASP paperless scores are presented alongside all of these other areas of the system.
So you have your attendance, you have your grades, your notifications from the school, and you have your CASP electronic score reports.
As was mentioned before, the reports are available in multiple languages.
So we present those languages here, English and Spanish, as examples.
But as the other language reports come online, those will automatically display as available to parents.
And in fact, the entire parent portal in ARIES, and most of our competitors as well, are fully translated into a number of different languages.
The parent or student just chooses that language when they log in.
So they would see the whole environment just change over.
Now, in addition, what I was mentioning before, trying to engage parents into the parent portal is very important.
It's one of the big challenges, especially at the elementary level, where teachers are less inclined to be using a grade book on a day-to-day basis.
So with elementary parents,
We want to provide as much content in these parent portals as possible so that the communications can work outbound from the school to the parents, so the parents have a channel to communicate back to teachers in the school.
So the CASP electronic score reports are just one more piece to try to get those parents more actively involved.
And of course, parent engagement is a very important part of our LCAP goals.
Notice also with the way that we've presented.
Now, this is an example of the way that ARIES is presenting to parents and students.
This is not necessarily how other vendors are going to do it, but we have served as a leadership role with other vendors and given them guidance about how
things that they need to know about, things they need to learn, and how to present this information.
So we have this information, not just by language, but multiple years worth of data will start to accumulate for students.
And as students move from district to district,
you'll actually see all the information from tests administered in the previous district.
And that we saw was one of the greatest benefits.
A lot of these reports just go off into the ether, right?
The paper goes home and the paper gets thrown away or it gets lost.
Like, I can't find my kids' reports from last year, and most parents are probably the same.
But if we want to track the student's progress over time, and as a parent, an engaged parent, I want to see that progress.
So I can go into the Parent Portal, whether it's ARIES or one of the other systems, no matter what district, and I can see all of these score reports of full history.
Now, hopefully, CASP isn't just the end.
Hopefully, we see other state reports also included as this type of delivery system.
Now, and there's one last element.
We decided to kind of take it to the next level.
As we saw this delivery of information so critical to parents being through the Parent Portal, we also want to provide this information to counselors, teachers, and other office staff.
So because Ares is a unified platform, we were able to take this same interface and just apply it to other types of users.
Now, of course, it's secured independently.
So teachers have access to it.
Counselors can have access to it.
But maybe the nurse or a secretary will not.
So that's going to give parents, not just parents, but teachers the ability to view more detailed information about their students as they move around from district to district.
So you have your high mobility students, like foster and homeless, that when they come into a new school, the teacher really knows nothing about what's going on with that student's academic progress.
So they're able to see a full history of the student's
state tests and hopefully be able to adjust and create some more into better individualized learning programs for that student.
So hopefully that will make an impact.
And lastly, the other thing was the app.
We are including access to these reports, which are delivered via PDF, but they will be embedded inside our app that we provide for parents as well.
Because we're seeing that the majority of parents are using our app and not the website.
So it's been a huge migration over the last 12 months for our parents after we rolled it out last year.
So it has to be there.
And so for the full-fledged implementation later on this year, it will be available.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Sergio.
Thank you.
Good afternoon again.
I am representing Porterville Unified School District in Tulare County.
And we did it for two reasons why we got into the paperless pilot this year.
One of them is all of the things that Camden just said is a lot of our parents, our newer parents are online, are using their cell phones, are using emails, and it's a quicker access to the process.
Plus, also, we saw ourselves as one of those districts, as Michael stated, that wasn't pushing it, weren't pushing it, weren't getting that response back.
In fact, we were under 20% of parents with accounts for a parent portal
And now we've gone up to 32% since we started in July with this paperless product.
And we're not finished yet because we're in the middle of back to school nights.
And we're promoting it very hard in these next couple of weeks also.
And we continue to see that there's some schools primarily that are in need of some extra support that just their office staff cannot do.
But we plan to do that at the district level.
That was one of the two main reasons that we were involved in it.
And the other thing was really to engage our students and parents in that communication piece about their school and the essential piece of knowing what's happening at school and how are we doing as students.
So one of the things we did is quickly changed our website.
and made sure that it said Ares portal.
We used to call it MyPUSD, but we changed it and put the Ares portal.
And one of the things is how we did that.
As you see here is the parent would see this on their screens.
And then up there on the very top under the district, the name district, is this English.
And there's a toggle there.
And you quickly change it to Spanish.
And then it'll change to Spanish for our parents.
So one of the things we do is as a parent came into our district office and they wanted to be a part of this, we went through the whole process with them on their phones.
got them an email if they needed an email, and we made it accessible to them immediately.
For those parents that still don't have that, that's what the schools are doing now.
And just to let you know, we did receive this year all of this test scores on paper also.
But we also kept those until school started, because we wanted to see how many parents came in, how many parents were using their portal accounts.
And we saw much success in it.
And right now, as of right now, we don't have any complaints.
So that's a good thing, right?
So we always look at that as the barometer for all of us.
So that's one of the things that we do.
So one of the things is we started with our system, which did a text, email, and phone messaging through Blackboard Connect.
And we made sure that at that time it was done in English and Spanish, because our Spanish is our majority language.
And so we got that out during the summer.
And lo and behold, people were receiving the message and calling back and coming in.
And we had extended hours in our office
near our enrollment center for people to come and access their accounts.
And if they really wanted it printed, we even printed it for them.
But at the same time, we were promoting the fact of let's get it onto the electronic.
And so we signed up parents.
And again,
trying to do that all with bilingual staff.
And one of the things, as you see here, and went even a little step further, is with the QR code, right?
You can grab that from pretty much anywhere.
If you put it on a poster outside of your school, you can grab that with your camera, as long as you have that capability with your phone, iPad, whatever you might be carrying with you.
And one of the other big things that we're using is, of course, our social media right now.
Our Twitter account is on my left-hand side.
That would be, I guess, your left-hand side, too, if you're seeing the screen in front of you.
And also our Facebook.
As you can see, probably some people also on attendance, I came and I thought about that after as it went on to there.
I go, I came at the appropriate time because I came up earlier on the chronic absenteeism, but this is our
Awareness month and that's one of the things we do promote in our our district also, but the the Twitter account Also made a big impact.
We use our local newspaper, even though that may be sliding away at least we know parents read that and we do as much as we can on local radio English and Spanish for all of that and
But the biggest thing I think that we're learning, too, is that now we're having to identify the people that are not doing it.
And so why?
What is that?
Is it work-related?
We're in a very rural agricultural area, and right now it's hot and heavy with all of the
of picking the fruit right now.
And so we know, and that's why we stayed open later, but we know that's a need and a necessity.
And we'll continue to do that and outreach because we know they do have cell phones because we get calls back.
I missed a phone call.
who called me, right?
And so sometimes they call us at the district office and maybe not the school site.
So we know the communication piece is there, and we just have to work on our part to get out to it.
But we did not neglect the fact that if parents don't want
Right?
The electronic will have the paper always, always available.
But we found much success.
We had a few little glitches, but ARIES and CALPADS and ETS and everybody that combines our efforts for all our scores.
help create and resolve those issues.
At the beginning, we were having a couple of students, and we ended up finding out everybody that had an issue actually was a good thing, I guess, in a way, because they had perfect scores on either ELA or math or combination.
So somebody
over here was holding on to those test scores a little bit.
So that's OK.
But the reality is those students did receive those perfect scores.
So that was the only glitch that we saw.
So other than that, it went well for us.
So shall we go back?
So I'd like to thank ARIES as well as Porterville, but also thank all the other entities that you see on the slide here that participated in the pilot.
And as you can see, ARIES was not the only vendor that participated, but we thought one was enough in terms of the presentation before you today.
So I'm available to answer any questions.
Board member questions?
Board member Williams.
I'm just curious about something.
I have a little experience with this because I serve as an advocate for a couple of Latino low-income boys in San Diego and have for several years.
And as it turns out, one of the things that I didn't know was going to be my role turned out to be a need, which is the parents are divorced.
The mother doesn't use email.
The dad doesn't read email.
He only reads text.
He works as a contractor and is fluent on text and phone, but neither of them email.
And so one of the things I wind up doing is I'm on power school.
you know, as one of the recipients of the grades.
And so I get the grades and then send the grades to the sons and also to the dad.
And sometimes I have to interpret them, you know, what they mean.
And I'm just one, you know, this can't be the only case like this.
that I just wound up with this family that I'm supporting that does not benefit or won't access the power school.
And so I was glad to hear you say that you still make paper available for some people.
This particular school that they go to doesn't.
And so, you know, I've kind of, I don't, I mean, it's not a big deal for me, but I didn't know that was going to be part of what I was going to be doing, that they were not able to access that.
So I'm just curious how common that is if you're working in, you know, low-income families with low-income families that may not be fluent in English or fluent in education jargon.
I do not have statistics on how many parents have delegated the parent portal to another person.
And if I hadn't taken it, they would have just not known the grades is what that would have worked out.
It's not like they would have, they didn't delegate that to me.
I just figured out that it was a problem they were having.
And once I figured it out, I wasn't going to let it go.
I wanted to make sure that they had the grades.
I would say it is true that many things are going paperless.
And you mentioned grades.
Registration, for example, is another thing that is going paperless.
So it is the future.
You did mention interpretation.
though, is another thing that you mentioned.
And as we move forward, another future presentation that I hope to bring forward to you, and I believe Tony Alpert might be behind me somewhere, the executive director of Smarter Balanced.
So one of the future presentations I'm going to do for you will be on a new resource that we are developing with Smarter Balanced that we would be able to link from our parent report to this new resources to help parents interpret their data.
And the fact that we have a resource now but we give that to someone on paper and they'd have to go to a computer and they'd have to type in a URL is really causing us probably not to have the hit rate that we would like to have on that.
So we're really hoping that another benefit of putting our student reports electronic is how easy it's going to be for those parents who want additional information
to now just be able to click on that and go to a parent resource that helps them understand what the scores mean.
And so that's another advantage that we'll be showing that as soon as it's developed, probably in the early next year.
Sounds great.
I'm sorry.
I'm confused, I guess.
If a parent wants to access student results online, can they go to the state website?
No.
So it's all being passed down to the local?
A local district is the entity responsible for ensuring that parents get the reports.
Okay.
local school district has options as we move in the future about how they get that information to parents.
The easiest option in the new schema will be to use a parent portal.
That will be the easiest option.
This year we have a limited quantity of paper and we are currently developing the criteria for who would be eligible for that small amount of paper that we have available to us.
But they also have all of it electronically.
If they choose to print it out themselves, they can print it out themselves.
We've also heard from some districts that are implementing these parent hubs.
So for example, if they don't have Technology at home another thing they're using are these hubs where an individual can help them access Not only this but various things that have gone paperless and districts.
So that's another option I think la unified is Considering for the future, but no we we are not the entity that's responsible for getting it to parents and that's and that's a shift correct
No.
That is currently, right now, it is the district that is responsible for getting the reports to parents.
I'm thinking of individual schools, like individual charter schools that may not have the wherewithal to have a vendor system, you know, and that sort of thing, but potentially.
And so how do they find out, how do they get support or help to figure out how to do this?
I'm sorry, how does who help?
The gentleman who spoke, you know, how this robust system, but tiny little LEAs.
a way they can get support just by contacting CDE?
I almost feel like a fellow board member is dying to answer your question, but... I'll let her, but I just had one other comment.
Tremendous savings in paper, right?
Tremendous cost...
In terms of the state costs, there are savings in paper that has all been reinvested into, one, setting up this process, which has been costly, but then also storage, cloud storage for all of these reports, as well as now translation services.
Thank you.
I wanted to give you the opportunity to explain where all the savings was going, because I thought in your presentation you said it went for translation of the... That is one of the... That's one of the things, but that's...
That wouldn't cost that much.
Absolutely.
I assume there's quite a bit more savings and you're using it in these other ways.
Yes.
Okay.
Board member Sun, do you want to respond?
Not necessarily.
So in the past, what happens is that the LEAs charter schools would get these huge boxes of reports and you sort them out and you mail them out.
So the difference is now you get them electronically.
You can print them out yourself.
So the cost does shift from the state to the LEA if that's the way that the LEA chooses to do that.
I love this option and wondering when this might expand at some point to other SIS systems and
Other SIS systems?
Yes.
So you can see the SIS systems on the slide here who participated in the pilot, right?
So Aries and Infinite Campus, as well as two districts, I believe, on here who have their homegrown system, LA Unified and El Monte.
And El Monte, both of those have, those two school districts have their own SIS system and then two other vendors.
But we have not excluded any vendors from these conversations.
We have included them as part of our normal SIS meetings that we have with the vendors.
We've included this as part of that.
So we hope that they are all ready this year.
All of the major ones.
And it would be the SIS system company contracting with ETS or through the state?
They do not need to contract at all.
Most of these vendors, as Camden presented,
Parent Portal is kind of free with the purchase of their SIS system, so they just need to implement the Parent Portal part.
We have a system in place whereby we transfer electronically these reports, and so that's the type of work.
that we needed to spend some of those cost savings on is developing that system to store and have the language, if you will, to transfer the reports from our storage facility to where they need to access them from.
Right.
Thank you.
Patricia Rucker.
Hi, Michelle.
I'm very excited about this project.
I think my question is related to the work that your department's also doing as it relates to wiring and getting districts across the state connected.
What is the limitation for districts that are still geographically remote and don't have access because they're not wired yet?
to be able to take advantage of this?
Are there still districts out there that are not yet wired and online and able to do this?
And how is that capacity going to be looked at and developed?
I'm gonna ask my my pair Jerry to come up.
I knew who that was.
That's and I wanted I wanted to hear his voice today That's why I asked that question.
I've been dying to come up here Jerry Winkler data management There are very very few districts that don't have Extensive broadband as a matter of fact, we've been working with a big grant since 2014-15
We've worked with even the smallest of districts to get at least some microwave towers up, some wireless.
Most districts have significant broadband.
And if they do not, we've been working.
And I shouldn't say if they don't, because they do have.
broadband.
So if there, if you know of some that I'm not aware of.
I didn't ask the question.
I'm very interested.
Yeah, I didn't ask the question because I knew it when I asked the question because I wanted to hear you say that.
The reason I was asking that question is related to what board member Sun said.
There is some cost shifting from the department because they no longer have to print the report to the districts on how they make a decision about how the information gets out.
So for, is there a difference?
Is there a difference in cost or is there a difference in cost pressures among districts because of the type of broadband they have or the type of services they're actually able to use to do any of this?
Not that I'm aware of.
Okay.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Doug McRae, Mary Perry, Martha Saragosa-Diaz.
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon again.
I'm Doug McRae, retired test publisher for Monterey.
Given the controversy last year over the 2017 consortium-wide gain scores for Smarter Balanced states, a major concern this year should be whether the 2018 scores will provide credible change data for state and local accountability.
To address this concern I've been collecting 2018 results from all the Smarter Balanced as well as PARC states Right now.
I've got only seven.
I've got seven of 16 states With six of those described in your electronic folder the basic results submitted last week it's too early to say whether the change data from 2017 to 2018 for Smarter Balanced states will deviate from the
2017 gain data.
I anticipate results for most of the remaining consortium states within the next two weeks.
And as soon as I have a sufficient number, I'll do a 2018 data document parallel to the one I did last year.
Tom.
And I'll then distribute that email to, by email, to interested parties.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing Californians Together.
And I'm here to say that we are very, very pleased to see that there will be, in addition to Spanish, other languages with regards to the electronic student score reports.
Also, the expanded information contained in these reports for the purpose of parent understanding and family engagement.
We believe that this will be a very useful tool for our parents.
Now, our responsibility is to inform our parents in terms of the fact that the parent portal is available and how to access it.
Additionally, just a reminder that the inclusion of the
California Spanish assessment in the accountability system is still a priority of ours and we will continue to pursue this and we will have future conversations with State Board and CDE staff.
Thank you.
Hello, Mary Perry, representing the California State PTA.
And first, I really want to thank Michelle and her team and her partners at ETS and at ARIES for the comprehensive work they've done to not only think through the vast differences among districts and their needs, but also what works in terms of family engagement and this kind of information.
The idea that these reports are going to be accessible and also point people, parents, more effectively to those portals is really important.
First of all, because it helps parents to understand that they're welcome to have this information.
Secondly, the communication.
is broad, is consistent, and I love the fact that there's going to be data collection that gives that two-way information because I think districts really need that.
And we also know from research that family engagement hinges on parents understanding how their kids are doing in school.
So this is a triple play.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Jan Correa from CAVE.
And again, I just want to add my word of thanks and appreciation for this emphasis.
CAVE has a strong emphasis on engaging our parents in being involved in their school communities and being leaders in their school communities with a variety of languages.
We have talked often with the department and our colleagues here at the state level about the need to make information accessible in other languages.
And so we really commend you for doing so and for the support of the state board in doing so.
Now we know the next step is really putting it to practice and helping our parent leaders become the advocates for this and putting this into practice with other parents in their communities.
And CABE, through our Project to Inspire program and other partnerships with the state, will do what we can through trainings, through social media, through other convenings that we hold to make this information available for parents as well.
So we thank you for the support.
Muchas gracias.
Okay, that's the end of this item and so the board will break till three o'clock and then we'll resume with item four.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're ready for item four.
This is a reorganization issue and it'll be a public hearing.
But first, our CDE presenter, Larry Shirey, will begin.
Larry, will you come up, please?
Good afternoon.
Is it on?
Yeah, it's on.
Good afternoon, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I'm Larry Shirey, School Fiscal Services Division.
First thing we have up today, our first item is an appeal from the action of the San Mateo County Committee on School District Organization to disapprove a transfer of territory from the Ravenswood City Elementary School District to the Menlo Park City Elementary School District.
The County Committee unanimously disapproved the proposal.
And after I present information regarding the proposal and you've heard the public and affected parties in the public comment period, you'll take action on either to affirm that unanimous decision of the County Committee or reverse it.
If you reverse the county committee, the transfer proposal will go to an election.
So you will also need to set an election area.
We'll go over these options again after later.
In terms of the procedure for taking action today, the first thing we're going to do is consider the minimum threshold requirements for district reorganizations.
Once that's over, there are nine of them.
Just as a background, there are nine of them in Education Code Statute 35753.
We're only going to go through three of them.
Those are the three that the County Committee found were not met.
The other ones will agree, you know, if you have questions about the other six, I'll be happy to answer them.
But in the interest of time, we'll just address the three that the County Committee found lacking.
Once you have made a determination about these conditions being met, then the next step is to determine whether there is a local educational need to approve the reorganization, approve the territory expansion.
In other words, is there a local reason, a compelling local reason to overturn the county committee's decision?
But before we get started, I want to talk a little bit about, give you a little bit of background about the districts and some of the other issues that I think are important for you to consider.
First of all, here's a map.
If you can see that, it's a map of both the Ravenswood District and the Menlo Park District.
Both of these elementary school districts are components of Sequoia Union High School District and both are in the attendance area of the Menlo-Atherton High School of that high school district.
The blank area that you see there is the city of Menlo Park.
The city of Menlo Park, as you see, is in at least three school districts.
It's about half of the Menlo Park district.
It's about half of the Ravenswood school district.
It looks a little bigger for Ravenswood because school district boundaries, as with city boundaries, include bodies of water.
So a lot of that in the northeast section is the south part of San Francisco Bay.
There's also a chunk down towards the bottom left-hand corner of the map of the city of Menlo Park in the Las Lomitas School District.
And I suppose if we want to include bodies of water, there's a corner of the city in Redwood City School District.
The two districts are fairly different in terms of ethnic composition.
Ravenswood School District is over 99% minority, while the Menlo Park School District is about 40% minority.
The city of Menlo Park and the city of East Palo Alto, if you see the words proposed transfer area, the little red area is the transfer area we're going to talk about, but the land underneath the wording is the city of East Palo Alto.
They're also very different in terms of measures of affluent, you know, in terms of education level of parents and income and those sorts of issues.
Throughout the course of the past number of decades, there have been a lot of territory transfers out of Ravenswood into the Menlo Park School District.
The area that we're going to be interested in mostly is the Willows neighborhood of Menlo Park.
And on the map of the school district, Menlo Park School District, the Willows area is basically the far eastern corner of the Menlo Park School District.
Most of that, as you see, is in the Menlo
Park School District.
That's because the State Board approved transfer of most of that neighborhood out of Ravenswood into Menlo Park in 1983.
The Ravenswood School District opposed that transfer partly because at the time the Willows area was about
only about 28% minority, while they at that time were 98% minority and they didn't see the sense in transferring such a large number of non-minority students out of a very minority district into Menlo Park, which was only about 10% minority at that time.
The Willows transfer occurred.
We're going to move into some litigation that is relevant to the issue here.
The Willows transfer occurred in the middle of the decade-long Tinsley litigation.
brought forward by parents of Ravenswood students because of what they perceived as a racial isolation of their students from students in the other school district.
One of the allegations in that litigation is that the history of territory transfers out of Ravenswood removed a large number of non-minority students, which in turn increased the racial isolation of the students.
In 1986, I should note that all the elementary districts in Sequoia were respondents to this litigation as was Palo Alto Unified in Santa Clara County, the county superintendents in both Santa Clara and San Mateo County, the department and the State Board of Education.
In 86, the court issued a settlement order in response to litigation with a primary goal, stated goal to reduce racial isolation in Ravenswood with the other area districts.
That settlement order included a voluntary transfer plan.
that allows minority students from Ravenswood to transfer into eight other school districts, including Menlo Park.
Non-minority students from these other districts also under the plan may transfer into the Ravenswood school district.
The court specifically charged the state board with responsibility for monitoring compliance with the order, including this transfer plan.
It also gave the board the option to delegate that authority to the county superintendents, which it did.
In 1992, the State Board heard the first appeal from the Territory Transfer Denial of the San Mateo County Committee that occurred after the Tinsley settlement.
That area that was proposed for transfer is the exact same area that you're dealing with today.
At that time, the department recommended that the state board and the county committee, as they did with the current one, they disapprove that.
And at that time, the department recommended that the state board affirm that action of the county committee to disapprove the territory transfer.
And our primary reason was that the proposed transfer was directly contrary to the Tinsley Voluntary Transfer Plan.
The State Board unanimously affirmed the action of the County Committee to disapprove the transfer.
A lot of the same reasons that the petitioners brought forward in 1992 are the same as today.
The primary issue is that the transfer area is part of the Willows neighborhood that transferred in 1983.
Here's a map provided by the chief petitioners for the transfer.
of the area that they want to transfer from Ravenswood School District to Menlo Park School District.
Their belief is that they were not part of the city of Menlo Park in 1983 when the area of the Willows neighborhood did transfer.
And since the boundary of the transfer area was the city boundaries, they didn't transfer, their neighborhood didn't transfer.
About the same time, Menlo Park annexed that community into the city of Menlo Park.
So it's now part of the city of Menlo Park, but it's not part of the Menlo Park City School District.
And I'm sure the chief petitioners are going to go through these reasons in more detail.
I'm going to go through them rather quickly.
The transfer, another reason for the transfer is that it will align city and school boundaries in this area.
As you'll probably hear later, the Menlo Park School District is experiencing some enrollment increases.
They've reopened a school, the Laurel School Upper Campus there.
So they believe that's their neighborhood school.
It's a grade three to five school.
It used to be a school in Reguinswood School District, but it was part of the transfer in 1983.
They also note that the proposed transfer area has no community identity with Ravenswood School District or the City of East Palo Alto.
They believe that this is a local education need and concern because their children deserve a quality public education which they can't receive in the Ravenswood School District.
And they also finally note that the Pacific Park community, which was a townhouse complex in the Willows area,
was transferred in 2010 when the State Board reversed a County Committee disapproval of that transfer.
Both districts, Menlo Park and Ravenswood opposed the transfer.
Again, I'm going to go through these quickly because I believe the districts are here to address them in more detail in the public hearing section.
Menlo Park believes that the transfer reflects continuing erosion of diversity, property taxes and assessed valuation from Ravenswood.
They also believe that the transfer would encourage unwanted future transfers of City of Menlo Park territory from the Ravenswood district.
The Menlo Park District is looking at increased enrollment due to developments in the area and they think that any additional students will provide challenges for them housing students they have right now or are projected to have.
All Ravenswood schools are within two miles of the area proposed for transfer while a number of the Menlo Park School District schools are further away.
And they also believe that the transfer result in significant property value increases to the chief petitioners.
That is increasing chief property values is one of the nine minimum requirements that we need to look at.
The Ravenswood School District also opposes.
Again, they focus on the historical pattern of transfers, exacerbating the racial isolation of students in the district.
They're concerned that the transfer would create a greater divide between Menlo Park and East Palo Alto communities.
They referenced the 1992 transfer, saying that was denied previously and the conditions leading to that disapproval remain valid.
And they also note that under the Tinsley Voluntary Transfer Plan, there are only students leaving the district.
As I noted earlier, the plan allows for non-minority students to transfer into the Ravenswood School District.
In reality, that hasn't really happened.
I think there have been one or two students in the 32 years of the program that have transferred.
And Ravenswood loses about 160 students a year through the voluntary transfer plan.
And there are probably about 1,200 students, Ravenswood students right now that are attending these other school districts.
They have some financial problems in the district and they believe that any additional loss of students will exacerbate their fiscal difficulties.
Okay, as I mentioned, the County Committee unanimously disapproved the territory transfer, finding that the proposal failed to meet three of the minimum threshold requirements.
The first is preservation of each affected district's ability to educate pupils in an integrated environment.
the concern that it will lead to significant increases in school facility costs for the Menlo Park School District and that it will not continue to promote sound fiscal management because of the negative fiscal effects it'll have on the Ravenswood School District.
I'm going to go through these three and talk about a little bit more detail and talk about the department's analysis and recommendation.
And then we'll move into an area where we'll talk about some compelling reasons and some concerns that we have with the reorganization itself.
The first one is the issue about educating pupils in an integrated environment.
Both, as I've noted earlier, both affected districts expressed concerns that the proposed transfer reflects the continuing erosion of diversity from the Ravenswood community and will have a negative impact on racial isolation of students.
Appellants in the appeal state that 86% of the neighborhood children in the area proposed for transfer are minority.
Currently, you know, we don't have the exact number of the petitioner state.
There are about seven public school students there.
The Menlo Park estimates there could be as many as 12.
Either way, there aren't a lot, but only one of those students currently attends Ravenswood School District.
Our findings, as I noted earlier, Menlo Park District is 40% minority while Ravenswood is over 99% minority.
Again, referring to that small number of students in the transfer area, we don't think that that will significantly affect racial isolation of students.
As opposed to the 1992 recommendation when we recommended that the
transfer at that time would be contrary to Tinsley.
We've kind of rethought that.
The Tinsley plan does not directly prohibit territory transfers.
So we do not find that the proposed transfer now is directly contrary to Tinsley.
So we find that this condition is substantially met.
The second involves the increase of school facility cost for the Menlo Park school districts.
Again, the affected districts note that it will exacerbate difficulties in providing housing for a growing Menlo student population.
And also on the Ravenswood side, it'll pull out assessed valuation and bonding capacity.
Per capita assessed valuation and bonding capacity is already the lowest in the county for Ravenswood school district.
The appellants note that Menlo Park will have capacity for all students into the foreseeable future.
And the assessed valuation is growing, so that will counter any loss of their property.
Our findings, again, based on student capacities of the schools and projected enrollment growth that the district provided us.
We don't see that district-wide that Menlo Park School District will exceed their capacity to house students in the foreseeable future.
The assessed valuation in Ravenswood District since 2011 has grown 52%.
still is the lowest per capita in the county because all the other district areas are growing too.
And again, the small number of students and relatively small assessed valuation in the transfer area should not have significant negative effects on or significantly increase school facility cost.
So we find this condition is substantially met.
Second is the fiscal impact condition.
Affected districts note that Menlo Park's cost would increase by about $167,000 annually.
Menlo Park is a basic aid district, so they do not receive additional funding for any students to come into the district.
And as we noted earlier, Ravenswood revenue is important because of its declining enrollment.
It's lost about 20% of its students in the last 10 years and it's very low per student tax base.
The appellants note that the Menlo Park costs will be offset by property tax revenue from the area going into the district.
And again, the tax base in Ravenswood is growing significantly.
Our findings, Menlo Park District is fiscally healthy.
Additional costs for the students in this area will be offset by increased property tax revenue and in the greater scheme of things will be minimal.
The district AV growth over the past five years has increased by 42% far exceeding the Menlo Park enrollment growth over that same period of over 10%.
Although there are concerns with the Ravenswood District's fiscal health due to declining enrollment issues, the loss of one student and 30 homes should not be significant.
So we find this condition met.
Now, before I move into reasons and concerns, I should, as you've probably picked up, we differ from the County Committee on the findings of these three conditions.
I think it's probably important just to note
why that might be.
When we look at the minimum threshold requirements, we only focus on the effects of the area proposed for transfer on those requirements.
County committees that are dealing with an area where they've seen significant past transfers and are concerned that future transfers are going to be encouraged by
by actions to approve the current ones, sometimes will, and I believe that San Mateo County Committee considered this, is they will consider that domino effect.
of future transfers when they look at the, when they look at those minimum threshold requirements.
I'm not saying, that's not wrong.
That's just different than the way we look at it.
We're going to be looking at, as you'll see in a moment, we will look at that domino effect, our concerns with that effect as a concern with the reorganization itself.
So now, if you agree with us that all these minimum threshold requirements have been met, the next thing that we're going to look at is determine whether there's compelling local educational reason to overturn the county committee's action to disapprove the territory transfer.
And I'm going to go through these again quickly because they're basically a restatement of some of the reasons for the petition.
The appellants offer a number of reasons including, again, the timing of the 1983 Willows annexation and territory transfer.
They believe that their neighborhood should have transferred at that time had it been part of the City of Menlo Park.
Community identity, they note again that the area is part of the City of Menlo Park and close to the newly opened school of that district, of the Menlo Park School District.
Again, they see this as a local educational need.
They claim that Ravenswood cannot provide the quality education that their students deserve.
They note that this is a unique situation.
The neighborhood is small with few students and should not set a precedent for future transfers.
Okay, that's it.
Now we'll move to concerns that you may want to consider when determining whether or not you want to support
the county committee's decision to disapprove the territory transfer.
This map that you see here is a close-up of the, of a smaller area around the proposed transfer area.
And it,
It gives, I think, a good depiction of some of the issues that occur when you deal with piecemeal changes, piecemeal transfers, piecemeal alterations of a school district boundary.
In this case, you can see the area proposed for transfer.
Petitioners claim that they're isolated from the rest of the city of Menlo Park and, of course, the Menlo Park School District because
They're not there.
But that isolation is really a result of the territory transfer.
If you look at that school at the bottom of the map, that's Willow Oak School.
That's in the Willows neighborhood.
It's one of Ravenswood School District.
And though it looks like there's a large area of the city of Menlo Park,
around it, and there is, it's VA hospital and other non-residential area.
So what the transfer has done as there are no students around there.
It is under the petitioner's definition of isolation.
It's isolated that school from the rest of the Ravenswood School District.
Just above the little red area where the proposed transfer area is, is a small section of the city of East Palo Alto.
that is nestled between the transfer area and the Bayshore Freeway.
Again, as a result of this territory transfer, the Willows Territory transfer,
That area of East Palo Alto is isolated not only from the rest of the Ravenswood School, but also to their neighborhood school, which is the Willow Oak School.
Another concern is that approval, and the districts will probably talk about this in more detail, approval may encourage continued boundary erosion.
Now, where might that come from?
Well, for one thing, that little area of East Palo Alto we just talked about, even though they're not part of the city of Menlo Park, they still have some of the same concerns regarding isolation that the petitioners have.
And as we've already noted, there are large areas of the city of Menlo Park still in the Ravenswood School District.
Just last September, the city of Menlo Park City Council conducted a education equity forum.
And as part of that forum, they brought in an expert on school district organization and presented the process for what it would take to transfer territory and rearrange school district boundaries.
The little school at the top of the map is the Belhaven School.
That's part of the city of Menlo Park, the Belhaven neighborhood.
the residents of the Belhaven neighborhood just this past spring started circulating a petition to transfer the Belhaven area out of the Ravenswood School District.
So this gets us into what I talked about earlier, how we consider
or how we're going to look at the domino effect of territory transfers.
A concern that the State Board might consider is that if we see this domino effect and we have additional transfers of territory out, then that enrollment growth due to the transfers may now place pressure on the Menlo Park District's future ability to house students, especially at the middle school level.
It only has one middle school.
Similarly, if we use that domino effect as a potential, you know, Ravenswood currently is experiencing fiscal difficulties because of their declining enrollment.
They, I believe, cut $2.5 million in certificated staff two years ago.
They just cut another $5 million from their budget for this upcoming year.
Again, declining enrollment is a big issue for them and for the County Office of Education.
And finally, even though we do not view the territory transfer as directly contrary to the Tinsley plan, the state board still may consider that it's in violation of the spirit of that plan.
So in summary, we find that all minimum threshold conditions are met, including the three the county committee determined were not.
We don't believe that there is any reason compelling enough to overturn the County Committee's disapproval.
We do have some concerns about piecemeal approaches to transfers and encouraging future erosion that we think are substantial enough to warrant upholding the County Committee's decision to disapprove the territory transfer.
Therefore, we recommend that the State Board affirm the County Committee disapproval of the transfer.
So your action today is to either, as I mentioned earlier, to either affirm or reverse the county committee's action to disapprove the proposed transfer of territory.
If you reverse the county committee action, then thus approving the territory transfer, you then have to establish an election area.
I'm happy to answer any questions you have now or you can just turn to the public hearing.
Well, we see if there's any technical questions in the board, which is these are really technical.
And then we'll proceed to the public hearing and the public comment.
I mean, I remember stress.
So, Larry, thank you for your always thorough and look at all the details.
This map, I just want to go back to the map.
If you go back a couple of slides, a lot that says potential concerns.
Yeah.
So,
Starting from going across the angle, there's a cut out there.
Yeah, that's a flood control area.
When the transfers took place, they didn't include areas that didn't have.
It's like so weird because usually you see a line between two different districts, not like it jockeyed.
And the second one that's jockeyed out with the Laurel School down at the bottom, what's that?
That is a VA hospital, another non-residential area.
So all of the areas of the city of Menlo Park that jut down below the straighter line, which is the Bayshore Freeway, are for the most part
Uh, you know, there may be, I don't think there are any students there anyway.
And my last question, as you said, if we were to, um, if we had to establish an election area, what does that mean?
An election?
Well, because the
there's opposition from the school district, any proposed transfer that either the committee approves and doesn't come here, the county committee approves and doesn't come here, or the state board approves, has to go to an election.
So the default election area is just the little red area there, the area proposed for transfer, but the state board can expand that election area if they find a reason to do that.
And I should add that the County Committee has, I forgot to say this earlier, but the County Committee has recommended that the election area, if the territory transfer is approved, be expanded to the whole of Ravenswood School District.
Yeah, let's come to that when we have to, yeah, or if we have to, yeah.
The election area, yeah.
I'm a veteran of these things from the 70s.
This election is in a very different, somewhat different discussion and where the election area is.
Right.
So any other technical comments?
If not, then I will open the public hearing.
Each side will have 10 minutes.
We'll start with the petitioners.
who want the transfer.
Can you hear me correctly?
Yes, go ahead.
Great.
Ladies and gentlemen of the board, my name is John Barksell and I'm the Sheep Petitioner for the Oconto Street Petition.
I wanted to start off with asking you guys a question about what is the difference between these homes?
Both are single family homes.
Both are part of Menlo Park.
Both part of the Willows neighborhood.
In fact, both are on O'Connor Street and facing each other.
But I'll tell you what the difference of these homes is that they are separated not only down the middle of the street but also in the center of the block of the two different school districts.
The aim of today's petition is to incorporate the 31 single-family homes located on O'Connor Street in the Willows neighborhood in the city of Menlo Park.
Approving our petition today will unify O'Connor Street's community identity, align and restore O'Connor Street's original city and school boundaries, and correct the oversights from the past.
The Willows neighborhood and the O'Connor Street definitely has a complicated history with different territory transfers.
But in short, the 31 homes should have been included in the 1983 Willows neighborhood transfer as evident of these measures and election.
I'd like to point out to you that our proposal meets all nine criteria outlined by the State Board of California Education Code.
The California Department of Education report prepared by Larry Shirley also includes that we meet all nine criteria.
There is no dispute that we do not meet the 9th State Board of Education criteria and the only logical decision is to overturn the San Mateo County Board of Education decision.
So we talk a lot about community.
Well, we live on O'Connor Street and the Willows is our community.
The city of Memo Park is our community.
There is a school less than 500 yards away that we cannot send our kids to that has always been the neighborhood school.
We are a narrow strip of land isolated by two different cities, three different school districts, and we don't have the benefit of other homes behind us or surrounding us that share the same community.
we meet the nine criteria just as the Willows did in 1983 when it was annexed into the Menlo Park City School District.
Again, the CDE recommends that education and integrated environment is substantially met.
We are only talking about 6 to 12 students depending what SGR ratio that you want to use.
Our children are now 86% minority.
Thus, approving this transfer increases the diversity and reduces the segregation of the Menlo Park School District, which as Larry pointed out, is at 40% minority.
Approving this transfer makes no impact to the Waverenswood School District because currently there are no students.
I know we said one but now there are no students attending the Waverenswood School District.
The demographics of our transfer petition is substantially diverse than ever before in the history of our petitions.
Tinsley is not the answer.
The Tinsley Volunteer Transfer Program was not intended for students in the Menlo Park community to transfer into the Menlo Park City School District.
In fact, the true spirit of the transfer was to foster integration for those families from segregated communities to have the opportunity to have an integrated educational environment.
In fact, if we follow the California Department of Education recommendation and utilize Tinsley with our minority students, we are in fact going to be taking 12 spots out of the available 24 spots of all Raymond's School District for the Tinsley program.
The California Department of Education talked about enrollment growth concerns.
I'd like to point out to the recent report that was prepared in November 2017 that you should have in front of your desk that was done by the same consultant that did an earlier enrollment study.
They are projecting declining enrollment year after year for the next five years in the Menlo Park School District.
Again, we're talking about the contribution of our 31 homes being between 6 to 12 students across 9 different grade levels and out of 3,000 students.
The California Department of Education also concluded that the impact, the financial impact is minimal and we do meet the State Board of Education criteria.
If granted, the Ravenswood City Schools District will lose combined total of out of the 31 homes $6,076 annually.
That equates to less than 0.15% out of the annual 45 or close to $46 million district budget.
I'd also like to point out, since this petition started, the bond capacity of the Ravenswood School District has increased by 52%.
That negates the less than half percent our 31 homes would contribute to the overall bonding capacity of the school district.
Even more so, the Ravenswood School District home prices have increased by 76% over the last two years.
and zero students from our 31 homes currently attend Ravenswood School District which would mean a net zero dollar change from the LCFF.
Now there's a lot of talk about precedent.
Well I'd like to point out to you that each petition should be weighed on its own merits and not consider previous transfers or potential future transfers to make your decision.
In fact, we're not an entire neighborhood attempting to move with hundreds of homes.
We are very unique.
Since we are just 31 single family homes, we are split down the middle of our street, neighborhood street, into two different school districts and down the center of our block.
We are part of the Willows
And if you look at the history, we should have been transferred along with the rest of Willow's neighborhood in 1983.
Approving this transfer today is actually good public policy.
I'd like to point out the other letter on your desk from former City of Menlo Park Mayor and current Council Member Kristen Keith that talks about creating a school district boundary like this makes sense and can fix the inaccuracies of the past.
In fact, the San Mateo County LAFCO that drove the unification of O'Connor Street in 1983 to be in one school or one city also supported the transfer of school district boundaries at that time.
But as you know, city and school district boundaries don't always go hand in hand.
I'd like to read the last guiding principles of the City of Menlo Park.
Schools are intentionally organized as neighborhood as opposed to choice magnet schools.
The reason for this is that our community values the unique opportunities that neighborhood schools provide to develop strong relationships and deep roots within the community by fostering friendships with other families who live within reasonable biking and walking distance.
And that is exactly what we are aiming to do.
Finally today, I would like to ask you to approve this petition because the California Department of Education agrees we meet all nine Board of Education criteria.
Two, the Willows is our community.
This is where our families and children play, shop, worship, and vote.
Three, we are only talking about six to 12 students.
Four, as Larry Shurer talked about election area, we agree that election area should be restricted to our 31 homes.
And if you have to look at case precedent, I'll look at the State Board of Education ruling on Pacific Park in 2010 that had a very similar oversight of the Willows neighborhood in 1983.
And I ask you to prove the errors of the past and reunite us back to the Willows community and the city of Menlo Park and into the Menlo Park School District.
Thank you.
Now the opponents will have 10 minutes.
Let's see here.
I can do the slides for you.
Good afternoon, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst and trustees.
We are here.
My name is Gloria Hernandez and I'm the superintendent of Ravenswood City School District, which is in two cities, Menlo Park and East Palo Alto.
And we are here.
I have with me Eugene Clark Herrera from OREC and Shen Green from East Shore Consulting, who are our financial advisors.
The proposed territory transfer perpetuates a historical pattern of territorial transfers.
You just saw the slides.
These transfers have exacerbated rather than ameliorated the racial isolation of students and our entire community in the Ravenswood City School District.
What we have been going through is
bleeding out by a thousand cuts.
Each cut is not enough to kill the organism, but you cut enough and you bleed somebody to death.
That's what we have been going through over the last few decades.
I'm here to fight for the survival of my community.
We strongly believe that the petition has failed on most of the nine statutes.
As has been stated, there was a similar petition that was denied over 30 years ago.
And we strongly believe that the rationale for this previous denial remains valid.
Our community, you're gonna see, you've seen this before, this is the boundary.
This was Ravenswood.
And now you're going to see how we have been decimated by these territory transfers over time.
And I would say that, yes, we would be very happy to bring in communities because they belong to Ravenswood.
They were taken from us.
We have ended up with a hub of poverty that has happened over the decades as property values have increased all around us.
Our funding capacity, while it is growing, is still, as you heard, the lowest in San Mateo County.
This has really led to our facilities not being able to be maintained, our educational programs suffering, and we have been working very, very hard over the last five to six years to change this dynamic.
But it's a very difficult battle, and with
Pieces that are taken away and again With property values going up.
There's such such a temptation for communities and neighborhoods to want to opt out of our district because their property values will go up and
I'm Eugene Clark Herrera from ORIC.
We're council to the district.
I want to apologize.
We had an animation in this slide that apparently did not work as it was moved over to your system.
But you should have in front of you hard copies which show the illustration.
And I'd like to walk you through that if I may because it's a critical piece of the information we intend to present.
here this afternoon.
If you look at slide three, you see the original boundaries of the Ravenswood School District.
And then if you turn the pages, the next seven slides show you the geographic areas that are the subject of the transfers that Mr. Shirey described in his staff summary.
And you see that over time, there is without doubt a pattern
of territory transfers.
Dr. Hernandez-Goff referred to it as death by a thousand cuts, the petition before you being the next cut in that succession.
Mr. Shirey referred to a domino effect, this petition before you being the next domino in that succession.
I want to make one editorial comment before I dive into a few substantive points and then I'm going to turn it over to Mr. Green to make a few additional substantive points on the nine criteria.
My editorial comment is that I lived in East Palo Alto for four years.
I attended law school at Stanford and I never formed the sort of divisive sense of I live on this block so therefore this is my community and that.
I'm going to go into the
issue of community identity that's raised by the petitioners, but I think the bigger picture point is the peninsula is a community and people who care about education on the peninsula care about Menlo Park students, Ravenswood students, Sequoia students, and Palo Alto students, and that all of those students have the best opportunities that they can.
And so I, in part, see this petition as undermining that effort in a not constructive way.
The standard of review that Your board has today over this petition is de novo, which means you are able to consider all nine criteria even though the staff only focused on the three that were opposed or that were not met in the in the view of the County committee, so I'm going to run through all of them again between me and mr. Green with a few minutes we have left and just try to
Articulate our position that actually Very few of them are met The first is not applicable or before we do think it's met about adequacy of enrollment and I'm on page 12 slide 12 Sorry, I'm jumping through here
And these slides won't even advance, so I apologize.
I want to state that we concur at the top level in the staff's recommendation to oppose this petition and support the county committee's decision.
rejection of the petition.
On community identity, I just find several logic problems with the petitioner's arguments.
As I said a moment ago, I think they are equidistant to city centers.
That's hard to discern from the maps you've seen.
The East Palo Alto City Center, the Menlo Park City Center, that's a criteria.
They are actually closer to more Ravenswood schools than they are to Menlo Park schools, even though Menlo Park just opened a three to five campus very close to their homes.
Junior high schools in Ravenswood are closer.
I could go on about community identity.
I think the biggest issue that I find that we find with the way petitioners have framed this argument is that they're using code words like our homes look
Our homes are single-family homes, and if you read the materials that have been presented, it was not said in this oral presentation, but there are multifamily homes behind us.
That's not our community.
Well, to me, that's code for wealth versus poverty and a disassociation from the poverty, and I think that's an inappropriate justification for a territory transfer.
I think it fails on community identity.
I'm going to move quickly.
There is no property divide.
That's not an applicable
Criteria I'm going to hit Racial and ethnic integration quickly and then give it to chin with a couple minutes.
We have left and
Our position is that any transfer of territory out of this school district necessarily results in a greater concentration of minorities, which is the definition of racial segregation.
So it could be one home, it could be 33, it could be the entire, it could be hundreds, but any movement of any homes, no matter what kinds of kids live in them, out of this district creates a higher concentration of minority students.
That's racial segregation.
It fails on this criteria.
Thank you.
I'm Shane Green, a B. Shore Consulting Financial Advisor to the district.
Just about out of time, but in terms of cost to the state, the reality is, is that the Ravenswood City School District is one of the few state-funded districts in the area.
Everyone else is basic aid.
Why is that?
Because those dominoes that were discussed have already fallen.
They have taken the territory away.
If you look at the map and the progress of territory removed, think about the value of that.
That is prime Silicon Valley land.
Go straight to this one more time.
In terms of the...
primary purposes other than property value.
Skipping ahead here.
We took a look at sales reported on the county rolls from 2014-15 on.
There's an attachment to the back of the presentation where you'll see slides.
If you want to know what the differential is, it's 20%.
Homes on the O'Connor Street on this petitioner side are selling for 20% on average over that four or five year period more than the ones on the other side of the street that are already within.
And so that the petitioners are essentially looking to have homes that sell at a higher value.
We can't say what their motivations are definitively, but it's very clear that across the street homes sell for more.
Thank you.
All right.
We're now... That concludes the public hearing part of the presentations and now we'll go to public comment.
Will the following individuals please line up at the podium?
Ken Hoyle, Ajit Jain, Diana Freitas, Arvind Chakravarti, Purvi Modi, Adele Mazzone, Tom Jackson, Matthew Paik, Tim Fox, Duane Goff, Mel Espinoza, Eric Burmeister, Ahmed Shikholeslami,
Michael Tucker, Carlos Alcala, John Barksdale, Sarita Jain.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Ken Hoyle, and I'm a resident of the Willis neighborhood in Menlo Park, California.
I'm also a resident of the 31 homes in O'Connor Street that we're talking about today.
I have two boys.
Both my boys play soccer for AYSO.
They play for Menlo Park AYSO soccer.
They play Menlo Park Little League.
These leagues are defined by city.
city boundaries.
So the friends that they have, the friends that they grew up with, the friends they play at the park with, all are Menlo Park residents.
That's just who we are.
We're part of Menlo Park.
We're part of this neighborhood.
We go sit every Thursday and Friday night.
They have live bands play at the little local coffeehouse.
This is our neighborhood.
This is our home.
It's important to us.
But I would like my children to go to school with their friends.
When we played Little League at the Upper Laurel School, which is right by my house, I threw a baseball to my house from the school.
That's how close we are.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Ajit Jain.
I was born in Mexico City.
My mother, also Mexican, my father from India.
My grandparents, my grandfather was from Sonora, my grandmother was from Oaxaca.
When I was almost six years old, we moved to Canada.
That's where I grew up.
I grew up in public schools throughout, including college in Canada, and I've been living here since 2002.
I have three sons.
My oldest is eight, and he attends Laurel Elementary, the upper school, through the Tinsley Transfer Program.
He did do the Laurel School until last year.
I just wanted to speak to the significance of the Willows community in our lives.
Our lives truly center around the Willows, not just because of our son, but because of our son's friends and their parents.
They've become our close friends.
He's very active in sports and activities.
As Ken said, we're in the Menlo Park Little League because of our address.
We're in Pac 565 for the Boy Scouts because of our address.
AYSO Soccer for Menlo Park Atherton because of our address.
Similarly, excuse me, sorry.
I was also asked to be a coach for Menlo Park Atherton for next year.
Sorry.
My son is also in Spanish immersion.
I just wanted to say that Spanish immersion in particular is very, very important to us.
The Laurel community, the Willows community is our home.
We love it and we thank you for your time.
Thank you so much.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Purvi Modi.
I am a resident of the Willows and my son is, I am Ajit's wife.
My son is at Laurel.
He was in part of Tinsley, so it's pure lottery.
We have two other boys in the morning.
I want to talk to you about
We've talked about community, and you've heard a lot of data, but I don't want you to think of us as data.
My education is an education.
I was the first person to apply for the UCLA education minor program, did a master's in education.
I work in education.
I get it.
We're taught to think about numbers, but these are little kids, and these are real people.
My three-year-old son, I want him to go to school at the same district as my eight-year-old.
My six-month-old son, I want him to have those same experiences, be part of that same community.
We are part of the community.
We give back to the community.
We don't just take from it.
After this evening, I'm running to back to school night where I'm a homeroom parent, and I have to advocate to 150 third grade parents why they should give to the home apart community, why they should donate to the foundation.
Feels a little bit weird to be advocating here to say like, I'm part of this community because we are part of it.
We love it.
Thank you.
My name is Diana Freitas, and I have lived in the Willows since 2011.
I love this neighborhood.
It's a true community in every sense.
We often spend our weekends barbecuing at each other's houses and holding our annual garage sales.
We help each other out, whether it's checking for mail when we're out of town or buying cookies at a local lemonade stand.
I'm a mother of an 11-month-old, and I've made several friends with new mothers throughout the neighborhood, and we've had numerous playdates at each other's houses and stroller walks through the neighborhood.
It saddens me that these children will not grow up to attend the same schools, all because we're on the wrong side of the street.
The school district boundary is down our quiet neighborhood street, not a freeway, not a major roadway, and only half of one side is in a separate school district from the rest of the Willows neighborhood.
It makes zero sense.
I won't be able to walk my child to our neighborhood school that is literally like less than 500 yards away.
I'm a working mother and as it is, I won't be able to lean on my neighbors for carpooling or childcare sharing or discuss common curriculum.
Time.
As the saying goes, it takes a village and my village is the Willows.
I urge the board to support the petition to unite the entire Willows community and give all the children in this neighborhood opportunity to go to school together.
Thank you.
Hello and thank you for the opportunity.
My name is Adela Matson and I am from Mexico.
When I moved to the Willows neighborhood because my family lived there and my friends and I wanted my kids to grow up with their cousins and my friends' kids.
But we were not able to do so, and we never realized how difficult it will be having some of our members, family members, go to one school district and then go to another.
Luckily, we were given a spot through the teen sleep program.
But with the TNC program, you can't really choose the school.
You are given a school chosen by the district.
So my kids went to another school district where we have to drive 25 minutes each way.
For over 10 years, we did this.
And even when my kids were little or sick, I had to get one out of bed because we have to drive all the way to school.
It was very difficult for us, very difficult.
My kids couldn't hike, couldn't walk.
And I will ask you to approve our transfer because I don't want my neighbor's kids to go through what I went through.
I mean, my kids should know our neighbor's kids, which they don't.
Board members, my name is Tom Jackson.
I've been a resident of the Willows for over 20 years.
I want to commend the board for your endurance.
You must have practiced for this by taking flights to Australia.
I am here in support of my neighbors who have children.
And the question that those kids ask is, how come I can't go to school with my friends?
It's amazing how little children can cut to the very quick of the issue.
These are kids who want to go to school with their friends.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Tim Fox.
I'm a Deputy County Counsel for the County of San Mateo.
I'm also the attorney for the San Mateo County Committee on School District Organization, and I'm here to ask that you uphold the decision of the committee in its entirety.
In addition to representing the committee, I am also the county's desegregation lawyer, which is something I didn't think a person needed to do in the 21st century.
But it is a task that I take on proudly.
The reason every local agency that has looked at this issue has determined that the petition should not be granted is that they have seen that over the course of the past 30 or 40 years, the death by a thousand cuts has isolated students in Ravenswood.
It is a form of surgery where healthy tissue gets cut away, and it gets cut away against the advice of the local agencies, all of which have stood against these petitions every time they've been brought.
And I was here in 2010 when the Park Pacific petition was brought before you.
I opposed that then.
I oppose this now because my committee has determined that granting the petition would isolate students in Ravenswood by eliminating a major source of potential diversity for the Ravenswood schools as all of these folks would be tremendous additions to that district.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I prepared to say good morning, but it is now a few hours later.
My name is Eric Burmeister.
I'm the superintendent of Menlo Park City School District and here representing also the five elected board members of our school board.
I'd like to share with you that the Menlo Park City School District supports Ravenswood's
interest in keeping these residents as part of the Ravenswood School District.
While many of our board members would also add that there are lots of problems that we need to address with boundary situations, but this is probably not the way to do it.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Ahmad Shekhal-Islami.
I'm the Chief Business and Operations Officer with the Menlo Park City School District, and I've been involved from the beginning in terms of the review of the original petition.
And we also agree with the county in its denial for the same reasons that have been indicated before.
As you consider this, if you do change those recommendations, we also would recommend that the election be held by both communities so that the entire community can make a decision and not just by the residents of the street.
Thank you.
Hi, dear members of the board.
My name is Matt Pick and I'm here with my wife and our two boys.
In the back, you might have heard them.
We also live in one of the 31 homes, and we are here to ask that you approve our petition.
Our two sons attend preschool and daycare in the neighborhood just a few blocks away from our house.
Their friends are our neighbor's children from just across the street.
Our children share birthday parties, play soccer together, and do all the things that neighbors in the same community do.
We just want our kids to be able to go to the same school as their friends.
Each morning as we head out for the day, we see children walking, biking down on our street to get to an elementary school just a few hundred feet away.
Regarding Tinsley, the application process is a lottery.
There are only 24 Menlo Park spots for all of the kids in Ravenswood.
And if a child is selected through the lottery, the receiving school district can place the student anywhere in the school district.
So it doesn't guarantee that you'll be placed in your neighborhood school.
In our view, it is by no means addresses the reasons for a time petition.
At the end of it all, approving this petition will likely have no material impact on both school districts will have a tremendous impact on our time.
So we ask that you keep that in mind and approve this petition.
Thank you.
Hi, folks.
I'm Arvind.
I'm an engineer and an immigrant living in one of those 31 homes.
So I'm not a lawyer.
I'm not going to be as articulate as the others, but I'm going to speak from my heart.
And I grew up not getting into a school that my friends and neighbors went to for reasons that were as arbitrary as this case.
And that was a chip on my shoulder for a really long time.
I don't want my kids to go through the same.
Instead, I want them to be able to go to the same school that their neighbors go to.
I want them to be able to walk and bike to the school that they can see from their front yard.
I want them to play the same games as their community does.
As far as I can see, there's no rational reason that has been advanced for us to not be part of Menlo Park School District.
I want to be able to explain to my kids that most things in life are fair and rational.
We met all nine criteria.
This decision will have minimal impact on Ravenswood or Menlo Park, but it'll have a huge impact on the 31 homes, on the half a dozen kids that this decision stands on.
Thank you all.
Good afternoon, Dr. Kirst, members of the board.
My name is Tom Griffin.
For the last 46 years, I've been an education attorney, including 10 years as the attorney for this board and the State Department and the superintendent.
In that capacity, I rewrote the law on school district reorganization, which became a State Board of Education proposal.
And I was intimately involved in desegregation cases.
The Tinsley decision actually enhances the spirit of Tinsley, not the other way around.
These are a transfer of a predominantly minority community into Menlo Park, which needs more minority students and doesn't do much of anything to change the demographics of Ravenswood.
I believe that the petitioners have really been treated unfairly.
over the years, and the county committee and school district organization can clean up the boundaries.
Time.
And they shouldn't be, the parents here shouldn't be held hostage to the county committee for not having done, doing its job.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Mr. President, Mr. Superintendent and board members.
My name is Dwayne Goff.
I'm a resident of East Palo Alto EPA and a community volunteer.
And in the interest of transparency, I'm half white, so I'm contributing to the diversity of East Palo Alto.
This appeal is a continuation of a long history by Mendel Park residents to undermine and take for themselves East Palo Alto resources.
Part of the Ravenswood City School District is in Menlo Park because Menlo Park used its money and influence to take valuable land from EPA before it could finalize its incorporation as a city.
This is back in 1985.
The land was taken in 83.
Disappeal is about land values.
The properties in question will increase in value and again, the residents of EPA will lose tax dollars.
Dollars that are needed by the school district to continue providing a quality education to its children of color who make up 99% of the district.
It's not about education.
It's not about neighbors.
The children don't attend public school.
Please don't give our assets to Menlo Park, one of the richest districts in the state.
Good afternoon, long-suffering board.
My name is Mel Espinosa.
I'm an administrator, teacher, parent, and community member.
And I personally have witnessed the devastation, the subtle devastation of encroachment,
As we have learned earlier, there have been five encroachments over the past two decades.
And with each encroachment, there is one commonality.
And that commonality is that segregation has increased and continued to increase.
This is not about keeping a community together.
This is about segregation.
Someone earlier called it isolation.
No, I choose to call it what it is.
Segregation.
And it's not about separate and equal.
That's not going to work.
And the Constitution forbids it.
And so I ask that you please deny this petition because it has non-method criteria set forth by San Mateo County Office of Education.
I lived and I worked
in a segregated school district, and I attended one, and it definitely is not a positive thing.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Sarita.
I've faced racial and other discrimination so often in my life.
It's so hurtful to hear again and again people accusing us of having ulterior motives, of maybe through some future domino effect causing racial isolation, when we ourselves desire for our children not to be isolated.
which is what they would probably get if they could get approved through Tinsley.
They may be commuting for 45 minutes one way in this notorious Bay Area traffic.
They may not even get approved because chances of Tinsley approval is very slim.
We live in fear that we cannot take advantage of pooling resources with our neighbors, whether it's for going to school, whether it's for after-school resources.
People have talked again and again about the fiscal impact of us leaving.
Ravenswood assessed value has gone up $1.8 billion in the last few years since they last objected.
They're just worried about losing $25 million.
That's 7,200% of what they gained in value versus what they're afraid of losing.
So I really appeal to you to accept a proposal today because you can transform the life of us and our children, but there will be no impact on Ravenswood of approving this transfer.
There's going to be no negative impact, but a huge impact on us.
Thank you so much.
Hello, my name is Carlos Alcala.
I'm the chair of the Chicano Latino Caucus for the Democratic Party.
And I've come here to recommend that you support the district in this matter.
I have represented minority groups in many desegregation cases in Tucson, Houston, Denver, various other cities.
And what I see, I've been just listening as patiently as the rest of you.
And I see here that there are two districts.
One very wealthy, one very poor.
The wealthy one says it will have no impact.
The poor one says $500,000 coming out of our budget will have a big effect.
You're going to be the judge of that.
What would $500,000 in property taxes pay in that district?
What effect will that have?
It will have no effect on Menlo Park.
It will have every effect on the poor district.
Okay, that completes the public comment and the public hearing.
So now we're ready for board member deliberations.
We're going to start with our liaison for this area, Bruce Holliday.
Single liaison for this area.
I want to make sure you all remember that.
I'm in this one alone.
First of all, Larry, thank you again for all your work, all your team's work.
You do bring
a really balanced approach to your presentation.
You do explain things in great detail for those of us who don't understand all of those details.
And thank you so much for that work.
You don't have to make the vote, though, but we do.
And this is a tough one.
This is not an easy one.
And I have a great deal of empathy and sympathy for both sides of this issue.
I want to point out a couple things, and then I'm happy to go ahead and make a motion at this point.
But if at the same time there's a lot of discussion, that's fine with me, of course.
But we can't hear you.
Sorry.
So a few points I want to make ahead of time, and then I'm prepared to make a motion.
But at the same time, if there's a lot of board discussion, that's fine as well.
A reminder that city boundaries are not always related to district boundaries.
I come from the Midwest where they were, but that's not the way here.
And there were, over the years, very logical and good reasons for those decisions.
This will not be precedent-setting.
in the sense that it is not a legal decision.
It's not a court ruling, judge ruling, that sort of thing.
And just the way with charter schools, we can make choices as each appeal comes to us.
The problem here, though, is
this realm, this area, not just the 31 houses, but Ravenswood and Menlo Park, they have a serious reorganization problem on their hands.
And it cannot be solved in bits and pieces, in my opinion.
Instead, I think it has to be solved with both communities coming together in a larger format in order to make
really good choices for lots of families and not just this pocket or that pocket.
I do believe that moving any houses out of Ravenswood at this point, one or 31 or whatever, as painful as not being able to go to a school 500 yards away,
is moving any houses out of Ravenswood at this point, after all of these years and all of these problems, does increase the concentration of minority population in Ravenswood and does increase segregation.
And I move to support the CDE recommendation.
Okay.
Is there a second?
Second.
Second by Ortiz-Lacombe.
Patricia Smith.
Board member Ruckers next.
Okay, so I just want to ask a question.
Looking at the presentation that you're making, Larry, I always appreciate the work that you do.
I learn so much each time you put these presentations together.
The statute requires this analysis about the threshold conditions.
But meeting the threshold conditions, whether they're met or not met, well, let me change that.
Meeting the threshold conditions is not the reason that would compel a decision that the board or even the county would make.
So, I heard a lot from the appellants that the petition should be approved because they met the conditions.
But what I want to hear from you is what does it mean to have a reason compelling enough
to make this determination?
What is a compelling reason or what would be an example?
Because just simply meeting the nine threshold conditions alone is not a compelling reason to approve their petition.
And I'm very clear on that.
Well, when you first started,
I have a hard time knowing if this is on or not.
I'm assuming it is.
When you first started, I thought you were going to go into a court case in 1981.
I was, but I decided to let you go.
That's the case that made the determination that these are minimum threshold requirements and meaning it does not compel the State Board that you have to find other reasons.
What those reasons are, that's, you know, what
The way we look at that, the way our, in the past, is that we have to look at this as a value judgment.
Once these conditions are met, once you determine that these conditions are met, you have to make a value judgment on this.
And that's, you know, it could be anything.
I mean, you could...
You could use the nine conditions being met as a reason if you think that's compelling enough.
That's all it needs to do is meet the conditions.
That's up to this board.
Pretty much anything you want to use that you think is relevant here is a compelling reason.
The issue of what we look at is
You know, if the tables were turned, we would look at this.
We might recommend, shouldn't say we would look, but we might recommend to you that this whole idea of a domino effect and potential future transfers is a compelling reason to support the County Committee's decision.
That would probably be the most prominent one in my mind right now.
But in terms of what are examples, certainly the ones that come up are things like effects on students, effects on... It's hard to come up with something that's definitive.
It's up to this board to make a value judgment on the proposal and on the action of the county committee.
Okay, thank you.
You know, we heard a lot of things, a lot of issues that were raised today about the community, about segregation, about property values.
And I agree with the findings from the department that there really is no compelling reason to overturn the recommendations that have come both from the district and from the county committee.
So, I understand that.
But I wanted to make sure that I heard very clearly this explanation because I didn't hear from the presentation from the appellants what their compelling reason was.
for asking the board to overturn the recommendation.
I will say this that, you know, I came on to the board just after the last decision concerning doing this chopping off from Ravenswood.
You know, there is this other action or behavior that happens from government entities on redlining schools or redlining communities.
that really does happen to communities of color.
And so, I am sensitive to that concern.
And for me, that's a compelling reason not to approve the request from the appellant.
So, thank you very much for talking me through that.
Just as an aside, you know, we kind of made the assumption that the reasons that the appellants or the chief petitioners put in their petition are the compelling reasons that they would argue.
And that's
And we, that's how we listed them in our presentation.
Thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I did second the motion, though I'm not dismissing what this means to the families.
I'm a parent.
I've had to navigate the choice process so that my children could attend a school that was nearby but not close enough to be my home school.
I've been on both sides of it.
I've been the person you want to run away from.
I'm that part of that community that you don't want to be associated with.
And I'm also now part of the community that has this willow effect.
So I know I've seen it all in terms of how this looks because I'm also an urban planner.
So when I look at this map and maybe 1967 taking that little slither wasn't going to be a big deal.
And then when they came back in 1976 for a piece, a little piece more, and then 77.
But this is exactly what white flight and suburbanization, this is what happens when there are some undertones, when there are code words that lead people to want to get away from other people.
When I was looking at one of the reasons is area children deserve a quality public education.
All kids deserve a public quality education.
This is not something that should be reserved for middle class children, whether you're racially diverse or not.
This is something that we should aim for all children.
But the fact that that is one of the reasons that their children cannot attend
Ravenswood District really speaks to that coding that we're seeing.
And I can't look at 31 families.
I have to look at this systemically.
What does this mean?
What is the precedent that we're setting?
Because people in 1967 didn't do that.
People in 1976 didn't do that when they were racially isolating the community.
So we have people in 2018 are not doing that.
And so we need to be aware of what this means in the long run.
Historically, we are setting precedent.
And so and we are, you know, taking away from a community and racially isolating it.
And we need to be aware of that, whether it's one child, 31 homes or thousands of residents.
Board Member Strauss.
So I just have some clarifying questions.
I just this is emotional.
I really feel I feel for Ravenswood.
I feel for Menlo Park and I feel for the parents and the community on that 31 homes.
And I guess my question is as a parent and grandparent thinking about the kids across the street.
Do we know the reason why that line was drawn in the middle of the street where they didn't at least let the whole block go to one district?
Do we know why that happened?
Was it not built at the time?
It was built, but when the 1983 transfer was approved, the petition was to transfer only the city of Menlo Park portion of the willows.
And at that point in time, that the city boundary ran, that was a city boundary.
Okay.
The comment I would make on this is that it's sort of a time warp in the sense that the racial, the word race has changed a great deal from when I looked at these in the 1970s.
It was white people and black people, mostly in the Ravenswood area.
Now we have a mixture of people that are
called racial, although ethnicity is in here too.
So I think somewhat this policy needs to be revamped.
I would say another thing here that our finance formula in California isn't driven by race.
It's driven by low income and English learners.
And that doesn't appear anywhere in this conversation, you know, that the income levels may be different.
You don't even have, you presented us with nothing on this.
So it, to me, I would recommend for the future that the board
uh and the department try and think of this of this whole issue of reorganization in the new california uh because it's been framed just like it was framed back in the middle 70s to me and and i think we have some work to do here so um uh so that since we've clarified on judgments uh you know i think we
where you can make a judgment, as well as looking at these nine criteria.
Same damn stuff was around in 1975.
And a lot's changed in California since 1975.
In this area, we have a firm called Facebook, which is in this very area, transforming it before our eyes.
And it doesn't seem to me that the way the criteria are drawn up for these organizations
is really up to speed for what I think is a new California in that regard.
So, that's my closing comment.
If there are any other comments, we can have them or we have a motion.
Okay.
Are we ready to vote?
All those in favor of the motion, raise your hands.
Okay.
It carries then with one abstention.
One abstention.
Okay.
We're on then to the next item.
which is item five, another reorganization.
And another reorganization in San Mateo County.
In this case, we have an appeal from the La Honda Pescadero Unified School District.
The county committee approved the transfer of territory out of La Honda Pescadero into the Port Talbot Valley and the Sequoia Union High School District.
I'm not doing a PowerPoint presentation, but if you look at the map on page two of attachment one, you can get a view of where this area is.
At ten homes that are on a mountain range to the east and to the north is the Portola Valley area.
To the west and the south is La Honda Pescadero.
La Honda Pescadero is primarily rural, stretches down from the mountains to the Pacific Ocean, while the Portola Valley District contains the city of Portola as well as a portion of the city of Woodside.
Petitioners brought forward the petition to transfer territory for a number of reasons.
One is that no students from this area have attended La Honda Pescadero for at least 30 years.
They've been attending Portola Valley on inter-district transfers.
The middle school and the high school in La Honda Pescadero or down in Pescadero near the coast.
They're about 17 miles away and it's further away than the middle school and the high school for in Portola Valley and Sequoia Union High School District.
And we have the same community identity argument and reason that we see in most reorganization proposals.
Petitioners don't feel they have any community identity with La Honda Pescadero.
Everything they do, where they work, where they shop, etc.
is in Portola Valley.
The County Committee unanimously approved the transfer after finding all the threshold conditions met.
And both the, neither the Portola Valley nor the Sequoia High School District are on record either opposing or supporting the transfer.
But again, La Honda Pescadero is in opposition and has filed the appeal.
They point to the fact that the reorganization fails to meet five of the conditions.
I'm just going to combine their reasons with our analysis in the interest of time.
One is that the reorganized districts will be adequate in terms of size.
State Board has a regulation on this issue that you should not form any new district that will be direct service or, you know, depend on the state or a county for additional support.
And those numbers are 901 students for elementary districts, 301 for high school and 1,501 for unified school districts.
Both of these districts are currently direct service districts.
La Honda Pescadero as a unified school district has about 320 students.
the Portola Valley Elementary School District has around 600 or so.
La Honda Pescadero claims that this condition is not met because they are
more, their enrollment is further away from the standard than Portola Valley's.
But again, that's not the requirement we're looking at.
It's are we creating a new direct service district?
And no, that's not the case.
Districts are already direct service districts.
The second requirement is that the school districts are each organized on the basis of community identity.
LaHonda Pescadero notes that the proposed transfer area is in unincorporated San Mateo County territory as is the entirety of the district.
And that the petitioner should not be using proximity to communities or their commute routes to work as a reason for community identity.
You know, we agree to a little bit with the district.
There is some community identity between the transfer area and La Honda Pescadero.
But there's also community identity with that community and the Portola Valley.
So, no matter what the reorganization outcome is, the districts will be organized on the sense of community identity.
The third requirement is that when we dealt with the last time is that the districts will be able to educate students in an integrated environment.
The La Honda Pescadero points out that they have a better, they have more integration in their district.
They are about 65% minority versus 24% minority.
But again,
There are no students in this area that are attending La Honda Pescadero.
So moving the territory will not take any students out or put any students in any given district.
The fourth requirement is that the proposed reorganization is primarily designed for purposes other than to significantly increase property values.
the district points out that they don't have, they don't have any direct evidence that the primary reason for the reorganization is to increase property values.
But they do note that there are a lot of things that can go into increasing the property, property values.
You know, Portola Valley has higher test scores, the proximity to Stanford.
They note, the district also notes that, that since the kids are all, the students already attend Portola Valley on inter-district transfer.
and that a lot of the parents in the neighborhood don't have kids and that's a reason for them to believe that the reorganization is designed primarily to increase property values.
We disagree.
The district itself notes that there is no direct evidence to support that.
And finally, the fifth condition is the fiscal effect on La Honda Pescadero.
They have a number of reasons, but I'm only going to point to the primary one, which is as a basic aid district, the loss of assessed valuation from these 10 homes, they believe will have negative fiscal effects on the district.
Again, it's not a large area.
It's about 0.7% of the assessed valuation of the district.
So we don't believe that there is any negative effect on the fiscal status of La Honda Pescadero.
So in summary, we agree with the County Committee that all nine conditions are met.
and we support or we recommend that the State Board support or affirm the action of the County Committee.
If you do... Yeah, okay.
I want to announce before we begin the public hearing.
We're ready for that, Larry, or not?
We're doing both.
There are two.
Yeah.
Okay.
I will.
We're going to hear these items five and six together because they both are the appeals of the same underlying petition to transfer territory from La Honda Pescadero Unified School District to the Portola Valley Elementary School District in Sequoia Union.
So we're going to combine them and since we're combining two of the appeals, we will then give 15 minutes to each side to present their opening and their comments, either pro or con, once I start the public hearing.
Right.
So again, in summary, for the first appeal, we recommend that the State Board affirm the action of the County Committee and establish the election area as just the home proposed for transfer.
Now, that is a point where we disagree with the County Committee.
The County Committee recommends that the election area be expanded to the entire La Honda Pescadera Unified School District.
But I should note that even if you set the election area as just these homes proposed for transfer, because Lejando Pescadero is as small as it is, the education code states that if the district opposes the transfer, the election area by statute,
has to be expanded to the entire district.
So... Okay, good.
The second appeal is... Only if there are... We'll open the public hearing if there are questions after the questions, technical questions by the board members.
Yeah.
And the second appeal is based on... It comes from this decision of the county committee to expand the election area by the chief petitioners.
If you take action on the first appeal, there's no reason to hear this because if you affirm the action of the county committee, you have to set the election area.
And if you reverse the county committee, the territory transfer is denied and there's no election.
So our recommendation there is that if you take action on the first appeal, that you summarily deny review of the second.
Okay, technical questions, board member Ortiz-Lacon.
I couldn't find it in the item, but the parcel to be transferred, you said it's seven homes?
Ten homes.
And some undeveloped.
And underdeveloped.
So that piece of it, that those parcels of land that are vacant, are they, could they potentially be developed into housing units or they're not?
Undeveloped.
These are areas that can't be developed.
Okay, great.
Other questions?
Yes.
Board member?
Once again, just to clarify.
If we set the election area, the district, because of its size, can demand the election area include the entire district?
Well, the opposition, the fact that the district opposes it under statute requires the election area to be expanded to the whole district.
Thank you.
The difference is there is that the county pays for the portion of the election that's in the territory proposed for transfer, but the La Honda Pescadero district will have to pay for the cost of the expanded election area.
Okay, I guess we're ready for the public hearing then.
And so, we'll first hear for the petitioners that support the CD recommendation and for the transfer.
Right here on the screen.
Our presentation is the current one.
Okay.
Terrific.
You might want to just make it a slideshow.
Like that?
Okay.
Good afternoon.
I'm John Ellis, Chief Petitioner of the Lahonda Road Territory Transfer Petition.
I'll address the reasons for the petition and then my counsel, Chris Skinnell, will speak to the legal issues.
Our 10 houses are in the Skylanda community in San Mateo County near the ridge of the Santa Cruz Mountains separating Silicon Valley from the coastal communities of the county.
Almost all of Skylanda is in the Portola Valley School District to the east, but our houses are just across the border in the La Honda Pescadero School District.
As shown on the map in the handouts, our homes are 17 miles from the middle and high schools in La Honda, Pescadero.
17 miles along rural roads in the opposite direction of where we all work.
We drive east to Silicon Valley, going past the Portola Valley and Sequoia Union school districts.
To attend La Honda Pescadero, our children would spend one hour and 45 minutes each day traveling to school.
Not only would this be a severe burden, but it would be nearly impossible for them to participate in extracurricular activities and socialize with classmates.
And it would take parents an hour and a half to get to the schools from work and another 40 minutes to drive home.
This is also impractical that no child from our neighborhood has attended the school district since 1985, 33 years.
In contrast, the Portola Valley and Sequoia Union schools are only nine miles away in the same direction as our commutes.
Our children would spend less than half the time traveling to school.
Not only could our children participate in after-school programs and socialize with classmates, many of whom live in our Skylanda community, but parents could attend school functions and volunteer.
And in emergencies, we'd be an hour closer to our children.
Inter-district transfers are not a viable solution.
The nearby districts all have policies prohibiting most transfers.
Portola Valley denied our first application and a divided County Board of Education overturned on appeal.
Further, the districts require students to reapply annually, subjecting families to the uncertainties and stress of local school board politics and county politics.
And if a reapplication is denied, the child would be uprooted and forced to switch schools midstream.
We're all strongly committed to public education, but it just isn't feasible for our children to attend La Honda Pescadero.
So six years ago, we petitioned the San Mateo County Committee to transfer our 10 homes and our four children to Portola Valley and, excuse me,
Sequoia Union.
The County Committee unanimously approved our petition, finding it met all of the Education Code requirements and was in the best interest of our children.
The CDE reaches the same conclusion.
My attorney, Chris Skinnell, will address those requirements in La Honda Pescadero's appeal, but please don't lose sight of the main point.
It simply isn't just or fair to make our children spend two hours a day traveling to school when there are public schools less than half the distance and which the children of our closest neighbors already attend.
Thank you.
Good afternoon members of the board.
My name is Chris Sconell and I represent obviously the petitioners in this appeal.
Before addressing the legal criteria issue in the appeal, I want to reiterate just several crucial facts that I think underlie the entire point.
First, this is a very small area, only ten homes affected and no prospect of future development.
Second, only four kids live there and only one is currently of school age and none of them are attending the schools or have done so in the last 30 years and there's no reason to think that any students from this area will do so in the future.
Next, obviously, the key point that Mr. Ellis made is the distance that would be required for any of these students to attend when they could be going to schools that are much closer and in the direction of their work.
And fifth, I want to stress, as he has, that the county committee reviewed this closely and unanimously found that all of the criteria were met and that this was
a good proposal and that the transfer should be allowed.
And so turning briefly to the education code provisions that the Lajonda-Pescadero School District is focused on.
First, criterion number one, the number of pupils.
Well, there aren't any pupils that are attending Lajonda-Pescadero.
So as the CDE staff found, there's no effect of this transfer on that criterion.
Regarding this community interest criterion number two, these houses are in the same skylawn community, most of which is already in the Portala Valley School District.
And so this would be uniting a community that already exists and where everybody socializes and works and dines and recreates together.
Regarding condition number four, the question of racial isolation, frankly, we think this is a bit of a red herring given the fact that no students are attending the La Honda Pescadero School.
And so again, there's not going to be any impact
on this criterion from approving the proposal.
And also, as the staff report here notes, the picture of this effect is really overstated in any respect.
The elementary schools is actually
It actually has the opposite effect when you move to the Portola Valley schools.
The middle schools, yes, there is more of a transfer of minority students.
But then in high schools, it's all about the same.
And so there is not a clear cut move one direction or the other in the racial makeup, even accounting for the fact that no students are attending.
As for condition number eight, the question of property values.
First of all, there's no evidence at all, again, that this is done primarily for the purpose of increasing property values.
But I want to make an additional point, which is there's no reason to think this is actually going to improve property values for these homes at all.
The fact is that we went back and looked at a number of appraisals that were done on these houses in the last few years.
Then we have about nine of them for six different houses.
And most of the comparables in those appraisals are already in the Portola Valley School District.
Very, very, very few are in the La Honda Pescadero School District at all.
So to the extent there's an impact on property values of being in one or the other, that effect is really already baked in to the values of these homes already.
And so moving the line is really not going to, there's no reason to think that it's going to affect those property values at all.
And then finally, with respect to the fiscal management piece, La Honda Pescadero's appeal claims that this proposal would have real and considerable financial impact on the district.
But the county committee and CDE both concluded that it would have an insignificant effect and we agree.
The original petition showed that La Honda Pescadero was one of the best funded districts in the county and state.
And in the six years since, the district's finances have only improved.
The parcels that are going to be transferred now contribute $34,000 of property tax to La Honda Pescadero representing a negligible 0.6% of the total revenue.
As a community funded or basic aid district, La Honda Pescadero is among the best funded in the state.
Just 12% of all districts are community funded.
The district's total revenue and revenue per student have continued to grow steadily with revenue per student increasing 26% from 2011 to 2016.
Of the 23 stool districts in San Mateo County, La Honda Pescadero ranks fourth in revenue per student with 49% more than the median.
It has the third best teacher-student ratio of 37% better than the median.
Moody's Investor Service believes the district is financially healthy and rated the district's bonds A1, the median for all U.S.
school districts.
And in 2018, Moody said that the credit position for La Honda Pescadero is favorable with a healthy financial position, a modestly sized tax base with strong socioeconomic profile, and mid-range debt and pension burdens.
So, in other words, the district is in good financial shape.
And even beyond that, there are two key arguments that the district makes here that we believe are not accurately presented or certainly don't accurately represent the facts on the ground today as you consider this.
The first is that the district claimed that it owed $2 million to the county in 2019 to pay off an emergency loan.
after it mismanaged a bond construction project.
And it said that the district was currently engaged in costly litigation to recover damages from the project manager and several contractors.
Second, relatedly, the appeal claimed that La Honda Pescadero would be unable to pay off the loan to the county in 2019 without a future sale of bonds.
And what's missing from the staff report, and I think this is because facts haven't been updated, is the fact that the litigation that was talked about was actually settled in 2012 before the appeal was even filed.
And the county committee was, I'm sorry, the bonds that were, the loans that were being talked about for the county were paid off in 2014 using the funds from that settlement.
So that concern about being unable to pay the county this loan in 2019 have evaporated because that loan has been paid off.
Additionally, the county, while its assessed value was very near the limit back in 2012 when this was, the appeal was filed, because of property, good fiscal management and property valuation increase,
The district's assessed value has now, instead of being close to the $60 limit, is now down approximately 44 percent, I'm sorry, $44 per $100,000 of assessed value.
So much more room for bonds and that's even after they issued
approximately $4 million in bonds in 2016.
So long story short, the district is doing fine financially and is in fact in much better condition now than it was in 2012 when the County Committee concluded that this was not a reason to prevent the transfer.
Finally, I want to address the area of election briefly.
In the past 15 years of transfer appeals, the State Board of Education has consistently set the area of election to just the territory being transferred, which is the default under the Education Code.
And here, too, the CDE recommends that the area of election be set to just the territory being transferred.
They found that the transfer, quote, would have no significant effect on the voters in either the remaining Lohanda-Pescadero USD or the receiving Portola Valley ESD and Sequoia UHSD.
We obviously support the CDE's recommendation.
And one thing I want to try to clarify just a little bit is it may sound a little bit academic because the statutes require the expansion of the election area anyway in the event that the district opposes it because of its size.
But in fact, if you do agree with the CDE's proposal, that leaves the door open for potential discussions with the district about withdrawing its opposition in which case the election area would shrink back to the default area.
So if they maintain their opposition, then it's going to be bigger anyway.
But if they withdraw it, if their concerns are eventually ameliorated, that would allow for a much smaller election area.
And it would save them money, it would save everybody more trouble, and it would allow it to be shrunk at that point.
Ultimately, this proposed transfer boils down to a fundamental question of fairness.
Are the families in this affected area going to be allowed to participate in the promise of a public education like other families, which this transfer would facilitate with minimal impact on Lujan de Pescadero?
Or are they going to continue to be forced out of the public school system by the sheer impossibility of attending the public schools to which they're assigned?
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the comments and now we'll hear 15 minutes for the opponents.
15 because we have two petitions together.
I promise I won't use all 15 minutes.
Thank you, State Board of Education, Superintendent Torlakson, Board President Kirst for hearing from me today.
My name is Amy Williver.
I'm the superintendent of La Honda Pescadero Unified School District.
I have worked in the district since 1991, serving as a teacher, a principal, and have spent eight years as superintendent.
I am here today to address the Lohanda Pescadero Appeal of the County Committee's decision to remove 35 parcels, 10 homes and additional parcels from Lohanda Pescadero to Portola Valley.
And I speak on behalf of the approximately 325 students and associated staff members who support and attend three tiny schools on the south coast of San Mateo County.
We are the smallest district in our county, yet we cover the largest geographical area
We are an unusual district for a mostly suburban community.
We stretch from the Redwoods along the ridgeline down to the ocean, all the way to Santa Cruz border at Anya Nuevo there.
We have ag-based coastal areas in Pescadero and San Gregorio and the Redwood mountain towns of La Honda and Loma Mar.
We are entirely unincorporated.
And we have no local government or municipal government or advocacy.
We are socioeconomically and linguistically and culturally diverse.
Our residents are connected not by parks, playgrounds, library supermarkets or movie theaters, for we have none of those in our district, but by our schools.
Our schools serve as our glue.
It is where we gather, we sing, we exercise, we eat, we learn and play.
And we are a proud district.
I really appreciate the work of the CDE staff to put together such a thorough analysis of the boundary transfer petition and appeal.
I'm not here to repeat the facts stated in my district's appeal of the county committee's decision, and I'm not here to argue with the information presented by the petitioners and his attorney.
I am here for a couple of reasons.
I'm here to clarify a few points regarding the appeal.
I am also here to put this boundary transfer in the context of a small, underpowered rural district, which is surrounded by suburban and urban areas accustomed to the conveniences of life, what we call over the hill.
It's literally a hill.
And to show that in context of Lohana Pescadero's viability,
The whole can be greater than the sum of its many parts.
And satisfying the nine conditions, the parts, does not necessarily support the whole, which is the health of our district.
On the points of appeal, I will address the following quickly.
Conditions 8, 9 and the area of election.
Condition 8, the interaction of property tax values.
Yes, we did not spend the money to do a study of the property tax increases.
We were offered, but we didn't do it.
I do affirm the district position that the transfer of these properties will likely increase petitioner property values.
For Patola Valley is one of the most wealthy zip codes in America.
While I realize that these parcels will not assume a Portola Valley zip code, we do know the impact of high-quality schools on property tax values.
And Portola Valley certainly outperforms on our state testing, La Honda Pescadero.
Condition 9, the promotion of sound fiscal management and no negative impact.
The continued chipping away of our district in the past, present, and future is a serious concern to La Honda Pescadero.
While $30,000, $10,000, $40,000 at a time may not seem like great sums and may not trigger a significant impact, the cumulative effect
is a problem.
And this precedent leaves other areas of our district at risk.
We border four different districts and our boundaries are wide and large.
One by one, property transfers may not have that large effect, but over time we are seeing an impact.
and the setting of the election area, as I know we've already been discussing.
After many meetings and discussions, the County Committee set the area of election should the district continue to oppose the petition to the entire district boundary.
The CDE staff rejects this decision by the County Committee and recommends today that the election be set in the area of the affected parcels.
I understand and I think it's already been explained that we have the option to expand it, but I wonder why uphold some local decisions by the County Committee but reject others.
My second reason for coming today, placing this petition in the context of the whole, our district's viability as a rural district.
Only months prior to receiving this petition, La Honda Pescadero lost a similar petition in a nearby area by a decision of the same county committee.
Circumstances were a little bit different.
We didn't know this second petition was coming, and we decided that it was not in our best interest to appeal due to the limited infrastructure we have in our district.
As you might notice, I'm here without a team.
I'm here without an attorney, and I'm a part-time superintendent.
Located in a beautiful landscape, we also continue to lose property tax revenue as a powerful local open space trust fueled by Silicon Valley donors purchase large swaths of land and then qualifies them for welfare exemptions, thus removing them from our tax rolls.
Peninsula Open Space, POST, is our biggest landowner and pays a fraction of the taxes a private landowner would pay.
Between 1997 and 2014, when we last calculated, POST had removed and or impacted the tax base of 18% of our assessed valuation.
That has only accelerated as more purchases have accumulated over the past four years.
So our AV does not increase at the pace of our county.
In 2017 our growth was about 73% of the rest of the county and this past year was 59% being the lowest increase in AV in our county.
We're basic aid, we rely on those increases to fund ongoing cost increases.
The whole, what it's like to be a rural district in a wealthy suburban county?
Being rural brings joys and sorrows.
Silicon Valley residents flock to our small towns over the weekend for ecotourism, ag tourism, goat farms, and berry picking.
While at the same time, our deep infrastructure issues are out of context with the rest of the Bay Area.
Our schools struggle for clean water.
Our families struggle for warm, affordable housing and services.
Local agencies making decisions which affect us lack this context and understanding of rural life.
We are misunderstood in our local context.
We travel long distances to attend non-district events through roads which must withstand the fury of nature.
I don't want to get into our roads.
Our kids bus long distances back and forth to school.
We have to plan trips over the hill for doctors, dentists, and groceries.
My boardroom is a mobile dental clinic.
four to eight days of the month because we're the only building in our community that has double doors to let the equipment in.
That is our context.
So a committee decision willing to change district boundaries so families have a more convenient drive when their local elementary school is seven or eight minutes.
away and closer than the desired school of attendance, as is our bus stop for middle and high school students.
And we do run early and late buses.
Makes it clear to me that I will be back here again, which is reason number three.
I'm lastly here so that you can get to know me because this transfer of property only moves our boundary to new areas, subdivisions and neighbors.
We share boundaries with four districts that will always be new neighbors of ours to claim that they are now the farthest away and do a boundary change.
However, while I respect the work of the CDC staff to prepare such a thoughtful staff report, the context in which this recommendation is being made, with the many conditions and lists being checked, does not take into account the whole picture of a district that does not fit into the context of its surrounding neighbors.
I stand here as a public worker, a longtime small town superintendent watching the Bay Area change around her.
A Bay Area that takes what they want from the Lohanda and Pescadero communities, but leaves behind what's inconvenient.
This is the opportunity for you, members of the State Board, to right the wrong and apply a broader perspective.
You see, you work with more districts and you see all sorts of different types of districts.
And I ask you to bring that perspective to this decision.
Thank you.
That concludes that portion of the public hearing of the pro and con.
Now we'll move to public comment.
There's one speaker.
Would Tim Fox come to the podium?
I got to say good afternoon, now I'll say good evening.
My name is Tim Fox.
I'm a Deputy County Counsel.
I represent the County Committee.
The position of the County Committee was to support the petition.
The only thing I'm going to speak on is the election area.
I imagine that you all are a bit confused about why we did what we did.
And I'll be quite honest, it wasn't my idea.
The committee themselves decided they wanted to set the election area because they knew about the statute, they knew about what Mr. Shirey was talking about, and they knew what it provided.
they simply wanted the superintendent to pay for the election.
My take on why they did what they did was they know Amy Wolliver, they know the La Honda Pescadero School District, and they decided that if there was going to be an election, it should be at the cost of the county superintendent and not at the cost of the school district.
And if that's still confusing to you, that tells me that you haven't been to Pescadero.
So I believe that the decision of the committee should be upheld in its entirety.
I understand it's somewhat unusual for the State Board to set an election area.
And I know the statute operates as a backup to this position.
But I also know that there will be an argument made by the Chief Petitioner
that the district should just capitulate rather than bear the cost of the election.
And I think that's why the county committee decided to do what it did.
That it wanted to say that this should be a decision of the Ohana Pescadero school community and that it was unfair to make them pay for an election for it.
That's why it should be upheld.
Time.
It's a piety.
Thank you.
Okay.
That concludes that testimony and we have Larry back.
I think, I think we need some comments from our liaison, Bruce Holliday.
And could you, in your terms, put how these, are we going to vote on these?
We're going to vote separately.
It was a combined hearing, but we need two separate motions.
Is that right?
Right.
Okay.
We need one.
One motion on the La Honda Pescadero, the district appeal.
That's either to affirm the action of the county committee and set the election area.
And then once that's done, the recommendation, since you don't really need to deal with the second appeal, you've already dealt with the issues of the second appeal, is to summarily deny review of that appeal.
Okay.
So the first motion would decide both issues, the transfer of property and the motion would also include the election of boundary in that first motion.
Right.
Or simply put.
the motion to support the staff recommendation.
Okay.
Just, sorry, just to clarify.
Of the staff recommendation.
Sorry, just to clarify from council table.
The item five and item six are both as to the same underlying petition.
So the board's vote on item five makes essentially item six the other appeal moot.
And so that's the recommendation is six is to summarily deny.
Another way of doing it is to, should the board ultimately, their motion to support the CD recommendation as to both, just move the CD recommendation as to both items since they've both been called jointly together.
So, however the board wishes to frame the motion, we can ensure it's clear and everyone understands what they're voting on.
Okay.
And so before I call on Bruce, I'm going to make some comments on the election district, since I've had really extensive experience of this.
We did most of Orange County in the 70s, which was a maze of school districts cut up by freeways.
And it was really huge numbers of people involved in these things.
So we heard many of these.
And I'm not recommending this.
I'm just saying what was done by the board at that time.
Not that we were right.
But I want to present our reasoning.
Once we decided, you know, there may have been exceptions, but generally once we decided what we wanted to do, meaning how we wanted the boundaries to be set,
then we thought about the election in terms of how would the election get what the board wanted when it decided on the boundaries.
So in effect, the election was not a separate decision.
It was a derivative of if you want the property transfer, then you want an election that is most likely to bring that about.
And so we
And we are able to make that decision.
We have the authority to do that.
So that was generally the practice that the election was determined by the result that we reached.
in terms of the boundary transfer at that point.
So, the two could be considered.
And so, the criteria would be for the election, which election boundaries will bring about the result the board wanted in terms of the transfer of property.
It was a derivative decision rather than it's an independent thing with a whole big debate about it.
So, that's all I'll say about the past.
So, Board Member Holliday.
Larry this County Commission that heard the Ravenswood Appeal is the same County Commission that heard this one, correct, right?
So they had they The same people had to have the same experience over the years with all these various transfers
Which is, I think, something to think about in the sense that they understand about the importance of racial integration.
They understand about...
all of the factors that we talked about for the last hour and a half or whatever, right?
They think about all these things.
But in this case, they did say, nah, it just makes sense that these 10 homes make the transfer.
So I feel, I love Pescadero.
And I hope that it's not just my ecotourism.
I actually drive an hour and a half to bring my dogs to a vet there because the vet is so wonderful.
And I do think that it's a community that needs tons of support and not just gawking tourists.
I hope that there are good things coming down the road for Pescadero.
But this notion of over the hill, because I used to work on the coastal side and I know what over the hill means.
This group of homes is at the top of the hill.
You couldn't be closer to over the hill.
They are pretty much basically over the hill.
I do support the CDE recommendation.
I don't think it's going to be a domino effect as we talked about in the last one.
I certainly would hope not.
I would like to go on record saying that future boards don't do that.
But I think this is an isolated case.
I hope it's an isolated case.
I feel it is an isolated case.
And so I would move to support the CDE recommendation in this case.
Yeah, you drove there every day, right, for your job?
No, but over, you drove from Oakland over to, so you have some feel for this.
Just a point of clarification on the motion, is it as to both item five and six, member Holliday, or just as to item five that you're moving the CD recommendation?
I thought we were doing, I thought we were going to vote CD, I'm moving CD recommendation for item five, period.
Okay, is there further board discussion of this?
Board Member Burr.
Are both of the districts basic aid?
Yes.
Okay.
Then the question, I guess I'm a little troubled by the election area or I don't really understand what's happening with the election area.
Your recommendation is that the election area, and I assume this was the county as well, be limited to these 10 or 25, 10 homes or... Correct.
Right.
So to your point earlier, President Kirst, I could argue that for democratic purposes, we should let the whole district vote.
I mean, it has it impacts the entire district.
And I'm I just want to say I'm very compelled by what the superintendent had to say about this district and feeling a little bit like board member Strauss did on the last one.
That it's it's a really tough call So but I thought I also understood you say that if the district objects to this little tiny election area of ten homes Then it would have to expand to the entire district.
How does that work?
Could you just explain that a little bit more?
right if if the state board expands the election area to the to the entire La Honda Pescadero Unified School District
the order that will go down to the county superintendent is call an election in that area.
And then that will be the election that the county will have fiscal responsibility for.
If the board chooses to limit the election area, it will again send that order down to the county superintendent.
And the county superintendent will then have to not only take into account
the state board's order, but also what statute states.
So the state board orders the election area in this area, but statute, if the district maintains its opposition, statute requires that the county superintendent expand the election area to the whole district.
And that expansion, that expanded part will be a cost to the district.
Because I thought there was some other.
If that's what you want, you expand the election area.
Yeah.
I appreciate the board members saying, you know, giving another reason and another way of looking at it.
I really think that's appropriate.
But the board must think that if it really wants this property transfer, you're at risk losing what you want by opening up the election area.
So you have, you take a risk if it goes to the,
Typically, if it went back to the districts that were losing the property, those districts turned down the reorganizations.
And therefore, you didn't get what you thought was the right policy because you set the election in a way that made it unlikely that it would succeed.
Board member.
Well, first of all, let me say to the superintendent who came from the school district that's on the other side of the county's decision, I really appreciate the fact that you actually made a very compelling argument for the harm that this decision will cause your district.
And I understand it and I absolutely agree with everything that you said.
But I'm also listening to the families in those 10 houses of those four children who actually physically seem to live closer to a school that they could get to.
Having lived in the Bay Area for a while, I understand that what you look at on the map and the line looks like this, that represents a significant amount of time sitting on the road for children that young to commute.
And so that also is a compelling interest for that community.
So weighing two very clear compelling interests, that's where the difficulty is here in making this decision.
But that was related to what I asked Larry to try to explain to us on the previous item to give me an idea of what a compelling reason would be.
The reason why I'm supporting this motion today is because in the interest of those very young children and the commute that would be required of them, while there is a clear compelling issue about the impact on the district, there is also a very clear and compelling concern about the impact on those very young children.
So I really appreciate both sides, not only what you did in choosing not to politicize this, but to look at the very practical reasons
for making a very practical decision.
I appreciate what both sides attempted to do for this hearing.
So I just wanted to make sure that was said.
Board Member Strauss.
Larry, I know it's complicated and you've been great, so I just need a review and clarification.
So let's say that the board supports the CDE recommendation and the decision is that the vote is to be taken by the area of the 10 houses.
It goes back to the county.
Did you say that the district then could challenge it and still do a district, the whole Lejando Pescadero election, even though we said only the small houses?
Yeah, I would alter that.
The district doesn't challenge what you did.
It's simply because it's on record opposing the transfer.
That's what the education code states, that any district under
a certain level, which this district under 900 students, 980 ADA or lower, if they oppose it, if they oppose a transfer out of their district, then that by operation of law expands the election area to the entire district.
So it's not that they're challenging the board's decision.
It's just that they're opposing the territory transfer and that opposition translates into an expansion of the district.
So even if we say just the small area votes to support what President Chris was saying, it still could be the large area.
If the district maintains its opposition, then by statute, the election area will be expanded.
The difference is that if you set the election area for just the 10 homes and the election area is expanded by operation of law, then the district has to pay
for that expanded portion of the election rather than the county.
The county pays for the 10 homes, rest of the district is, election is a cost to the district.
If you expand the election area, then that becomes, the entire election becomes a county cost.
And then if I heard the attorney who spoke representing the residents in those 10 homes, he's suggesting that if we agree with or affirm the county's position and set the election for those 10 homes, that would co-opt the superintendent out of an effort to try to oppose this and broaden or set the election to be larger.
I found that a little disconcerting.
I didn't like that part of the presentation.
So, yeah, I understand that now.
Okay, so we have a motion.
Yeah, we have a motion and it's seconded.
We're ready for a vote.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Just for item five.
Just for item five, which included all the CDE recommendation, which is to transfer the property and set the election as the ten, as the ten homes.
All right.
We clear on that?
I mean, yes.
Maybe read it out loud.
You've got to get closer to that mic.
Sorry, I didn't hit my button.
I'm sorry.
The CEE recommends that the state board affirm the action of the county committee to approve the proposal to transfer territory from the La Honda Pescadero Unified School District to the Portola Valley Elementary School District and the Sequoia Union High School District.
The CDE further recommends that the State Board establish the area proposed for transfer as the election area.
That's my motion.
Okay.
And that's the seconder's motion.
All right.
Now, all those in favor, raise your hands.
It carries.
No.
One no vote.
Two no.
Okay.
It carries.
So do we want to break before computer science?
We have to go to six.
Yeah.
We want to go to six.
True.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now six.
Summarily deny review of that petition by the chief petitioners regarding the establishment of the election area by the county committee.
So moved.
Is there a second?
Second on that?
I'll second.
Okay.
Public comment on this second motion and item.
Yes, there isn't any public comment.
It was combined.
Okay.
All right.
Hearing none.
People, no discussion.
All those in favor of Member Holiday's motion, raise your hands.
Okay, that carries.
Two no's.
Three no's.
Okay, so that, it still carries.
Okay, so we're now ready for, and we've ended the hearings and we're now ready for the computer science issues.
And before we get into item seven, I understand that
We have a presentation by the assembly, assembly resolution to one of our board members, Trish Williams.
And so we will... I'm gonna do it together.
It's in this presentation.
I've incorporated it into our presentation for item seven.
Oh, okay.
Go ahead then.
So Stephanie Gregson will present now item seven and combine that with the resolution.
Yes, so good evening, members of the State Board.
I'm Stephanie Gregson, and I serve as the Executive Director of the Instructional Quality Commission.
I'm honored to be here today in front of you presenting the first ever California Computer Science Standards.
Joining me today is Dean Reese, the Chair of the Instructional Quality Commission.
This is an exciting time for California to focus on computer science education.
Right now, there are over 74,000 open computing jobs in California.
Our students' daily lives, as we see, are impacted by the increasing reliance of technology.
So it is an advantageous time to expand the opportunities for K-12 students to learn about computer science concepts, practices, and how computer science influences our daily lives.
As stated in the K-12 Computer Science Framework, in our digital age, computers are both the paint
and the paintbrush.
Computer science education creates the artists.
Before we begin our official presentation on the California Computer Science Standards, I'd like to introduce our special guest, Ellen Green, the Legislative Director for Assembly Member Mark Berman.
Thank you for the opportunity to be here.
Board President Kirst, members of the board, Superintendent Torlakson.
Hello, my name is Ellen Green and I'm the Legislative Director for Assemblymember Mark Berman.
Last month, the legislature adopted Assemblymember Berman's Assembly Concurrent Resolution 265, which designates this month, September 2018, as California Computer Science Education Month.
Given the current developments in computer science education, this resolution highlights the crucial role that computer science plays in providing students the skills they need to thrive in the 21st century economy.
Assemblymember Berman looks forward to working with you to meet California's vision for ensuring that all students develop foundational knowledge and skills in computer science.
I'm here today to thank the State Board of Education, the California Department of Education, and the Instructional Quality Commission for all your work and present this resolution to Board President Williams, who has been a champion on this issue.
Thank you.
I'm not the president, but the board member.
Thank you for staying.
Thank you for hanging out.
Thank you to you guys for staying and hanging out.
We'll take a photo as soon as these two items are done.
So I'd like to start with, what is computer science?
In technical terms, computer science is the study of computers and algorithmic processes, including their principles, their hardware and software designs, their applications, and their impact on society.
In other words, computer science is the science of computing.
It is a tool that helps you tell a story or make something happen with technology.
It is a skill that teaches students how to use computers to create and not just consume.
This journey began back in September 2014 when the governor assigned Assembly Bill 1539 into law, commencing the process for developing the first ever California Computer Science Standards.
In November 2016, my staff and I traveled around California conducting focus groups to hear the thoughts and ideas from computer science educators on what should be included in the standards.
Then the IQC used the focus group information and recommended to the State Board of Education guidelines to be used in the creation of the standards.
The IQC also recommended and the State Board approved members of the Computer Science Standards Advisory Committee.
The Computer Science Standards Advisory Committee members met four times between September 2017 and January 2018.
In March, the IQC approved the draft standards for a 60-day public comment review period.
And between April and June 2018, we received public comment from over a dozen individuals as well as several stakeholder groups.
During the July 2018 IQC meeting, the IQC recommended changes based on the public comment received.
And that brings us to today.
At the foundation of the computer science standards are 21 state board adopted guidelines.
These on the slide are some highlights of those guidelines.
The state board of education guidelines included assurance that the standards allow for flexibility in implementation.
For example, the 912 core standards and the 912 specialty standards are part of that flexibility.
We realize that traditionally most students have access to at most one computer science course in high school.
These standards offer the opportunity for computer science to be integrated into their current programs.
In addition, the specialty standards help define content for standalone courses.
The guidelines also emphasize the use of work that has already been done, such as the Computer Science Teachers Association's standards and the work of Code.org developing the Computer Science K-12 framework.
The guidelines also emphasize coherence across all grade levels using clear and accessible language.
So with the state board guidelines in hand, the Computer Science Standards Advisory Committee, led by co-chairs Beth Simon of UC San Diego and Brian Tworek of San Francisco Unified School District, who is here today.
Brian, would you stand?
They accomplished the draft standards in four two-day meetings.
The group of people in this picture represent the committee members, CDE staff, and our computer science writer Catherine Goyette of Tulare County Office of Education.
We also had support from Alita Hubbard and Yvonne Cao of WestEd.
This was an amazing group of educators truly dedicated to ensuring high quality standards that allow for all K-12 students to experience quality computer science education.
We had a lot of fun during our meetings.
There may even be a video of a group chicken dance somewhere.
I have it.
So with 44 states who have developed or are in the process of developing computer science standards, we felt that California was in a prime position to create the gold star standards of computer science.
That was often the talk of the committee.
And they believe this because the committee approached the development process with the lens of access and inclusivity.
They utilized that foundation work of the Computer Science Teachers Association standards and the K-12 computer science framework
We also had several committee members that were part of developing those documents and felt that the California process allowed them the opportunity to improve clarity and consistency, to fill in gaps, to add interdisciplinary examples.
The Standards Advisory Committee was very thoughtful in providing how each sample might look and be aligned to other content standards.
So with this, I'd like to turn it over to Chair Dean Reese, that he'll go into the standards with more depth.
Thank you, Dr. Gregson.
So I'm going to start by talking a little bit about the introduction to the computer science standards.
And the introduction starts out with a quote.
And the quote says, computer science is no more about computers than astronomy is about telescopes.
So I'll let you think about that for a little bit.
And so for a time, in the field of education, we were interested in students using technology.
And that brought about conferences on computer literacy, education technology, digital citizenship, and information technology.
Now, with these standards, it's really more about those things, but it's also more about having students become active creators using computer science.
For example, students are asked to actively engage and create learning how to code algorithms or learning how networks transfer data and the importance of cybersecurity, how to use computers as a tool to analyze large data sets, and many other aspects of the field of computer science.
So the fundamental goal of these standards is to expose students to computer science so that they are well-equipped to civically engage on topics that fall under the wide umbrella of computer science.
But I think what we are most proud of with these standards is that they are truly meant for all students of California.
They were designed with access and equity as a primary driver in the creation of these standards and are meant for California's diverse educational landscape.
The racial and gender inequalities in terms of access and equity to quality CS education are well known.
And the introduction here presents these challenges and presents data that the field is looking at to basically help us understand the scale of what is at stake for our students.
For instance, 60% of California students are Latinx or African-American.
However, only 16% of students who take AP Computer Science A are Latinx or African-American.
Furthermore, 49% of our students are female in California, but yet only 27% of our students taking Computer Science A are female.
So this kind of illustrates some of these gender and racial inequalities that exist in this educational discipline.
But we're basically presenting them front and center, and our goal is to try to work on these.
OK, so.
So this here shows the progression of K-12 California computer science standards.
And it's kind of laid out by grade band.
So you have the K-2 standards, 3.5 standards, 6.8 standards, 9.12 core standards, and then 9.12 specialty standards.
And then on the left-hand column, you can kind of see that it's broken down within concepts.
The concepts being computing systems, networks and the internet, data analysis, algorithms and programming, impacts of computing.
And each one of these concepts is coupled with one of the seven practices, and those together formulate a standard.
In addition, the State Board of Education guidelines presented a need for appendices that can address flexible implementation to ensure the varying types of school programs would be supported in their implementation of the computer science standards.
These appendices provide guidance for school leaders and teachers.
They include a glossary of computer science terms.
career technical education connections, connections to other content area standards, and connections to post-secondary education.
So I'd like to take a minute here and show you one of the standards.
And the Computer Science Standards Advisory Committee did a pretty smart thing, because they realized that right now, currently, there's no plan for a computer science framework.
And so the frameworks, of course, are how to implement the standards.
And so what they wanted to do was, even though these are just computer science standards, they wanted to provide examples to the field on how a teacher might implement one of these standards.
So for instance, this standard is
Different algorithms can achieve the same result, though sometimes one algorithm might be more appropriate for a specific situation.
Students examine different ways to solve the same task and decide which would be the better solution for the specific scenario.
But then what, and this is a grade three through five standard.
But what's interesting here is a history social science example was presented along with the standard.
A common course state standards math example was also presented, as well as an ELA example.
So these standards were really created with the spirit of integration, not as an additional kind of discipline to teach necessarily, but thinking that the way we can kind of
incorporate these standards into the instruction of a teacher is by creating integrated units that will couple what they're already doing in, let's say, history, social science, math, or ELA with these new computer science standards.
Okay, and now I'll hand it back over to Dr. Gregson.
Thank you, Chair Reese.
So what happens next?
Well, once the State Board takes action today, we'll work on the design and editing of the standards, including working on an online platform for the standards.
They are, after all, computer science standards.
So, you'll be hearing about the Computer Science Implementation Plan later in the next item from my colleague Barbara Murchinson.
And also, you can follow the hashtag CS4CA, which is Computer Science for California.
This is a coalition of multiple agencies led by ACCESS who are ready and willing to support the computer science education at all levels.
So, those are some of the elements that we have going on after the standards are adopted.
So this endeavor was a true collaborative team effort with the dedication of many, including our Computer Science Champion Board Member Williams.
With all of the support and passion of all involved, I am honored and proud to bring to you the recommendation from the California Department of Education and the Instructional Quality Commission that the State Board of Education adopt the draft California Computer Science Standards as the first California Computer Science Standards.
Great.
Board Member Williams, you certainly deserve to go first.
What a long, long effort here to bring off such a great outcome.
I really didn't know what would happen with these when we started.
I mean, what were they?
What was it going to be?
Was it going to be?
That's another question.
So it's, yeah, really a lot of progress.
So I want to make a couple of preface comments and then share some feedback on the standards.
First of all, I'll remind President Kirst that this all started with you and I in May of 2014 when Hadi Partovi at Code.org sent a letter to Governor Brown asking for a meeting to talk about why California should be expanding computer science in K-12.
And Governor Brown, of course, sent that letter to you and said, please advise what should I do about this?
And you and I having been colleagues over two decades now, you sent it to me and said, what do you think we should do about this?
And I said, I don't have a clue.
I was an English major.
This was way over my head.
And I said, let me figure this out.
So I basically did some homework.
You guys know I like to do my homework, my research.
And then I contacted Hadi Partovi.
He came and met with Mike and I here at the State Board, spent two hours talking to us about what this campaign of Code.org was all about, why it was about, why now, why computer science, why all kids.
And we just went from there.
Mike basically gave me free reign and said, let's go figure out what all we should be doing about this and who the experts are and how we should think about it.
And so that's four years ago.
So this day, it has been a long time coming for me.
I want to thank Hadi for bringing the opportunity to us.
I want to thank Pat Young Prattett, who is the chief academic officer of Code.org, and who was the spearhead or the staff lead for the K-12 computer science framework, the national framework.
And the board may remember that he spoke to you about the framework in January 2017.
Both of them have provided tremendous support to me personally and to California for moving this agenda forward.
And I also want to thank all of the computer science advocates.
We only have a few of them sitting in the audience today.
We have Brian Twork, we have Deborah Richardson, we had David Miyashiro.
I think that's all.
Anybody I missed?
But then I'm going to also acknowledge, do a shout out to Julie Flappen with Access, who took on the CS for California Advocacy Coalition.
She's just a bundle of energy and has been the person that says when people say, I got an idea, she says, let me see if I can help make that happen.
So she's been really instrumental as well.
And so my point in all this is I want to share this resolution with everyone I just mentioned, including Dean, including the IQC, including Stephanie, including Barbara.
including the rest of the CDE staff and Tom, and also Glenn Price, who had dinner with me a couple of times in 2014, 2015, when I said, are you willing to have some dinner with me and talk about this computer science thing?
And I want to see what CDE thinks about it.
And so we basically kind of teamed up.
He was supportive on the CDE side, and I was the lead on the state board side.
So that was
really powerful for us moving it this far along.
So that said, before we move on the standards, I want to read you an email I got from Pat Young Prattett this morning, the Code.org academic officer.
I asked him,
What are your thoughts about the standards that we just developed, that the Standards Committee just developed, about how well they align or reflect with the CSK-12 framework?
And how do they compare with what other states have done?
And what he said was, they align very well with the vision and concepts and practices in the framework, some of the strongest connections to the framework that I've seen.
And by the way, he oversees all the states and their work on standards, so he knows what everybody is doing.
They are clear, to the point, read easily, have well-written explanations, and make interdisciplinary connections.
I would have no qualms pointing people to the California Computer Science Standards as a model, simply because of the attention to the framework and the attention to improving on the CSTA standards versus just copying them.
And that was referenced a little while ago about Brian
One of the strengths about Brian's leadership on the Standards Committee is that he was involved as a writer on both the Computer Science Teachers Association Standards and the National K-12 Framework.
So he not only knew those really well, but he also knew how to improve upon them for California.
That was a real strength we had.
And finally, Pat Young Prattett said, and also
Hands down, California ran the most comprehensive, diligent, and public process for computer science standards development of any state.
Computer science advocates in California should be proud.
I know I'm proud.
I am excited that we're at this stage.
I'm excited that we finally got here.
It felt for a couple of years.
Frankly, I would go to computer science-oriented meetings and have other states, some of them kind of rural states, I won't mention a name, where they would say, we're leading the nation now for computer science.
And everybody'd kind of look at me like, and California, are you guys doing anything?
It was it was kind of rough for a while.
I used to say I have small state envy.
Because in California, we are so big and so complex, we do not turn on a dime.
It takes a while.
And it did.
And we are here.
So I, I, I am open to hearing comment and questions.
And then I'll be ready to make a motion.
Okay, is there comment by board members?
Is there public comment on this?
Yeah, why don't we hear that and then we'll have... Okay.
The following individuals please line up at the podium.
Justin Goodrick, Michael Flores-Castaneda, Brian Twarek, Deborah Richardson.
My legs are numb.
Justin Goodrich, principal at Cajon Valley Middle School and member of the Cajon Valley Union School District.
We'd like to thank the stakeholders participating in the oversight and development of the computer science standards and emphasize our support for the integration of digital literacy in the K-12 classrooms.
However, we would like the board to examine the impact that adding additional content standards has on students and educators at the site level
many of who are already struggling to meet the expectations placed upon them by our current curricular frameworks.
The result is a systematic failure of overall student achievement, particularly for students living in poverty, and a reduction in student self-efficacy.
We respectfully request that the State Board re-examine the whole of the content state frameworks through the lens of educating the whole child and preparing for the 21st century learner for the world of work.
We urge you to consider opportunities for the integration of social-emotional learning and the intentional teaching of soft skills such as effective communication, presentation literacy, collaboration, and empathy, all of which have been identified by major companies throughout the world as critical attributes of effective employees in the workplace.
We request that you reduce or eliminate any non-essential standards.
Thank you for listening to me.
I talked as fast as I could.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Brian Twork, and I'm from the San Francisco Unified School District and co-chaired the Standards Advisory Committee.
I want to thank Board Member Williams, as well as the leadership of the CDE and IQC in this process, and emphasize a few points.
We started with some really great products that were national frameworks and standards.
And as Board Member Williams and Dr. Gregson mentioned, we made them this way better.
And I'm very proud of our gold standard standards.
And I think that you should be too.
A few points.
One is that they are very much focused on the achievement of all students.
And we had this lens of equity inclusion throughout.
And so we wanted to make sure that all of the learning outcomes were doable by all students.
To support that, we gave a lot of guidance for how to implement and also integrate with other subject matter.
Those are based on what's already happening throughout California, but it also sets a vision for what it can be in the future and at scale.
That was based on the strong expertise of the community.
Whoops, you can finish.
Oh, thanks.
That was based on the strong expertise and experience of the committee members, which was a pretty fantastic group.
And in summary, I'm just very excited for the precedent that we are setting now as California, because I know that other states are already looking at what we're doing.
Thanks.
Hi, I'm Deborah Richardson.
I'm from UC Irvine, and I'm also with ACCESS, that Trish mentioned, and the CS for California campaign.
I just want to stress how important it is that all of California's students be exposed to high quality computer science education.
Those points have been made before, but we need to prepare them for the skills they need for career and college readiness, as well as civic and community engagement.
These standards, although not required, will make it more likely that students have equitable access to quality computer science education because teachers, schools, administrators can have a better understanding of what computer science is and what students should be learning.
As Trish mentioned, we think of California as a leader, but in fact there are 21 states that have already adopted computer science standards.
And along with the recommendations in the next item, adopting these standards will move the state forward.
I want to thank the Standards Advisory Committee as well as CDE, the IQC, and Trish for their efforts.
I urge the board to approve these standards and thank you for your support of computer science in California.
And I want to make just a couple more comments.
One is computer science.
These are model standards.
And I know that Tom often says they're all model standards, but they're not all model standards when they come with state summative tests that get results reported out.
So those have a lot more influence behind them.
These are designed to serve as, and this is in the state board's guidance to them, to the committee.
They were designed to serve as substantive guidance for LEAs who want to bring computer science into their curricula and to allow flexibility on how they do that, that meets the needs of their students and their local community.
So that's one point.
It's not layering another set of standards on top of all the other standards.
It's offering another set of guidance for schools that want to bring this in.
And what I've seen just in the four years is we've got a lot of districts who have already brought computer science into their districts without even having computer science standards or any other guidance.
It's just kind of taking off like wildfire in terms of face validity, like, well, yes, I see why this is important.
I see why we should do this.
And so an example of that is that the
The data about computer science AP course taking that was cited a few minutes ago was 2016 data.
2017 data, the percent of Hispanics taking computer science AP course went from 16% in 2016 to 25% in 2017.
That's a pretty big leap.
So this, whether it's at the high school, more at the high school level because you have
you now have two college board AP exams.
So it's taking off faster, I think, at the high school level than it is in elementary and middle school.
But it is taking off.
Okay.
Other board comments?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
I was able to delve a little bit into the standards because, as it turns out, when I wear my other hat, I'm getting ready to launch a coding program for middle school Latinos.
So I thought, well, let me go and see what they already have here.
And I think that one first, I think you're the first to ever use Latinx in one of our official standards.
Very ahead of the game.
Thank you.
The rest of us need to catch up in terms of our other standards that we have.
And I understand that the reality in the classroom is there's so much to teach.
There's
a lot of competing interests in limited time.
But, you know, when I was going through my research of looking at how to develop this model with the emphasis on equity, soft skill development, civic engagement through coding, because that is very possible.
In fact, there was a report, Hashtag More Than Code, that just really looks at how is this, how does this relate to civic engagement,
advocacy and equity as it relates to students of color, in particular Latinx and African-American students.
So I think that people always focus on just what the computer board is and what it's doing, but there's actually so many uses for that coding.
But my husband actually uses coding through a curriculum that I won't mention, but he's using coding with fifth grade students that are predominantly Latino, 70% English learners.
It is something that he hasn't formally introduced.
But when students are done with their lesson, the accelerated students move on to coding.
I tried it.
My little mouse just kind of flipped and did nothing else.
But the students are eager to get their hands on this.
And I know that technology is an issue.
Not everyone has a Chromebook or not everyone has one-on-one technology.
But I think that we need to move the field because our students need that, and they need to be competitive, and they need to be relevant.
And their skill set needs to reflect that.
So kudos on this framework, on the standards.
Board member Valdez, yeah.
This is so exciting and thank you for doing this.
I think you've evened the playing field because as computer science was rolling out it was like the luck of who they had on staff and so now I think the opportunities there and I really appreciate the integration and the idea that you're creating not just you know using the computer for other things so this is very very exciting so thank you for the work.
Board member Sandoval.
Congratulations.
I think the draft is very well written.
I had an opportunity to review it.
And I really appreciate the relevance to so many areas.
And I love the highlight on problem solving and digital citizenship and collaboration and creativity.
And these are things that if we can help our students
practice these skills in many different ways, it's going to make our world better.
It really is.
And so I really appreciate also the focus on universal design as well.
And so just congratulations.
And I look forward to seeing what the results are of feedback from the public.
It's very exciting.
I just want to thank Board Member Williams for her leadership and Dean also and Stephanie for your work through IQC and through the CDE and the whole team approach.
I mean, this is really exciting as I think about what we need to do to get our kids and grandkids really ready for the 21st century.
And I just appreciate the district comment about there's a lot of stuff going on right now.
There's a lot of frameworks.
There's a lot of standards.
That whole idea of integrating the work and helping people see that these are not separate pieces, but they're tools and they can be integrated, I think we need to think about.
And again, we adopt policy and then obviously the districts and the counties help support that.
CD, the rollout and the implementation.
But I think we need to use that voice of helping people see how all the parts fit together.
This is not another separate piece.
It's, I mean, it's important model standards, but that there's ways to integrate it into the work that we're doing.
It's very, very exciting.
And I actually would love to see how this rolls out and do an update, you know, six months, a year from now, because we know this is just the beginning as we think about what our science discussion was and where that's going.
Anyway, I want to thank you and the whole committee and advisory and for all of you who stayed through all of our hearings today to be here.
This is actually a wonderful highlight and kind of a capstone to a pretty intense day about kind of looking forward to what we do in classrooms and schools with kids.
So just thank you for that work.
Okay, I think we're ready for the recommendation.
I recommend that we approve these computer science standards.
Second.
I'll second.
OK.
Any further board discussion?
If not, raise your hands.
All right.
A lot of smiles.
Yeah.
OK.
Good.
Now we're on to item eight.
Barbara Murchison will present this on the California Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan panel.
Hi, everyone.
Good afternoon, evening, good evening.
President Kerr, Superintendent, Chief Deputy of Price, and board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison, Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division.
This evening, I'm going to present to you the recommend, can you hear me?
Okay.
This evening, I'm going to present to you the recommendations of the California Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan Panel.
or CSIP for short.
These recommendations will be used to inform California's Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan, which we anticipate will be presented to the State Board in March of 2019.
So just so we can all relax a little bit, this is an information item and we are not recommending any action at this time.
So you can just relax and enjoy hearing about the work of this pretty fabulous panel.
So California Education Code requires the superintendent to develop and the state board to consider adopting a computer science strategic implementation plan on or before July 15, 2019.
Code also requires the superintendent to convene a computer science strategic implementation advisory panel to develop recommendations for the plan.
So the statute, which is relatively complicated, calls for a two-part process.
First, the development of the recommendations by the appointed panel, and then the development of a plan based upon informed by those recommendations.
So just to be super clear, this item represents the final step of the first part of that process.
At the end of the presentation, I'll share a little bit of information regarding the plan development process, but today I'm here primarily to share the recommendations of the panel.
So just very briefly, so you know the who's who of the 23-person panel, panel members were appointed by the governor, President Kirst, the Senate Committee on Rules, the Speaker of the Assembly, and the superintendent, and were selected based on their expertise in computer science.
The 23 appointees included K-12 teachers from each grade span, representatives from the Commission on Teacher Credentialing, the Computer Science Teachers Association, and private industry.
Faculty from each of the four higher education segments were also appointed to serve on the panel.
One thing that I think is really interesting is that you'll notice that there are many through lines from the computer science, the committee that created the standards,
to the implementation plan panel and the IQC.
So a lot of the folks who you see behind us and more folks who aren't here participated in both the standards development and the development of the recommendations.
And we will be moving the plan through the IQC to leverage all that expertise and have that through line throughout.
So, you know, the IQC has just learned all about computer science standards.
We want to make sure that they have that integrated into the final plan.
Appointees also included a teacher from the Instructional Quality Commission, Chair Reese, a representative from an equity-focused organization, a representative from a parent organization, a public school student, and administrators from school districts and a county office of education.
More information regarding the panel, including the names and organizations represented, is provided in the attachment itself.
But I do want to take a moment to recognize our two co-chairs, Deborah Richardson and David Miyashiro.
In addition to participating in the public meetings of the panel and leading the work of the panel, the co-chairs dedicated many hours between each of those meetings, working with the CDE team to plan the meetings and provide feedback on various drafts of the recommendations.
They're going to be standing a whole bunch more times.
Would you please stand, co-chairs, so we can recognize your work?
Thank you.
At the last meeting of the panel, the group delegated final approval authority to the co-chairs, and they worked with the CDE staff to polish and refine the document that you have before you today.
So once the panel was appointed, the CDE convened three two-day public meetings of the panel here in Sacramento in March, April, and June.
To inform the work of the panel, the CDE invited experts to provide presentations on various topics, including sessions on the standards themselves and the status of credentialing requirements for computer science educators.
These were public meetings, and the CDE and panel provided opportunities on each day for public comment.
Statute requires that the panel develop a set of recommendations for a computer science strategic implementation plan that addresses, at minimum, the following topics.
Broadening the pool of teachers to teach computer science, because as we just discussed, sometimes that can be a little bit haphazard.
If you have a teacher who can do it, then the kids get it.
Obviously, the state will want to expand the pool of teachers who can teach computer science, defining computer science education principles that meet the needs of pupils in kindergarten and grades 1 through 12, and ensuring that pupils have access to high-quality computer science courses.
So this came directly from the statute.
In addition to the required principles and recommendations, the panel developed an overall vision for computer science education in California as well as a mission.
The vision is on the screen in front of you to ensure that all students develop foundational knowledge and skills in computer science to prepare them for college, careers, and civic engagement.
And the mission is that all schools offer rigorous and relevant computer science education equitably and sustainably throughout grades K through 12.
All teachers should be adequately prepared to teach rigorous and relevant computer science aligned with California's K-12 computer science standards.
The panel developed eight computer science education principles.
The first three principles on the screen now are grounded in equity.
And really, the equity was a through line throughout all of the conversation, making sure that all of our students have access to high quality computer science education.
The panel felt very strongly that every student should have equitable access and that those opportunities for computer science education are continuous throughout their educational careers and that there are multiple entry points for students to engage with computer science from K through 12.
The next set of principles describe a little bit more about what that education should look like.
The panel felt very strongly that computer science education should be grounded in real world engaging activities that emphasize critical thinking and creativity, and that computer science education should align with the new computer science standards.
the most recently adopted state board standards, and that those standards should be leveraged in a variety of ways, both integrated into other subject areas and used as standalone courses.
The sixth principle put forth by the panel is that all schools should have the appropriate infrastructure to support computer science education, including software, hardware, and personnel.
Principle 7 is about making sure that teachers have opportunities to learn computer science content and pedagogy, both in preparation and for those teachers who are already in service as part of ongoing professional learning.
And Principle 8 is about making sure that we have partnerships with stakeholders across the educational system and with industry to support computer science implementation.
So the panel's recommendations are organized and labeled according to the requirements in education code, and are divided into three broad categories.
The access and equity standards, and there's a longer title, but it's late.
The educator support standard, or recommendations, and the standards implementation standards.
The relevant section, recommendations, no standards, standards was item seven, pardon me.
These are recommendations, three sets.
The relevant sections of Ed Code also contain a number of subsections.
And we use the language in the subsections to organize the work and to ensure that we are addressing all of the requirements.
So you'll see those subsections listed throughout the document.
The panel's final recommendations are provided in chart form starting on page nine of your attachment.
Each recommendation includes the entity responsible for implementation, and you can see on the screen there are many different, there's something for everyone in here.
The proposed strategy itself, what evidence of success of that strategy would look like, and a timeline.
Before we go into the recommendations, and it has been said before, but I want to be very clear, these are just recommendations for local educational agencies and policymakers for use in furthering computer science education here in California.
They are not requirements.
I know anytime anyone sees a big set of something, they're like, oh, what does this mean for us?
We should consider this as kind of guidance from
appointed experts in computer science on how we can move computer science further, both at the local level and at the state level.
Further, this is not a one-size-fits-all set of recommendations.
The panel recognized that different LEAs are in different stages of implementing computer science, and many districts have already implemented some of the recommendations.
Again, this document should really be considered a helpful, a set of helpful guidance recommendations from a panel of experts.
Finally, as you look at the document, you'll notice some overlap between the sections and across the organizational framework.
For example, as the panel was talking about how to ensure access and equity, sometimes that came down to making sure that teachers across the state are
are able to provide high quality computer science education.
So there's clearly an overlap between some of the recommendations you'll see in the access and equity section and those that you'll see in the educator support section because it's really, when we talk about systems, it's all connected.
But it's just trying to talk you through how they're organized in the chart.
So on to the recommendations, and I'll move pretty quickly through them, given the late hour.
But as we've noted a couple of different times, equity permeated pretty much all of the conversations.
It always came back to, how do we make sure this can happen for all kids?
The access and equity recommendations include creating more robust computer science education offerings in kindergarten through grade eight so that students are prepared for additional coursework in high school, providing professional development for educators on the computer science standards, adopting high school graduation requirements for computer science, and offering A through G approved course sequences, as well as having computer science courses approved for areas other than G.
The set of recommendations also includes ensuring that California students have access to computer science in both college and career pathways, and ensuring that California school districts have the infrastructure, hardware, software, and information technology personnel necessary to implement computer science courses.
The panel also recommended that we develop rollouts for the computer science standards, as we've done for other state board adopted standards, and that CSESA, our County Superintendents Association, create a new curriculum and instruction steering committee, subcommittee, just for computer science.
They also recommended doing outreach, especially to traditionally underrepresented groups, to create awareness and advocacy for computer science education.
They recommended that LEAs develop or expand partnerships with community organizations to create opportunities for expanded learning and scholarship, internship and mentorship, and that tools be created for teachers and school counselors to help guide underrepresented students into various computer science pathways.
Finally, in the access and equity section, the panel recommended that data regarding enrollment and achievement in computer science be collected by the CDE in any future data collection kind of updates, and that computer science be included in the college and career readiness indicator on the local control accountability plan.
So we had the largest number of recommendations when we were talking about supporting educators to teach computer science.
The educator support recommendations include providing computer science professional development for both current and future teachers, counselors, and administrators, working with institutions of higher education to recruit potential computer science educators, and creating local communities of practice so that computer science teachers can learn from one another in the local level.
The panel also recommended developing toolkits and modules for teachers in each grade band, offering credit-bearing computer science courses in community colleges, developing a directory of colleges that offer coursework for supplementary authorization in computer science, so it's that much easier for interested teachers to gain that supplementary authorization, and supporting the UC Office of the President to develop a new California subject matter project for computer science.
Finally, in this section, the panel recommended funding a position at the CDE to support computer science implementation and funding the Commission on Teacher Credentialing to develop a single subject credential in computer science.
They also recommended expanding scholarship eligibility and loan forgiveness programs for computer science teachers in rural and urban low-income and underserved school districts and recruiting and training industry professionals to become computer science teachers.
The last set of recommendations, scaling up K-12 computer science education, known as the standards implementation recommendations, call for statewide support as local districts move forward in implementing California's standards.
The panel recommended conducting a communications campaign to make sure stakeholders are aware of the new standards and the implementation plan and providing funding to LEAs during the initial implementation phase.
They also felt that it would be important for the state to provide guidance regarding instructional materials for computer science courses and to review the standards every seven years to provide updates as needed and to encourage districts to create local four-year implementation plans.
This section of the document also includes identifying early implementers and elevate those best practices and providing funding for LEAs for an initial implementation period.
So with one vision,
two mission statements, eight principles, and 49 distinct recommendations.
I think we could safely say that this was a very hardworking panel.
And here they are at the end of the last day, still smiling.
So I'd like to take a minute to ask our panel members in attendance to stand again.
So you're getting plenty of work out your knees and all of your parts are working.
so that we can thank them.
And for those of you who are watching at home, and I know lots of you are, thank you to computer science panel members.
I also want to recognize the Educator Excellence and Equity Division team who went above and beyond throughout this process to facilitate the development of the recommendations.
And also to thank Melanie Murphy, Corwin of the IQC, who participated in the meetings.
And of course, board member Williams for her continued support throughout the process.
So next steps, we'll talk a little bit about where we go from here.
The CDE plans to present the draft plan based on these recommendations to the Instructional Quality Commission Education Technology Committee later this month, two weeks from today.
And we'll encourage the public to participate in a 30-day public review of the draft plan in both October and November.
So we will have a draft plan based on these recommendations.
I anticipate that it will be posted as part of the IQC agenda sometime in the next couple of days.
We'll present that to the IQC and then put it out for public comment.
Again, we're going to move it through the IQC because there's so much expertise.
It's just fresh there right now.
We want to make sure to leverage that.
The CDE plans to present the Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan to the board for potential adoption in March 2019.
And if the plan is adopted by the board, the superintendent will present it to the legislature on or before July 15th, 2019.
You'll be watching the live stream, won't you?
Sue's thinking about July 2019.
I remember Burr.
I'm sorry it's very late.
So, more information regarding the Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan development process, including meeting agendas and a schedule of significant events, is available on the CDE Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan webpage.
The link is here on this screen.
I am happy to entertain questions.
Board Member Williams.
When the standards committee was meeting, I was only able to attend one day of that because that was right after I had a major sports injury that required extensive surgery.
So I didn't attend all the standards meetings.
But I did attend every day of the strategic implementation committee.
work six days and And I want to thank Pam for her support I don't think I mentioned Pam in the long list of staff before but she has been supporting me on computer science and she was there for all those meetings and Barb and Is it Melanie?
Yeah, from IQC, and it was actually quite fun, in addition to being a great learning experience.
It was interesting to watch Barb facilitate.
I had never seen kind of a facilitation process exactly like that, but especially the ending of it when you were reaching consensus on what recommendations and had different cups that were going up and down.
That was a new experience for me.
I'd never done that or seen that.
I feel like I've read, of course, the recommendations.
I feel like they're very strong and cover all the stuff that needs to be covered and probably more than will ever get implemented.
But it's going to be a great document that comes back to you in March.
for adoption, for consideration of adoption as a plan.
These recommendations today are just information item.
CDE is taking these as we speak and turning them into a draft plan that will go to the IQC in three weeks, two weeks.
for approval to send out for a 30-day public comment period in October and November.
That the comment will come back to the IQC in January.
They'll decide which comments that they want to include into the plan.
It'll get finalized and it will come to you in March for consideration of adoption.
If adopted, it will then go to the legislature and it has to be there by July 15th.
2019.
So I, let me finish.
So, so I, I... Trying to get on the list.
So I, I just want to say that I think the process went really well and that the group did really great work.
They were a body of people, pretty high-powered people.
They all had an interest in computer science, but didn't come from the same perspective and experience and background.
And that always takes a while for people to kind of gel and start working together.
And they did that, thanks to Barb, very quickly and did a great job with the recommendations.
My only regret is that at this point, January is my last board meeting.
And so I'm so happy that I was here for the standards adoption.
I feel badly that I won't be here for
seeing the plan when it comes in March unless something weird happens and I need to stay over for some reason.
But otherwise, likely not.
But I will be watching the live stream from home for this agenda item and cheering for its adoption.
So, yeah, do we want to have public comment first?
Yeah, let's have public comment.
Will the following individuals please line up at the podium?
David Miyashiro, Ed Hidalgo, Tamara Otero, Deborah Richardson, Brian Dworek.
I'm David Miyashiro.
I'm the superintendent of the Colon Valley School District and also President Kirst's appointee to co-chair this panel.
I have to say, your meeting was thoroughly engaging.
And honestly, listening to board members deliberate and talk and ask questions that are smart and thoughtful and listening and empathizing with people.
We do two board meetings a week in my home district.
It was refreshing to see.
Yes.
Anyways, thank you for your volunteerism and thank you for giving your time, especially those that you're currently teaching, leading, and being in leadership roles in current school districts.
Thank you.
I also want to acknowledge Kristen and your CDE staff and the gals from WestEd.
Working with them was an absolute pleasure.
They're like word ninjas.
Everything that we said magically appeared in better form than we said it on paper.
So thank you.
Cajon Valley was actually the first school district to introduce computer science magnet schools in the country.
We're pioneers in this space.
I wrote each of you a letter, which I'll allude to tomorrow in general comments.
But what I want to leave with you today is that what we're doing in terms of standards and the plan are the equivalent of adding chairs to the deck of the Titanic.
And I'll expand on that tomorrow, but I'm concerned that we'll do more harm than good with this great work.
I'll talk to you tomorrow.
President Kirst and Board, my name is Ed Hidalgo.
I'm a Chief Innovation and Engagement Officer for the Cajon Valley Union School District.
I want to thank you for your work on the computer science standards for California.
I'm sure that my former colleagues in staffing at Apple and Tesla and Qualcomm will be very happy that our state is committed to developing a pipeline of CS professionals.
For 18 years, I worked in staffing for Manpower and Qualcomm, leading hiring teams that recruited talent, technical talent,
globally for US-based work.
Thousands of workers bleed for the United States.
The need is real.
The work that you're doing here is critically important.
But I'm now an innovation lead for a public school district in Southern California.
I bring a couple of thoughts today.
The current system is not preparing all students for the world of work.
As much as it is about what we are not providing students, it's also about what we are not taking off the plates of students and teachers.
We can't add computer science as a requirement and not consider education requirements that are no longer relevant.
It's time to redesign a system that is no longer relevant to a 21st century world of work.
Thank you.
Good evening.
Thank you for hearing us again this evening.
My name is Tamara Otero and I'm the president of the San Diego County School Board Association.
I'm also a trustee in Cajon Valley Union School District and I admire your tenacity.
Our board meetings have never ran quite this long.
Thank you to your commitment for education.
I greatly respect the work that you're doing here.
I champion the fact that California is taking the initiative to move to the 21st century with computer science standards.
It will serve all students well as it has in my district.
I do wonder though why the state continues to add one more thing without stopping to first assess the current system of requirements on LEAs and on our students.
We continue to develop new ways to measure old practices.
Why not create new practices that have built-in growth measures and build relevance into the learning processes?
Recent results from Gallup state that the most important indicators of success in K-12 education include high graduation rates, engaged cultures, and students who are hopeful about the future.
Today is what we have to make tomorrow better.
The example of revised successful education practices are available around the world.
We are not leading the nation in education.
Time.
And while CS standards are exciting, it's time to get to work on the entire framework.
Thank you.
Hi, Deborah Richardson again.
And happy, I think I might make my plane home.
Maybe.
As you know, I served as the co-chair of this panel, and I wanted to thank Superintendent Torlakson for appointing me to that important position.
I already spoke about how important computer science is for all of California's students, and that was really part of the recommendations that we wrote.
In particular, California needs to focus on increasing the participation of traditionally underrepresented groups in computer science.
Girls, students of color, students from low socioeconomic backgrounds, as well as rural and urban students.
This requires broadening the pool of teachers at all levels from kindergarten through 12th grade across the state.
and providing them with the professional learning opportunities and resources they need to learn and teach rigorous and relevant computer science that's aligned with the standards that you've just approved.
Thank you for that.
This is just an informational item, so I want to urge you to look over the recommendations that we made and be ready for the plan that comes forward in March.
And I would urge you to support that plan as well.
And thanks again for your support of Computer Science for California.
Hi, I'm Brian Twerk from SFUSD.
Thanks for adopting those standards.
That's exciting.
I also want to urge you to consider the recommendations put forth by this panel.
It's an incredible group of individuals who have diverse perspectives.
And I represent a district who's already prioritizing computer science education.
And that's manifested by me having a position dedicated to computer science education.
I want to note that as a panel we considered all the districts and schools that don't have people dedicated to that and we considered how to make this possible by considering the system as a whole.
And so the recommendations outline how this complex system can work to support the implementation of those standards and the support of our educators.
I want to thank you for that.
Okay, board member comments on this item.
Board member Burr.
So I really appreciate all the enthusiasm and the hard work that's gone on, but I'm conflicted here because I thought when we adopted the standards they were meant to be voluntary and suggestions for what might happen in LEAs in order to promote computer science.
When I read these recommendations, and I recognize they're just recommendations, it reads like one big wish list for what every content teacher would want.
and potentially the recreation of every categorical program we've ever had in California.
So two things.
I hope as they go out for comment, people will think about that.
And I think a little bit of the feedback that we were getting reflected that too, of we're just piling on, piling on.
and potentially creating a really big funding requirement or pushing for one, that we think about that in the comments.
And just specifically, Barb, you and I always have these comments, conversations about the fiscal analysis.
If you look at the item, the fiscal analysis says what the cost of the plan is, which is $261,000, which I'm sure is not even close to what it would cost us to implement this.
So when we go forward, I know that it was very narrowly focused, but I really think if you're asking the board seriously to adopt a plan for loan forgiveness, teacher training, professional development, you name it, adding a graduation requirement course, that's millions and millions of dollars.
So we need to be very clear about that so that what people are voting on, their eyes are wide open.
Thanks.
Thank you for that feedback.
Patricia Rocker.
Well, I appreciate board member Burr opening the door on that conversation because that's also the direction my comments are going to go.
And I suspect having read the letter that's coming from our co-chair, you and I are a lot closer and on the same page and you may realize.
I want to say that when I was still a classroom teacher, I was hired as a computer resource teacher and that was in the days before we had this plan, before we had standards.
concerning instruction in the K-12 classrooms.
I also worked at Sac State in the teacher education department, and I taught that one class that was required for teachers to get their credential concerning the use of computer-based instruction in their classroom.
So a lot of the things that are addressed in the standards were addressed in that class.
But a lot of the work that I did with my colleagues, not only in my school, but in schools around the district where we would sit together and figure out what we were doing and how we were trying to go about doing this and making decisions on everything from hardware to the types of software experience, software that would be adopted or considered, as well as what the instruction would look like.
Though if this plan had been in place, first of all, I probably would have been happy
because I would know that there would be some uniformity not only in our district, but across our county on the type of work we were doing.
But at the same time, the standards that we're adopting are voluntary, which meant I still had the flexibility not only to decide what I was going to be doing in my classroom as a teacher,
but also some flexibility to work with those credential candidates to help them understand how to make instructionally appropriate decisions about appropriate use and activities for computers in their classroom.
This plan takes us down a different pathway
because we move from voluntary use and implementation of the standards to something that is a much larger type of infrastructure that would be created by the state and that would do more for the profession and in the classrooms about the implementation and use of these standards.
So I have great concern about what this plan is asking us to do.
And seeing it for this very first time, I have a lot of questions that we frankly don't have enough time
to talk about and ask about today.
So I know that this was only intended to be an information item, but I am taken aback by so many things that I read and what I saw in what's being presented today that I know in March, if you think we took a lot of time on item one today,
I just want you to know you have presented information and now you're going to give me one, two, three, six months to talk, think about all the questions that I'm going to want to ask and all the concerns that I'm going to want to raise and you know I know how to do that.
So, I have some concerns about the direction the plan suggested we should take.
If I were still a classroom teacher, if I was still in that classroom teaching those students as a computer resource teacher in my district, if I was still a lecturer at CSU Sacramento, I frankly would tell you I'd have to come here and raise some very serious concerns about what this plan is suggesting that what we should be doing.
not only to prepare our profession for certification and for using these standards, but also for what it means for classroom teachers to do this as an instructional decision in their classroom.
Can I respond just a bit?
I tried to set this foundation early on because, again, the statute is pretty detailed and it is a two-part process.
The first part of the statute required in paneling 23 experts
expertise in computer science to put forth a set of recommendations.
And that's what we have today in this item.
What you have today in the item, item 8, is not a plan.
Item 8 is a set of recommendations put forth by a panel of 23 experts that the department, the superintendent, will take and turn into a plan
something for which I have a little experience.
So I hear your concerns.
I appreciate you sharing the concerns, but I think it's really important for us to differentiate between the set of recommendations that you have before you now, which does have a pretty high price tag.
But that was the cost of pulling together the set of recommendations and pulling people, right?
Versus the plan for supporting computer science.
Let me be clear.
I am not confused by what was presented to us today.
But I do know that what was presented to us today is going to inform that plan.
is going to create, it will be the construction of many of the foundational elements that we are going to see in that plan.
So, the purpose of today was only information, so we're not going to get to talk about those foundational elements.
We're not even going to get a chance to talk about as a board how the decision will be made about
How these recommendations are going to inform the plan.
We're going to hear, we just got to see the recommendations and the next time we see it, we'll be taking action on some plan that's constructed.
You won't necessarily be taking action in March.
We want to bring a draft plan to you in March.
so that you will have plenty of time to discuss that draft plan in March.
We are not required... I think my point is between now and the time we see something in March, there are going to be a lot of intervening conversations about what was presented today that I don't see where I will have an opportunity to give some, to express some concerns or give some feedback.
I think that's the point I'm trying to make.
Okay, Board Member Valdez.
Just to piggyback on that, so what's the process between now and when you bring a plan?
Who helps build that plan?
I guess that's just my question.
Thank you for that question.
So we will bring a draft plan to the IQC on September 20th.
They're having a meeting the 20th and 21st.
We're going to present it to the Educational Technology Committee.
and ask them.
We'll review it with them.
We'll get some more public comment there, maybe some preliminary comment from them.
But then we're going to go out for a 30-day public comment process in October and November.
We're going to collect the public comment on the draft plan, which is a bit different from the set of recommendations that you have before you today.
bring that public comment back to the IQC in January, they will have the opportunity to weigh in on the public comment and provide guidance to department staff around what changes ought to be made, which of those pieces of feedback as we do with frameworks and other things that we bring to the board as we did with the standards today.
And then in March, the IQC and the department will present a draft plan to the board for potential adoption.
In my experience, the first time you bring a plan to the board is not the last time you bring the plan to the board.
Because the board needs to discuss the plan and provide feedback.
There will be additional public comments at the March meeting.
It could happen.
It could be adopted in March 2019.
But we gave ourself enough leeway to bring it back again in May and potentially back again in July.
So we created this timeline for plan development.
that provides plenty of opportunities.
Today was meeting statutory requirements to impanel 23 people to inform a plan because there's a lot of computer science expertise in California that doesn't necessarily all live here in the department, right?
So we're bringing the, that's what you saw today.
Today is not a plan.
Today is recommendations to inform a plan that will have a months long process and many opportunities for board members to weigh in.
Okay, you wanted to continue.
Yeah.
So with that, I think and I'm hearing the concern of the district and being an assistant superintendent in a large district, I understand the concern.
And I think the overall overarching theme is if everything is important, then nothing is important.
And that's, I think, what the voices I'm hearing today are asking.
How do we refine, integrate?
I mean, we've truly talked about an integrated system of curriculum.
And so when could that happen?
I think that's just one thing on the horizon.
Board Member Williams.
A couple of things that relate to this.
One thing is that one item in the state board guidance to the standards committee was to provide substantive guidance while allowing for flexibility and innovation across LEAs to determine from a variety of approaches how to best incorporate computer science into their curricula based on local capacity and context.
That was written clearly to be saying these are model standards and substantive guidance, not a new requirement.
And it's been clear all along with, or at least when I'm available, I've tried to make it clear that there's no plan for a curriculum framework
which Brian addressed by saying he knew that there wasn't a plan for a curriculum framework.
So in the standards, they built in examples of how various computer science practices could be integrated because they knew there weren't going to be a curriculum framework and no plan for a state summative assessment.
Now, all that said, that was pretty, you know, I say that every time to everyone.
But you also had, for this panel, you had a lot of expertise in computer science and a large contingent of really strong advocates for expanding computer science and expanding it equitably.
And so what I would say that what you have for recommendations is a really well done wish list.
So if you were going, you know, if we could dream from the advocacy standpoint, if we could dream of what it would look like if it was all through California and done really well, here's all the policy levers.
funding, you know, dedicated funding, this, that, that could make that happen.
So if you think of it that way, they developed a really robust and smart list of all the possible things that could be done to help advance computer science.
One question I have is what it means, how to interpret.
The statute says that it goes to the board for adoption.
And if adopted, it goes to the legislature.
So in two things I want to raise.
One is it goes to the legislature, which means it goes to them as a wish list.
It goes to them, whatever's in it by the time it goes to them is here's some things that could make a difference.
But I also want to ask, encourage us to ask ourselves, what does it, what does it convey when the, if the board adopts it, the plan?
Does it sound, is that going to be interpreted by the legislature that we endorse every single item that's in it as a recommendation?
Or is that, because if that's the case,
you know, that would, you know, you would start pruning.
If it's more, we think this is a really good set of recommendations, you know, do with it, legislature and governor, what you, you know, pick the ones you think are most effective and that you want to support.
then you wouldn't have to worry about the kind of pruning you did.
But that is what the questions that you're raising about how comprehensive it is and what that cost would be and the implications of that for all the other standards we have, which, you know,
I mean, you know, I'm worried about NGSS standards.
So, you know, it also needs some extra support.
So that's, so those are two things I would just say.
Think of this as this really smart panel's list, wish list of all the things that could be done to advance this agenda.
But then the board needs to decide what does it mean if we adopt it to go over to the legislature?
How would that be interpreted?
and make sure that it's getting interpreted the way you want it to or that it has in it the things that you feel comfortable with.
If I may, to your point, the difference between the NGSS standards and the computer science standards, the computer science standards are voluntary.
And so looking at those recommendations, we just can't simply say yes and pass them on to the legislature.
There needs to be not only this plan for the work that's going to be going on going for
There needs to be some plan for how we as a policy body vet those recommendations and pass them over to the legislature.
So, I have concerns.
Can I suggest we, you know, we'll have another shot at this and it's a long day.
Maybe we could continue this in the future.
All right.
With that, I want to announce that the item 18 and the Imagine School proposal has been pulled from our agenda by the Imagine Charter School people.
And we'll do the state board priorities tomorrow, Friday.
And the board is now in continuation state.
We will continue the meeting tomorrow with our executive session to begin.
Mike, can you please announce the two cases for the executive session?
Oh, OK.
OK, our two cases are CAP EEM versus the state.
And the second case is options for youth, Burbank versus Education Audits Appeal Panel, CDE, SBE, State of California.
So the board will consider those in closed session tomorrow when we continue our meeting in the morning.
So we've lost Deborah because she had to catch a flight.
But Dean and Brian and David, if you guys want to take a photo with the resolution, then let's go do it now.